rebonjour à tous et tous on reprend avec
l'amendement du rapporteur le 1717
oui merci monsieur le Président il
s'agit par cet amendement de rajouter à
l'alinée 7 l'égalité dont en effet parmi
les principes de la République que
doivent respecter les étrangers figure
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
je vous propose d'élargir ce principe à
toutes les égalités que nous nous devons
de respecter collectivement à savoir
bien sûr l'égalité femme homme mais
également l'égalité son la religion
l'origine orentation sexuelle ou encore
l'égalité sociale contre les castes
notamment il s'agit peut-être d'une
simple précision mais elle paraît
importante pour essayer d'oublier le
moins de choses possi je le mets au voix
qui vot pour contre adopté le
450 n'est pas
défendu le suivant le 533 n'est pas
défendu 1109 pas défendu le 128 est-ce
qu'il y a un signataire oui allez-y
madame jeunev monursur vousêes pas
M le 128 de Monsieur
po défendu monsieur le
rapporteur demande de retrait parce que
l'objet de de l'amendement qui vise à
aviser les comportements est inclus dans
la rédaction
actuelle je mets VO pour qui vote contre
rejeté le suivant monsieur le rapporteur
le 1718
oui donc par cet amendement il
est pardon donc cet amendement qui a été
mis en place par le Sénat et donc par
cet amendement il vis à supprimer la
compétence liée du préfet qui a souhaité
introduire en séance le Sénat enfin
selon un argument que j'ai déjà employé
il est important de maintenir la
capacité d'appréciation du préfet de
limiter au maximum les compétences liées
de façon à respecter le principe de
l'appréciation in cononcretto de chaque
situation madame
jeunbard merci monsieur le
Président alors c'est l'objet d'un de
mes amendements et de deux amendements
de monsieur
sooti nous nous considérons que le peu
est prive finalement le préfet d'un
pouvoir de de
décision en la matière et que c'est
c'est regrettable il doit pouvoir le
préfet retirer une carte de séjour
temporaire ou plur annuel dès lors que
l'étranger constitue une menace à
l'ordre public alors je ne comprends pas
monsieur le rapporteur dès lors que dans
le
texte il est spécifié que la vie du
préfet doit être fondée sur une décision
motivée ce n'est pas un pouvoir
discrétionnaire affranchi de tout et
puis on peut faire confiance à nos
préfets pour respecter tout de même le
droit donc dès lors qu'elle est que la
décision est motivée pourquoi ne pas
avoir une formule plus plus
affirmative la carte de séjour
temporaire ou plus pluriannuelle et par
une décision motivée retiré à tout
étranger dont la présence en France
constitue une menace pour l'ordre
public monsieur
rapporteur allez-y
alle-y merci oui oui effectivement vous
avez euh bien sûr posé très correctement
les les termes du débat mais
l'appréciation que doit porter le préfet
justement pour cela que euh l'amendement
que je dépose vise à rétablir sa
capacité d'appréciation et un pouvoir
qui n'est certainement pas un pouvoir
discrétionnaire mais pas un pouvoir
automatique non plus et c'est justement
par cette rédaction la possibilité de
permettre au préfet d'apprécier les
circonstan qui euh l'autoriseront et qui
lui permettront de justifier sous le
contrôle du juge l'attribution ou ou pas
du titre éventuellement contesté la
rédaction telle qu'elle est issue
actuellement des travaux du Sénat et qui
n'était pas la rédaction initiale déposé
dans le projet du gouvernement créer une
compétence automatique sur lequel je ne
vois pas où pourrait s'exercer le
pouvoir d'appréciation du préfet qui
serait dans une compétence liée la seule
appréciation du préfet qui resterait
serait sur le contenu des circonstances
qui me paraît plus robuste juridiquement
et constitutionnellement de recréer ce
pouvoir entre les mains du préfet madame
jeunevard prend votre quand je lis votre
exposé des motifs monsieur le le
rapporteur général euh vous dites il
apparaît nécessaire que le préfet
dispose d'une pleine capacité
d'appréciation de chaque situation mais
n'est-ce pas précisément garanti par la
formulation
euh par une décision motivée dès lors
qu'elle est motivée ça veut dire qu'il a
exercé sa pleine capacité d'appréciation
de chaque situation c'est ça que je ne
comprends pas parce que euh malgré tout
la formule peu est une formule qui
dégrade les marges de manœuvre du préfet
or si j'ai bien compris la philosophie
de ce texte c'est précisément de
redonner des marges de de de
d'appréciation et et du pouvoir contre
ceux qui menacent l'ordre public ça
n'est pas rien quand même une menace de
l'ordre contre l'ordre public et donc je
trouve que votre votre exposé des motifs
sert plutôt ma vision des choses qu'elle
ne défend la vôtre si je puis me
permettre monsieur le rapporteur je vais
mettre au voix l'amendement de monsieur
le rapporteur qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est adopté il fait tomber
l'article l'amendement pardon 1376 de
Monsieur Mandon le
374 monsieur gilet
défendu monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable défavorable qui vote pour
qui vote contre rejeté monsieur
rapporteur le 1710
19 merci monsieur le Président c'est cet
amendement vise en fait à supprimer le
caractère facultative de l'existence
d'un trouble à l'ordre public pour
caractériser l'atteinte au principes de
la République qui avait été introduit
par le Sénat il paraît important que que
cette appréciation ne relève pas de d'un
caractère facultatif mais qu'il y ait
véritablement une existence un trouble à
l'ordre public pour permettre au préfet
d'exercer pleinement ses droits dans le
cadre du pouvoir discrétionnaire que
nous venons de lui rétablir je vois qui
vote pour qui vote contre adopté euh qui
défend le l'amendement 436 monsieur
gilet
oui les les principes é dictés à
l'article 412-8 relèv du bon sens et
leur non respect par l'étranger signifie
que celui-ci ne doit pas se maintenir
sur notre territoire permettre à
l'autorité administrative de nier la
condition de gravité alors même qu'une
atteinte à l'exercice des droits et des
libertés mentionnées au premier Alinat
est caractérisé ouvre donc une brèche
qui risque de rendre cet article
inopérant dans les faits par ailleurs
cet article ne résout nullement la
problématique des étrangers rejetant nos
valeurs et les droits et libertés
fondamentales de la Nation pour ces deux
raisons cet amendement propose d'écarter
l'autorité administrative de
l'appréciation de la condition de
gravité mais également d'étendre la
présempption de gravité aux appels à
atteindre au principes édictés au
premier alinéat de l'article
42-8 défavorable car les situations
visées sont déjà traité par les les
textes existants et et en supprimant la
capacité d'appréciation on fragilise
considérablement le dispositif je mets
au voix qui vote pour contre rejeté le
suivant Madame
Dupont merci monsieur le Président il
s'agit d'un amendement travaillé avec la
Fédération des acteurs de la solidarité
par ma collègue Marjoline mier milfer
qui vise à introduire la possibilité de
retirer un titre de séjour qui vise à
supprimer justement la possibilité
de retirer un titre de séjour à un
réfugié résidant régulièrement en France
depuis plus de 5 ans lorsqu'il est
volontairement retourné dans son pays
d'origine monsieur le rapporteur oui je
vous remercie de de cette présentation
alors il y a un effet de bord dans le
dans l'amendement que vous présentez
c'est pour cela que je vous demanderai
de le retirer parce qu'en effet en
supprimant les alignéats 17 et 18 vous
visez à la fois les personnes qui ont
perdu leur statut de réfugié également
celles qui sont retourné volontairement
dans leur pays mais également qui
demeure présente et qui constitue une
menace à l'ordre public donc du fait de
de la rédaction de l'amendement qui qui
fragilise cette dimension je suis amené
à vous demander de le retirer Madame
Dupont je vais proposer à ma collègue
effectivement d'ajuster la rédaction
donc je le retire madame Diaz pour le de
429 monsieur gilet pour le 429
oui dans dans la continuité de de
l'entretien accordé au JDD en août 2022
par le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
d'Anin lequel a affirmé qu'un étranger
qui commet un acte délinquence grave
doit être expulsé très vite parce qu'il
crache sur le sol qu'il l'accueille le
rassemblement national considère que
tout étranger qui constitue une menace
pour l'ordre public doit être expulsé du
territoire national tout simplement
parce que la France subit assez de
délinquant etette criminalité pour
endosser celle d'une population
étrangère euh au-delà des faits tirés de
la plus incontestable objectivité des
des organismes ministériels 88 % des
Français sont favorables à la
facilitation de l'expulsion des
étrangers en situation irrégulière en
cas de non respect des principes de la
République euh il est temps donc de
permettre l'éloignement des étrangers
qui constitue une menace pour l'ordre
public c'est ce que prévoit cet
amendement je vous
remercie monsieur rapporteur avis
défavorable en effet supprimer la
qualification de gravité de la menace
pour l'ordre public afin de permettre la
mise en œuvre de l'article 13 est
nécessaire c'est jugé de façon constante
depuis 1997 par le Conseil
constitutionnel et c'est une bonne chose
que c'est un point
d'équilibre je voix qui vote pour qui
vote contre
rejeté le
suivant monsieur Dumont vous n'êtes pas
signataire
461 vous êtes signataire du
471 je vous en
prie le président alors c'est un
amendement de
Monsieur Je vous R à l'alinéa 23 que dit
cet alinéa le renouvellement d'une carte
de séjour pluriannuelle peut par une
décision motivée être refuser si
l'étranger ne peut pas prouver qu'il a
établi en France sa résidence habituelle
donc là même chose dès lors que la
décision du préfet est motivée dès lors
que l'étranger ne peut pas prouver qu'il
a établi sa résidence habituelle en
France quel problème y a-t-il à ce que
on utilise une tour
plus
affirmative et remplacer ces mots peu
par si
l'étranger
prouve
pardon le renouvellement d'une carte de
séjour
pluriannuel est refusé si l'étranger ne
peut pas prouver qu'il a établi sa
résidence habituelle parce que
franchement je ne comprends
pas
j'irais même jusqu'à dire votre
frilosité à acceptter que les choses
soient dites clairement et que les
préfets a tous les moyens d'agir comme
il se doit c'est la doudoune du du
rapporteur qui vous inspire ce terme
certainement allez monsieur rapporteur
certainement mais venant de Nice comme
d'autres députés d'ailleurs je suis
parfois un peu frileux non je je
plaisante c'est pardon de ne pas avoir
d'arguments peut-être plus plus
pertinents ou plus convainquants et je
le regrette par rapport au fait de
préserver la la compétence
enfin le pouvoir discrétionnaire du
préfet et donc maintenir le peu je
rajouterai juste un point par rapport à
l'événement que vous avez soulevé je
pense que légistiquement lorsqu'on
rédige un impératif au
présent et qu'on indique par ailleurs
que la décision est motivée je pense que
la motivation ne peut porter que sur la
décision compéten liée et non pas sur
l'opportunité ou pas de prendre la
décision donc à ce titre pense que si on
veut que la décision soit vraiment
motivée qu'on en connaisse les raisons
il vaut mieux avoir cette possibilité
donc cette compétence laissé au
préfet je mets au voix l'amendement qui
vote pour qui vote contre rejeté le
suivant est un amendement Mons diilippo
qui n'est pas défendu on arrive au 1056
de Monsieur SETI donc c'est madame
jeevard qui peut le défendre défendu
monsieur le rapporteur défavorable
défavorable qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeter alors là on a une série
je crois que c'est un nouveau 14
amendement de Madame Antoine qui ne peut
malheureusement pas les défendre et
Madame Genevard on arrive au
976 on est très déçu je dire
976 défendu monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable parce que j'ai confiance
dans les préfets je le mets au voix qui
vote pour qui vote contre il est rejeté
euh il n'y a pas de défenseur du 27
et on arrive au 1720 monsieur le
rapporteur
oui un amendement qui est quasiment un
amendement de cohérence puisque les
titulaires de la carte annuelle
passeport talent n'ont pas ét soumis à
la condition de résidence habituelle en
France ça n'aurait pas de sens car ils
AV voocation à être mobile c'est
l'objectif de ce titre et c'est aussi un
enjeu d'attractivité pour notre pays
donc je suis favorable à mon propre
amendement que je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est
adopté le suivant pas défendu le 626 euh
le 1121 madame yousoufa merci monsieur
le Président alors cet amendement vise à
considérer comme résident en France de
manière habituelle l'étranger qui
séjourne pendant 9 mois et non plus 6
comme proposé par le projet de loi je
vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur ce
merci beaucoup ce délai de 6 mois est
habituel et d'ailleurs sur tout un tas
d'autres sujets notamment la notion de
résidence fiscale la notion de résidence
retenue par le code de la sécurité
sociale c'est pour ça que nous pensons
opportun de conserver ce délai de 6 mois
je le mets au voix qui vote pour qui
vote contre rejeté le suivant à celui de
Monsieur pojet euh madame jeunevard vous
êtes
signateur merci monsieur le Président
cet amendement de Monsieur
poet vise à rétablir la possibilité de
pouvoir refuser la délivrance d'une
carte de séjour pluri-annuelle à un
étranger en situation régulière en
France si ce dernier a manifesté le
rejet des valeurs essentielles de la
société française et de la
République j'ai un amendement identique
pour le groupe rassemblement national
qui le
défend défendu monsieur le
rapporteur
allez-y mais décidément qu'est-ce qui
pique le
micro c'est bon je ne vais pas crier à
la censure donc la suppression de cette
alinéa n'a pas peut-être contrairement à
la lecture que vous en faites le pour
objet d'empêcher le refus de délivrance
d'une carte de séjour pluannuelle en cas
rejet principes de la République qu'il
s'agit plutôt d'une mesure de
coordination rédactionnelle de façon à
éviter que le czda retienne des formules
différentes sur la question des
principes et parce que la mention nous
paraissait redondante par rapport au
reste de l'article 13 d'ailleurs des
suppressions similaires ont été prévu
aux alinéat 15 et 16 de l'article 13
mais si je peux vous rassurer et donc
vous demandz de retirer les amendements
le refus de délivrer une CSP en cas de
rejet des principes de la République de
même que le refus de son renouvellement
ou son retrait sont prévus dans le
nouvel article L 412-7 et suivant du C
identique qui vote pour je vous ai pas
vu madame Martin allez-y
parlez pourraitattirer à nouveau si
besoin était votre attention sur le fait
qu'il faut en creux puisque là c'est en
creux être prudent quant aux formules
qui sont très vagues et qui ouvrent la
porte à
l'arbitraire je sais pas par exemple
imaginez qu'on a un ministre dans des
fonctions très importantes et qui soi
blanchies bon ça pourrait faire partie
de surcroix de du non respect des
principes de la République vous voyez ce
que je veux vous dire donc il y a une
question il y a une question
d'interprétation il y a une question
d'interprétation qui peut jouer derrière
ça et qui ouvre la porte à l'arbitraire
et en tout cas c'est bien sr vécu comme
tel ça arrange pas nos
affaires je mets au voix l'amendement
qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté l'article 13 qui vote pour
l'article 13 vote
contre alors attendez parce que vous
avez tous voté en même temps donc qui
vote pour l'article 13 voilà qui vote
contre l'article 13 il est donc adopté
après l'article 13 monsieur
Marcangeli merci monsieur le Président
bon cette amendement une forme de
rétablissement de la justice si je puis
me permettre puisque si une personne a
des dettes non soldées je pense et je
pense que il est normal de le penser
d'ailleurs que tant que cette dette
auprès d'un hôpital d'une contravention
non réglée n'est pas réglée que ce
dernier ne peut pas obtenir un visa
court ou long séjour tant qu'il n'a pas
remboursé cette dette donc c'est un
amendement de mon groupe qui connaît
l'engagement des personnels des
autorités diplomatiques et consulaires
et il faut leur donner les moyens
d'avoir accès à ce type d'information
afin qu'elle puisse refuser l'octroi
d'un visa tant que le demandeur ou la
demandeesse n'a pas réglé sa dette
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez deux
sous-amendements oui absolument deux
amendements de de précision deux
sous-amendements de précision pardon le
premier qui prévoit mais ça je ne
surprendrai personne que c'est une
possibilité offerte c'est-à-dire de ne
pas avoir une compétence liée des
autorités amenées à délivrer le visa et
le deuxième point c'est de préciser les
créancières dont la dont l'existence de
dette à leur égard peut limiter ce
pouvoir de délivrance d'un visa par les
autorités
consulaires alors le les premiers
sousamendes du rapporteur le 1748 qui
vote pour qui vote contre adopté le
deuxème sousamendement de monsieur le
rapporteur le 1768 qui vote pour contre
adopté l'amendement de Monsieur
Marcangeli sous-amendé qui vote pour qui
vote
contre adopté vous êtes vu madame regole
monsieur Dumont pour l'amendement de
Monsieur camardine Merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement prend un peu la
même veine de l'amendement qu'on avait
adopté avant la pause déjeuner et
consiste à faire en sorte de demander à
un étranger qui désire demander un visa
et se voir délivrer un visa par nos
autorités consulaires de respecter sur
l'honneur l'intégrité territoriale de la
République ça fait évidemment écho à la
situation de mayott vous l'avez bien
compris
oui j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer
lors de l'examen de l'amendement de
Monsieur camardine de Madame yousoufa
auquel j'avais donné un avis favorable
donc ce qui me permettra de d'exprimer
une demande de retrait parce que je
pense que la modification l'article 13
répond très largement à ce sujet en plus
là la rédaction peut inclure y compris
des vodes de très courte durée ce qui
peut créer une
difficulté je mets donc au voix qui vote
pour contre
rejeté article 13 V des amendements de
suppression monsieur le rapporteur
oui alors là aussi pas de méprise sur le
la dimension d'amendement de suppression
parce qu' effffectivement cette
disposition qui concerne les outreses
plus sa place dans le titre 6 et je
propose donc qu'elle soit débatue et
discuté à l'occasion d'amendements qui
et d'articles qui seront présentés par
mon excellent collègue Olivier
serv j'ai un amendement de Monsieur
Vallot
également un amendement de Madame Rego
ou monsieur Lucas défendu de Madame
alors madame pas vous êtes favorable à
votre amendement monsieur le rapporteur
je présume je mets au voix qui vote pour
contre adopté il supprime l'article 13
bis après l'article 13 bis madame Martin
l'amendement
alors
euh donc nous nous considérons que
l'entrée en France entre guillemets par
une sélection par par l'argent euh ne
nous paraît pas ne nous paraît pas être
une bonne chose cela signifie qu'on
ajoute encore des empêchements et des et
des conditions ou qu'on ajoute ou qu'on
conserve bien sûr ça dépend de quoi de
quoi on parle donc nous ne sommes pas en
accord avec cela ce d'autant plus que ça
un caractère
relatif là aussi que il n'est pas
toujours simple d'apporter d'une façon
formelle la preuve de cette contribution
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
ne voulons pas que il y ait un obstacle
supplémentaire à la régularisation
monsur le
rapporteur l'entretien de l'enfant est
une condition nécessaire et
indissociable pardon de celle tenant à
l'éducation à l'accompagnement de
l'enfant c'est le devoir qu'exerce tout
parent codifieré mais en était-il besoin
l'article 371-2 du Code civil mais donc
aujourd'hui le retirer pour un ou deux
parents paraît particulièrement
difficile par parce que je pense que
l'autorité parental le devoir nous av
àgard des enfants comme la République ne
se divise pas
oui on est bien d'accord c'est la raison
pour laquelle ça nous paraî être
superflu et dans un certain nombre de
conditions difficile finalement à
identifier surtout si l'on parle d'une
contribution financière isolable après
on peut donner les factures de cantine
mais voyez ce que je veux
dire je le mets au voix qui vot pour
Quiot contre
rejeté amendement suivant monsieur
48 merci Monsieur le le président
demande de suppression de l'article 14a
qui prévoit un net durcissement de la
délivrance des de visas ainsi qu'une
restriction de l'aide au développement
envers les étapes coopératifs en matière
migratoire verser davantage chez le pays
collabore en matière de réadmission ou
de contrôle des frontières reviendrait à
détourner cette tête de son objectif
initial de réduction de la pauvreté
c'est l'article 208 du traité de
fonctionnement de de l'Union européenne
rien de moins la condition la
conditionnalité pardon de l'aide
publique au développement à la
coopération migratoire des pays tiers va
à l'encontre des principes d'efficacité
de l'aide consigné dans la Déclaration
de Paris le programme d'action d'Akra le
partenariat de Buan et celui de de
Nairobi dont la France est signataire et
nous nous croyons que la signature de la
France l'engage et vaut notamment dans
nos
discussions l'AM de Monsieur pcher n'a
pas de défenseur madame Martin ou
monsieur monsieur LAN
allez-y merci monsieur le Président un
amendement de suppression de cet article
14a ajouté par le Sénat qui prévoit de
subordonner l'aide au développement des
pays à la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière c'est quand même je sais pas
comment dire ça de manière polie mais
c'est quand même une idée un peu étrange
que de se dire que l'aide au
développement qui précisément permet
normalement de faire en sorte que que il
y ait pas de problème de développement
dans les pays qu'on participe au
développement des pays et donc d'une
certaine manière que l'on permette aux
gens de pouvoir vivre et travailler dans
leur pays puisse être désormais
subordonné au fait que ces pays luttent
contre l'immigration irrégulière ça ne
prend pas en compte la question de de de
ces états ça ne prend pas en plus non
plus en compte la question des échanges
commerciaux que nous pouvons avoir avec
un certain nombre de ces pays et d'une
certaine manière je l'ai déjà dit mais
si vous voulez parler d'immigration et
de migration d'une manière correcte il
faudra à un moment donné aussi se poser
la question du capitalisme et de la
manière dont certains dans certains pays
nous participons à l'épuisement des
matières premières par exemple monsieur
valallot ce sera moi monsieur le
présidentciame
Ki tout me plaît tant qu'elle est
défendu je vous remercie alors cet
article
14a subordonne la délivrance de visa
à une espèce de
conditionnalité nous luttons contre
l'immigration
et en gros on donne des visas que si le
pays du du demandeur de visa laisse
donne des laisser passer consulaires le
visa consulaire ce qu'il faut rappeler
rappelle rapidement c'est le retour au
pays d'un immigré d'un d'un sans papier
délinquant aujourd'hui vous êtes en
train de poser une espèce de
chantage une conditionnalité qui est
insupportable moi je j'aimerais réécrire
cet article et j'aimerais vous proposer
plutôt ce ce chantage uniquement avec
les dirigeants des
pays ne pas accorder de visa à un
dirigeant de pays si ce pays ne laisse
ne donne pas de laisser passer
consulaire là c'est une bonne solution
donc nous demandons la suppression de
cet
article le alors 1694 va pas de
défenseur le 1433 madame Dupon merci
monsieur le Président euh le
conditionnement de la délivrance de visa
ou de l'aide publique au développement à
la coopération en matière de délivrance
de laisser passer consulaire constiue un
nonsens selon moi il impacte en effet
les personnes souhaitant voyager étudier
ou travailler dans notre pays sans peser
en définitive de manière concrète sur
les relations diplomatiques entre le
pays concerné et la France et c'est vrai
que ciblé comme le disait à l'instant ma
collègue sur les responsables du pays
d'origine qui euh s'oppose à la
délivrance de pass de laisser passer
consulaire serait certainement plus
pertinent que un
conditionnement large en définitive qui
peut être contre-productif par rapport
au développement du pays en en question
donc il me semble qu'il convient de
supprimer cet
article madame
e oui merci Monsieur le le président en
effet cet article est introduit par les
sénateurs des républicains au Sénat euh
est assez étrange je dois dire même
qu'il relève d'une certaine incohérence
dans la parole des républicains euh
parce qu'effectivement nous sommes
étonnés euh que les euh sénateurs et
députés des républicains ont sionné
l'ensemble des ambassades euh pour
critiquer les mesures qui ont été prises
en 2020 euh monsieur sooti lui-même est
allé critiquer euh la mesure qui avait
été prise par le ministre de l'Intérieur
lors de ses voyages auprès notamment des
Marocains euh et euh il s'agit là de
savoir si les parlementaires des
républicains sont des parlementaires des
ambassades ou de l'Assemblée nationale
euh j'espère qu'il adopterons les cet
amendement de de suppression parce que
nous pensons que les visas et l'aide au
développement sont des éléments de
rayonnement de la France ils sont
centraux dans les relations
diplomatiques et il ne me paraît pas
opportun de les inclure dans une
condition ialité de la politique
migratoire et si vous le permettez
monsieur le Président je défendrai aussi
le
1588 après en tout cas pas dans celle
discussion alors juste pour conclure je
sais que monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur a pris cette décision en
2020 vous avez qu'un secondes
systématiquement en plus madame Martin
donc c'est pas la peine de contester les
décisions
systématiquement voilà monsieur le
rapporteur mer merci monsieur le
Président quelques instants pour
apporter des des éléments de réponse
pour étayer mon avis défavorable à ces
amendements de suppression d'abord le le
premier point c'est que ce qui est
décrit c'est-à-dire à savoir créer une
une conditionnalité ou du moins indiquer
une
direction en matière de de lien entre
les laisser passer consulaires et les
visas est une pratique dont la
diplomatie française et la politique
migratoire française ont besoin et je
crois que même si dans la lecture que
j'ai des institutions de la 5e
République la politique diplomatique de
notre pays n'est pas conduite par le
Parlement même si elle est débatue au
Parlement il n'en demeure pas moins que
nous devons apporter des signaux et
apporter le soutien ce qui nous paraît
important et à ce titre je trouve que le
contenu de cet amendement qui subordonne
la délivrance des vis plutôt qu' lit la
délivrance des visa la coopération en
matière de laisser passer consulaire est
un élément important parce que nous
avons vu et nous avons pu constater dans
le passé que le fait de disposer de cet
outil permet d'amener à la coopération
un certain nombre d'États qui ont
parfois besoin et je ne souscrit pas du
tout le terme de chantage parce que je
pense que la notion de chantage pourrait
donner l'impression qu'il y a une une
force ou un un tribunal de l'opinion
public plus fort que ça mais les états
quand ils sont dans une relation
diplomatique ont besoin parfois de dire
et d'exprimer fortement leur position
afin que l'autre l'entende et sache la
prendre en compte dans la mesure où il
estime que ça présente plus davantage
que d'intérêt la diplomatie c'est aussi
un sujet de rapport de force je rappelle
que on a une statistique qui n'est quand
même pas bonne un 53,7 % des laisser
passer consulair ont été obtenu dans un
délai utile pour permettre l'exécution
des mesures augmenter ce ce ratio nous
permettrait certainement d'avoir un
meilleur taux d'exécution deuxième point
concernant l'aide publique au
développement là je ferai référence à
l'audition que nous avons eu avec
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur aux migration
Christophe léonzi il a dit que c'était
une donnée impérative et que la lutte
contre les migrations c'est-à-dire en
fait le développement dans les pays dont
partent les population migrante est un
élément important de l'aide publique au
développement et que c'est pour eux
important de voir que cet objectif est
partagé par le Parlement donc il s'agit
non pas du tout là de créer un chantage
mais bien au contraire de réaffirmer
quelque chose d'important à savoir que
l'aide publique au développement a aussi
et doit avoir pour objet de permettre
aux populations de continuer à vivre
travailler se développer dans des pays
plutôt que de l'équité vers le nôtre à
ce titre et pour cette raison de
justification j'ai met un avis
défavorable à ces amendements de
suppression alors madame Youfa ah pardon
monsieur le ministre avant
pardon
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président moi aussi je veux donner un
avis défavorable aux am de suppression
parce que je pense qu'il faut que on
regarde exactement quel est l'article de
ce texte à quoi ça sert et et qu'est-ce
que font nos collègues européens
l'article de ce texte il prévoit pas que
nous donnons pas de visa si il n'y a pas
de laisser passer il dit que l'État peut
ne pas donner de visa s'il n'y a pas de
laisser passer c'est pas une obligation
c'est pas une injonction au gouvernement
c'est une possibilité laisser à l'état
et c'est très important parce que je
vous parleris de mon expérience
puisque cela a été évoqué mon expérience
avec de négociations avec les États
étrangers pour le retour de leurs
compatriotes et singulièrement pour le
retour de leurs compatriotes qui doivent
être expulsés pour des raisons d'ordre
public c'est qu'en général ils vous
disent mais écoutez nous on est là pour
appliquer les règles d'un État souverain
bien évidemment mais rien dans le droit
français ne permet de faire ce que vous
faites c'est-à-dire comme le président
de la République l'a fait je je le
rappelle quand même bah on arrête un
certain nombre ou on diminue un certain
nombre de visa en échange d'une reprise
de nos discussions consulaires il y a
des pays avec lequels ça marche les pays
avecquels ça marche pas et je pense que
il faut regarder aussi ce qui marche ça
marche avec beaucoup de pays d'Afrique
ça marche avec ça marche avec les
Comores ça marche avec des pays d'Asie
et on peut comprendre la rétisence de
certains pays de récupérer une partie de
le ressortissant quand les États
étrangers c'est souvent le cas avec
l'Asie par exemple aussi avec l'Amérique
nous appelle pour dire voilà on va vous
renvoyer euh un tueur euh ou un
pédophile bah je mets un petit peu de
temps avant de dire oui c'est normal
c'est pas obligatoire mais je demande
s'il est bien français et en général
j'essaye parce que c'est quelque chose
assez logique j'essaie de négocier
quelque chose d'autre c'est c'est la
relation entre les États ils sont faits
d'intérêt ils ne sont pas fait seulement
de de grandeur d'âme et et de biéance
ces relations entre les États et
d'ailleurs la la relation consulaire
elle est le cas dans un ensemble de
relations diplomatiqu et il y a des
moments où on peut comprendre que malgré
les difficultés consulaires on continue
des relations diplomatiques pour des
raisons raisons qui sont notamment qui
relèv de la lutte contre le terrorisme
ou qui relèv des des puissances
économiques ou culturelles que l'on doit
avoir et puis il y a des moments où on
peut mettre ça dans la balance donc moi
je dis au parlementaires que supprimer C
article 14a c'est affaiblir la position
de la France c'est affaiblir la position
du ministère de l'Intérieur dans ces
négociations le deuxème sujet d'abord
c'est de vous dire que c'est une arme
qu'utilise également l'Union européenne
et je crois que on peut a se le dire
l'Union européenne elle l'utilise avec
la Gambie avec l'Irak nous utilisons en
commun tous les pays européens on s'est
mis d'accord pour queon ne donne pas de
laisser passer de visa s'il n'y a pas de
laisser passer consulaire avec des pays
et c'est toute l'Union européenne qui le
fait ce serait quand même assez étonnant
que la France se prive de de cette arme
diplomatique diplomatique là
troisièmement et je pense que ça c'est
aussi un point très très important on a
une une question qui qui est assez forte
finalement c'est celle qu'à posé la
commission des affaires étrangères et
moi je je donnerai par ailleurs des avis
favorables aux amemant de la commission
des affaires étrangères et je pense que
si on peut regarder en effet la question
des passeports diplomatiques et des
dirigeants il ne faut pas faire
abstraction de la population puisque
c'est par la population que souvent les
pressions politiques se font sur les
dirigeants je terminerai par dire que
cette application de qtf c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que c'est le premier
article sans doute de ce titre c'est
l'une des clés de bataille d'ailleurs ça
a été dit et redit par beaucoup de
groupes politiques s'il n'y a pas de
relation diplomatique de rapport de
force avec ces pays nous ne pourrons pas
appliquer les reconduites à la frontière
parce que si le pays refuse de recevoir
cette personne on va pas prendre un
avion et envoyer quelqu'un au-dessus
d'un aéroport si on peut pas s'y poser
et descendre les personnes qui avec
lesquelles nous souhaitons avoir des
relations diplomatiques si on n'a pas
des relations diplomatiques qui sont
fondées sur le rapport de force aussi et
surtout parce que ça fait plaisir à
personne de recevoir des personnes qui
ont été délinquantes ou criminelles et
qui appartiennent de leur à leur
nationalité alors nous nous privons
d'appliquer les eqtf on se on se coupe
un bras alors moi je con st y compris
sur le deuxième point parce qu'il y a
deux sujets dans cet article il y a un
sujet qui relève du laisser passer
consulaire vis-à-vis des visas et puis
il y a et d'ailleurs qui qui le dit
expressément ne respectant pas un accord
bilatéral c'estàd que c'est si le pays
ne respecte pas l'accord qu'il a signé
c'est pas une forme d'opposition bê et
méchant de la France d'autres pays c'est
un pays qui a signé quelque chose et qui
ne le respecte pas c'est le cas du
Traité des traités que nous avons avec
les pays du Maghreb par exemple bah
voilà c'est ça me paraît assez clair
qu'il faut respecter la parole et ou les
modifications de sa parole lorsquils ont
été dans comme un accord avec les États
étrangers il y a un deuxième point qui
est celui de l'aide au développement là
aussi l'aide au développement il n'est
pas si je le lis clairement c'est pas
une obligation c'est l'état s'il ne
respecte pas un accord bilatéral ou
multilatéral euh alors on pourrait
éventuellement bon ben je pense que
c'est pas non plus tout à fait délirant
d'autant plus que je le rappelle au
parlementaire que le le propre la propre
loi de la parce que la a augmenté
de manière considérable dans notre pays
à 0,55 % du du PIB il y avait dans le
conseil de défense qui a présidé à ces
augmentations très importantes
budgétaires évidemment le
conditionnement avec le des pays avec
lequels nous avons des relations
diplomatiques classiques dont font
partie les relations consulaires donc
cet article 14a il est extrêmement
nécessaire à la politique d'application
de nos reconduites à la frontière parce
que ça ça fait plaisir à personne de
parler d'immigration quand on a des
relations diplomatiques c'est assez rare
en tout cas s'il n'y a pas évidemment la
possibilité de de pouvoir conditionner
un C nombre d'action alors on va
continuer malheureusement et ce sera la
première fois dans le droit français que
nous le ferions à ne se priver et de
pouvoir avoir cette armes pour appliquer
notre politique
migratoire alors madame
yousoufa effectivement il me semble
important de rappeler le dans le
contexte des relations entre la France
et les Commores lors de l'opération
wambouchou cet été et comp tenu du
chantage migratoire exercé par Moroni
euh non seulement les autorités
comorienne ont dénoncé l'accord France
Comore signé en 2019 qui validait le
retour des des personnes comoriennes en
situation irrégulière à Mayotte elles
ont suspendu le retour et elles ont
encouragé les Comoriens à arriver par
bateau à Mayotte et jusqu'à ce
que le ministre ici présent et les
autorités françaises fassent peser une
menace concrète d'arrêter de délivrer
des visas c'est la seule chose qui a
fait plier le président
en l'occurrence je pense qu'il est
important dans un contexte de menace et
de chantage migratoire de donner à notre
état tous les moyens légaux et il me
semble que c'est un message important
que doit envoyer la représentation
nationale je vous remercie monsieur
gilet
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre quand on parle d'immigration
massive il faut que les Français
comprennent qu'il y a à la fois le
problème évidemment des frontières
grande ouvertes qui font que nous ne
maîtrisons plus rien mais que il y a
également effectivement le problème du
retour au pays des personnes qui n'ont
pas vocation à être sur le sol national
et en la matière c'est vrai que le
problème des expulsions relève
principalement du fait que les pays
d'origine n'acceptent pas leurs
ressortissant et ne délivre pas à la
France les laisser passer consulaires et
nous le proposons depuis longtemps avec
Marine Le Pen il y a nécessité de rendre
de rendre systématique et bien le la sup
des visas aux ressortissants des pays
qui n'acceptent pas de livvrer s laisser
passer consulaire mais également de
couper l'ensemble des aides au
développement et autres aide indirectes
international c'est pas acceptable il
faut se faire respecter il faut bien que
l'on comprenne que si la France ne tap
pas du point sur la table elle ne se
fera plus respecter et moi je voudrais
qu'on aille plus loin que ce que dit
monsieur le ministre que ce ne soit pas
seulement avec les pays avec lesquels on
a des accords mais que l'on généralise
ces sanctions qui sont
nécessaires oui la l'approche incitative
positive ou négative implique une
relation inégale entre les pays qui va à
l'encontre d'une démarche partenariale
et renforce des rapports de de
domination préexistant cette vision peut
avoir des effets contreproductifs sur
les sur les déplacements de population
et nourrir le le ressentiment de la
population de ces pays à l'égard des
États européens et et de la France une
politique restrictive en matière de visa
sert bien souvent à je met des
guillemets punir un étattiers dont la
coopération diplomatique dans un domaine
n'a pas été apprécié pourtant les
premières personnes à pâtir de la
situation sont les populations elles-mêm
dont les projets d'études de visite à
des proches ou de rapprochement familial
sont mises en en péril dans certains
pays cela provoque le départ par des
voies irrégulières et potentiellement
dangereuses de personnes qui avaient
vocation à emprunter des voies sûres et
légales de de migration la politique
restrictive en matière d'octroit de de
visa peut avoir des conséquences pour
conséquence de renforcer des filières
d'arnaque au visa ou de trait des
personnes désireuses de de se rendre en
France donc il nous paraît quand même
nécessaire de de supprimer cet
article monsieur Dumont
pour les républicains on a besoin
d'avoir des moyens de pression pour
exécuter les qtf obtenir et laisser
passer consula par de biais la
restriction des visas en particulier
pour les dirigeants et la limitation des
aides publiques au développement c'est
une question de respect pour le
contribuable français on a augmenté
l'aide publique au développement vers
les pays étrangers et donc on doit au
contribuable le fait de ne pas garder
sur notre territoire des personnes que
nous souhaitons éloigner par tous les
moyens prenons l'exemple de l'Albanie
l'Albanie qui vient d'entrer depuis 2019
avec l'Agence française pour le pour le
développement 6833 qtf prononcé 1882
exécuté 5660 demandeurs d'asile la Côte
d'Ivoire 3 milliards d'euros engagés par
la FD en Côte d'Ivoire en 2022 c'était
4629 auqtf prononcés 126 exécutés et
5800 demandeur d'asile le Bangladesh
1,14 milliards d'euros engagés depuis
2013 45 auqtf exécuté sur les 5720
prononcé et pour répondre à Madame e qui
nous a accusé tous les mots sur la
restriction des visas par rapport au
pays du Magre b nous dénoncions avant
toute chose le fait de mettre dans le
même sac le Maroc et l'Algérie alors que
le Maroc délivrait deux fois plus de
laisser passer consulaire que l'Algérie
c'est cela que nous dénonçons
contrairement à ce que vous laissez
faire croire merci Monsieur Merci
monsieur le Président j'interviens en
tant que rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des affaires étrangères cet
article il propose tout simplement de
mieux articuler nos objectifs
migratoires et notre nos outils de
politique étrangère comme le fait
d'ailleurs déjà très bien l'Union
européenne que ce soit sur la question
de l'aide au développement que ce soit
sur la question des visas c'est Visa ça
a été un outil qui a déjà été utilisé
par le gouvernement avec un certain
succès pour les pays d'Afrique du Nord
en
2022 qu en ce qui concerne la politique
migratoire ça permet aussi de de de
mettre des objectifs de politique
migratoire dans notre aide au
développement c'est aider nos
partenaires aussi à mieux contrôler
leurs frontières avoir une politique
d'état civil d'accueil des réfugiés de
de visas donc c'est aussi d'ailleurs ce
qu'il ce qu'il nous demande dans le
renforcement des des capacités donc cet
article mérite d'être débattu en
revanche comme l'a bien dit le ministre
de faire en sorte que ces outils soient
le plus efficace possible contre les
états contre les décideurs et non pas
contre les populations et les sociétés
civiles donc ce sera le sens des
amendements de la commission des
affaires étrangères à la fois sur les
visas et sur l'aide de développement de
préserver les populations et d'utiliser
ces ces levier de la façon la plus
efficace possible contre les
décideurs Monsieur bilongo Merci
monsieur le Président B lesaide public
au développement il faut savoir que
c'est un prêt c'est des prêts il y a
aussi des dons qui existent mais la
majorité c'est des prêts il faut pas
qu'elle soit conditionné à la
restriction des visas monsieur le
ministre vous le savez en 2021 avec les
pays du Maghreb vous avez voulu
instaurer cette situation là de chantage
et qu'est-ce qui en est
ressorti malheureusement on a éprouve
toutes difficultés au niveau
diplomatique ensuite à avoir des
relations scène avec le Maroc oui avec
le du Maroc il y a un gros souci de
communication aujourd'hui au niveau
diplomatique avec l'Algérie pareil et
avec la Tunisie également il ne faut pas
conditionner ces public développement
par rapport au visas et également quand
on on visite ces pays où l'AFD agit ben
ça profite réellement de la France ça
profite auement de la France parce que
lafd agit dans des pays où il y a des
français parfois qui sont aussi
entrepreneurs dans différents sujets et
la France a vocation parfois à être dans
ces pays à aider au développement au
travers de prêt parce que il y a aussi
d'ENT françaises qui sont dans ces pays
là qui utilise parfois le pétrole on a
comme au Congo on a peranco ou dans
différentes régions africaines par
exemple en Afrique au Mozambique vous
avez total qui va exproprier des
villages au Mozambique et
malheureusement les populations se
dépasse vers le nord et quand ces
populations dépassent vers le nord on se
dit qu'est-ce qu'ils font qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent venir en Europe bah c'est
un sujet aujourd'hui
voilà madame madame
keli merci monsieur le Président alors
monsieur le ministre vous avez raison en
effet c'est une pratique c'est une
pratique des relations entre les États
est-ce que ça doit être gravé dans la
loi est-ce que ce chantage doit être
gravé dans la loi il y a deux problèmes
l'aide au développement ça crée aussi
des relations entre les pays qui sont en
voie de développement et la France or
ces relations vous êtes en train de
vouloir les dégrader fortement et ce
chantage aussi sur les sur les visas par
rapport à la condition de plus de
laisser passer consulaire ça ne
fonctionne pas en tout cas en Algérie ça
n'a pas fonctionné depuis 2021 puisque
les laissés passer consulaires sont
vraiment moindres si j'ai bien compris
c'était la dernière fois que j'avais
regardé c'était 17 % donc le les laisser
passer consulaire le chantage avec les
visas ça ne fonctionne pas les visas ont
drastiquement baissé euh pour l'Algérie
alors j'ai j'ai le pourcentage de visa
qui a baissé je crois que c'était autour
de 15 ou 20 % de visa en moins donc
c'est une politique qui ne fonctionne
pas je pense que la pratique elle est
louable elle peut être utilisée mais le
graver dans la loi c'est nocif
madame
gnou oui merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président juste pour préciser que le
groupe Renaissance viendra en appui de
cet article et donc votera ces
amendements de de suppression pour nous
pour contre ces amendements de
suppression pardon donc rejettera ces
amendements de suppression pour nous cet
article 14a c'est un outil indispensable
un outil indispensable pour faire en
sorte que les pays qui doivent nous
renvoyer des laisser pass consulir pour
nous permettre d'éloigner des étrangers
originaires euh de leur territoire
puissent être effectivement renvoyé et
pour cela oui on a besoin d'établir un
rapport de force un rapport de force pas
obligatoire pas forcément contraignant
c'est une possibilité de le faire
rapport de force qui nous permettra
comme ça a été le cas de le faire sur
les visas et euh sur l'aide publicque au
développement alors notre collègue
Benjamin Hadad dans le cadre de la
commission des affaires étrangères a
déposé des amendements euh qui vont
venir ajuster cet article notamment avec
les passeports diplomatiques ou les
passeports de service qui nous semble
extrêmement intéressant ainsi que un des
des un élément sur qui viendrait écarter
de cette disposition les étudiants euh
catégorie à laquelle nous sommes
particulièrement sensibles au sein de
GRE prnaissance et nous sonons heureux
de voter ces
amendements encore madame et Madame
fossillon
et merci monsieur le Président la la
question du du du rapport de force dans
dans la diplomatie elle peut évidemment
à certains moment se poser elle est
pas on peut pas dire qu'elle n'existe
jamais cette question du rapport de
force mais mais la question c'est
jusqu'où on va et à quel prix et j'ai
j'ai vu hein par exemple pour avoir
discuté avec beaucoup d'agents en centre
de rétention qu'effectivement pendant un
temps les laisser passer consulaires
étaient totalement bloqué avec l'Algérie
d'ailleurs on finissait par se demander
pourquoi on continuait d'enfermer des
gens en centre de rétention alors qu'on
savait qu'on allait pas du tout pouvoir
les expulser ils ont un peu repris c'est
vrai ils ont un peu repris mais à quel
prix c'est-à-dire que vous votre
objectif à vous en tant que ministre de
l'intérieur avec les objectifs que vous
fixé c'est d'expulser plus de monde mais
quelle relation pour tout le reste nous
entretenons avec l'Algérie quand nous
faisons ce rapport de force qu'est-ce
que ça dit aussi des Algériens qui
veulent venir à l'enterrement de
quelqu'un en France au mariage de
quelqu'un en France qui veulent
simplement venir quelques jours en
France pour profiter d'un événement
familial important pour eux et qu'on
empêche de faire donc la question c'est
ce rapport de force à quel prix
uniquement sur la question des
expulsions et comment ça dégrade tout un
tas d'autres rapport d'autant que avec
certains pays disons-le et je le diraiis
en particulier avec l'Algérie je crois
que nous avons parfois trop dégradé nos
rapport et qui serait temps justement de
chercher à les améliorer madame et et
enfin Monsieur le Ministre oui merci
monsieur le Président très sincèrement
je ne pense pas que que le rapport de
force soit de nature à à améliorer la
collaboration parce que il me semble
monsieur le ministre la décision que
vous avez prise en 2020 ne relève pas
d'une sanction que vous aviez souhaité
infliger au pays mais plutôt une
invitation à un dialogue sur une
problématique des laisser passer
consulaire personne ne le ni dans cette
salle et donc les amener à discuter à
échanger pour améliorer effectivement
les reconduites dans les pays d'origine
je sais Monsieur le Ministre que vous ne
considérez pas ces ces pays comme des
adversaires mais bien comme des
partenaires qui peuvent nous aider à a
imposer cette
sanction cette reconduite et et et la
sanction par la loi me semble totalement
contre-productif nuirit à nos relations
bilatérales et il me semble que ce que
vous souhaitez faire rentrerait
davantage dans le le cadre d'une
discussion de conditions et de
convention bilatéral plutôt que d'une
inscription de sanction dans la loi
française monsieur le
ministre
bien alors c'est une question très
importante he en effet c'est un article
très important de ce de ce projet de loi
bon d'abord je je veux redire une
nouvelle fois que ce n'est pas
l'obligation d'arrêter la délivrance des
visas c'est la possibilité donneré à
l'état sans viser qui que ce soit parce
que la grande difficulté des chos
précédente c'est qu'elle visait parfois
tel ou tel pays faisant ainsi naître une
difficulté dans la relation bilatérale
mais qui permet à tous les États qui ont
des accords bilatéral ou multilatéral
avec nous de pouvoir effectivement
conditionner la délivrance de visas et
d'ailleurs on n'a pas fait visa zéro
madame et vous le savez bien on a divisé
par deux le nombre de visas et donc les
gens qui ont pu qui voulaient avoir un
mariage et cetera dans notre pays
peut-être que les choses étaient plus
difficiles le but étant que la
population dise quand même à leurs
dirigeants que nous aussi nous avions
des intérêts et moi je dis à Madame
fussillon quel est l'intérêt également
pour nous de garder des des multiévis
dont on sait qu'ils ne sont absolument
pas français et qu'ils doiventir dans
leur pays et qu'ils sont refusés par ces
pays-là comment vous l'expliquer à la
population personne ne l'explique voilà
donc évidemment tout le monde se dit
c'est terrible c'est terrible mais il
faut effectivement quand on est en
responsabilité politique prendre des
décisions c'est tellement vrai d'illeurs
que Monsieur Brar que vous connaissez
bien m'a écrit je peux vous passer sa
letre si vous voulez Jean-Pierre Brar
lui qui intervient beaucoup dans cette
sujet ben pour ceux qui ne le
connaissent pas il a été 20 ans député
du Parti communiste il est encore très
en responsabilité dans les questions qui
touchent les étrangers
m'a écrit pour dire qu'il soutenait la
disposition qui consiste effectivement à
conditionner la ou les visas pour les
pays d'immigration alors deuxième
contevérité qui a pu être dit pardon
monsieur bilongo mais c'est c'est le
sujet de l'efficacité ou non de ces
mesures alors moi je vous
renvoie je vous renvoie au rapport de
Monsieur lefur rapporteur spécial pour
la commission Affaires étrangères qui
est publié à 3 semaines sur les chiffres
que lui a confi ministère d'intérieur et
ministère des Affaires étrangères donc
Monsieur Le Fur chacun sa combat le le
gouvernement taux de délivrance de LPC
en 2021 Algérie 6 % 2022 46 %. voilà 40
points d'augmentation de délivrance de
LPC pour le Maroc 43 % en 2021 en 2022
54 %. et pour la Tunisie 41 % en 2021 44
% en 2022 ce sont les documents de
l'Assemblée nationale et du rapporteur
social qui a été publié il y a 3
semaines et moi je voudrais redire ici
une nouvelle fois médiatiquement je ne
sais pas que cela sera repris mais quand
on passe de 6 % de laisser passer
consulire en 2021 par l'Algérie à 46 %
c'estàdire que pour l'instant un
document sur deux nous est délivré bah
c'est quand même 40 points de plus que
ce qui se passait en 2021 on pourrait
aussi s'en réjouir et remercier en effet
l'État algérien l'État marocain l'État
tunisien et je regarde sur les autres
nationalités Côte d'Ivoire en 2022 96 %
Guinée 93 % Sénégal 75 % donc la
difficulté c'est évidemment avec les
États du Maghreb chacun le sait
constater que 46 % ou 44 % c'est pas
suffisant je le dis et c'est pour ça que
j'ai besoin de cette disposition mais on
a augmenté de 40 % les taux de
délivrament laisser passer consulaire
donc on peut pas à la fois me dire vous
n'appliquez pas les eqtf ou il y a trop
de monde en CR et alors vous pouvez
pourquoi vous les mettez en cas parce
qu'on arrive pas à les reconduire et
puis quand on vous dit bah voilà on a
des techniques pour que ça aille mieux
refusz ces techniques au ministère
d'intérieur je pense que il y a un sujet
sauf à porter ce que porte certains
groupes politiques et c'est émidemment
respectable la régularisation de tous
les les sans papiers y compris les y
compris les délinquants bon ça c'est un
autre non non c'est un non non vous oui
oui non mais bah vous avez voté contre
l'article 9 contre l'article 10 vous
voulez supprimer la rétention et vous
avez porté un amement de régularisation
de toutes les personnes sans papier
donc
vous vous
êtes vous êtes contre les sans papier je
comprends pas
non monsieur min finissez votre propos
s'il vous plaît donc ce que Ben j'essae
monsieur le Président je voudrais je
voudrais donc dire que cette disposition
est très importante et qu'elle a montré
son
efficacité donc je mets au voix les
amendements de suppression de l'article
14a qui vote
pour qui vote contre ils sont rejetés
l'amendement suivant le 267 monsieur
Hadad merci monsieur le Président donc
suite à cette discussion cet amendement
propose de rajouter dans les visas qui
pourraent être utilisés refusés par le
gouvernement le visa de cour séjour
sollicité par le titulaire d'un
passeport diplomatique ou de service
ressortissant d'un État délivrant un
nombre particulièrement faible de
laisser passer consulaire ou ne
respectant pas un accord bilatéral ou
multilatéral de gestion des flux
migratoires donc cela vise vraiment à à
cibler le plus possible les décideurs
les dignitaires les les gouvernement de
pays non coopératifs sur la politique
migratoire plutôt que les populations
donc en rajoutant euh les visas
diplomatiques du dispositif de l'article
14a Monsieur
marcangéi Merci monsieur le Président
cet amendement du groupe horizon donc
reprend donc l'amendement adopté en
commission des affaires étrangères pour
avis par le rapporteur Hadad euh le
projet issu du Sénat n'incluait pas les
titulaires de visa diplomatiques on
trouve que pour inciter les états peu
coopératifs à davantage coopérer ça une
bonne idée et plutôt que de pénaliser la
population influer sur les décideurs
nous paraît
juste merci Monsieur balanan oui c'est
exactement le même amendement donc on va
dire qu'il est
défendu merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis merci madame la
Présidente donc je donner un avis
favorable à à ces trois amendements
identiques parce qu'effectivement il
pointe un des sujets qui a été évoqué
qui est le fait de cibler véritablement
les populations ce qu'elle nous
souhaitons faire porter cet effort
particulier en matière de délivrance de
visa et même s'il y a peut-être des
difficultés rédactionnelles qui
mériteraiit qu'il soit peut-être un
petit peu réécrit d'ici la séance je
pense que en l'état j'ai plaisir à leur
donner un avis
favorable je vous remercie monsieur
Dumont vous avez demandé la parole oui
dire notre plein soutien évidemment à
cette série d'amendements parce que ça
permet de viser aussi ceux qui sont les
dirigeants de ces pays et ce sera en
effet quelque chose d'extrêmement
dire également à Monsieur le Ministre
par rapport à son intervention
précédente Queen effet peut-être qu'il y
a eu 46 % de laissé passer consulairire
délivré par l'Algérie en 2022 mais ça ne
fait que 962 sur les 26147 au qtf la
réalité c'est que on demande très très
peu de laisser passer consulaire on
demande 2092 laisser passer consulaire à
l'Algérie c'est à peine 10 % du nombre
deqtf délivrés à l' compte d'Algérien
donc il faut aussi comparer ce qui est
comparable je vous remercie je vais
mettre au voix ces amendements avec un
avis favorable du rapporteur qui est
pour qui est contre ils sont adoptés je
vous remercie amendement suivant le 510
défendu par merci collègue oui en
contrepartie d'un effort financier
considérable de la part des Français il
est légitime de demander que les pays
aidés s'engagent à reprendre l'ensemble
de leur ressortissant résident
illégalement en France il avait été
proposé lors de l'examen du PLF 2024 la
création d'un indicateur taux de reprise
de ses ressortissants expulsés de France
pour pays recevant une aide économique
ou financière française mais cette
amendement avait été rejeté concernant
les montants de l'aide française au
développement le gouvernement avait
annoncé qu'il s'efforcera d'atteindre
0,7 % du revenu national brut en 2025 et
dans la perspective d'atteindre 22
milliards d'euros par an pour rappel les
recettes de la taxe d'habitation ont
rapporté 24,3 milliards d'euros en 2020
au 1er trimestre 2022
seulement 6,9 % des TF étaient exécutés
en partie du fait de l'abstention
volontaire de certains pays à délivrer
les laiss passer consulair le présent
amendement vise donc à établir les bases
de relation de confiance avec les états
soutenus avec l'argent de l'État à force
de ne plus rien exiger c'est la France
qui n'est plus
respectée je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur sur le 510 avis défavorable
puisque dans dans sa rédaction actuelle
visant le nombre de laisser passer
consul particulièrement faible au lieu
de faible tel que votre amendement le
précise on a à la fois des éléments plus
précis plus équilibrés et qui fait qu'on
ouvrira la possibilité ainsi que la
décrit ministre de l'Intérieur à une
action ciblée efficace et non pas une
action générale qui pourrait être un peu
aveugle donc beaucoup moins efficace je
vous remercie monsieur léoman une
réaction mais merci madame la Présidente
simplement une réaction puisque là le
dispositif qui est proposé par le
rassemblement national propose de durcir
un dispositif auquel nous sommes opposés
et sur le lequel nous nous sommes
exprimés tout à l'heure mais pour redire
donner un un un argument supplémentaire
quand on dit que on va refuser des euh
titres de longue de des des séjours de
longue durée à des ressortissants d'État
qui ne donnent pas assez de laisser
passer consulaair c'est-à-dire euh
d'acceptation en gros des euh des des
des des personnes étrangères sans
passeport quand ils ont une cttf pour
qu'il reviennent dans le pays d'origine
ça veut dire donc que on vient pénaliser
des individus qui demandent un titre de
séjour de longue durée en raison du
comportement de leur état
or c'est quand même une idée un peu
étrange euh de de dire que l'État dont
sont originaires les personnes en raison
de son comportement peut avoir une
influence sur l'individu euh qui cherche
à rejoindre notre pays c'est une vision
un peu particulière de la liberté je
vous remerci je vais mettre au voie le
510 avec un avis défavorable du
rapporteur qui est
pour qui est contre il est rejeté le 534
n'est pas soutenu le
1588 madame e oui merci madame la
Présidente donc c'est un amendement de
repli suite au au rejet des amendements
de de suppression il exclut les visas du
du
dispositif et il il porte uniquement sur
l'Agence française de développement donc
il supprime les alinéats de 1 à 5 et on
garde un point d'accroche sur l'Agence
française de développement qui peut
prendre en compte la qualité de la
coopération des États en matière de
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
dans la répartition de l'ensemble des
concours qu'elle attribue j'exclus les
visas parce que j'estime que c'est déjà
un titre de séjour qui est totalement
subjectif nul besoin de l'inscrire cette
sanction dans la loi pour mener une
potentielle politique de sanction en la
matière monsieur le
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente
défavorable pour les mêmes raisons que c
exposé contre les amendements de
suppression je je vais mettre monsieur
le ministre bien sûr oui je veux dire à
la ministre que elle minimise d'apporter
t amendement cette bonne guerre mais
mais c'est pas le cas puisque les quatre
premièr alinéas sont les plus importants
c'est sont ceux qui permettent au
gouvernement sans doute d'obtenir le
plus des états encore une fois
possibilité pour l'état de le faire et
si et seulement si un un accord n'est
pas respecté un accord signé librement
par le pays voilà donc je pense que on a
déjà eu le débat sur l'importance de ce
sujet pour la politique migratoire la
politique étrangère notre p
madame e vous souhaitez répondre oui je
pense qu'on aura ce débat une nouvelle
fois en séance parce que je maintiens
mes propos et et ma conviction sur le
fait que cette mesure ne permettra pas
d'obtenir plus de laisser passer
consulair je crois que le lien de cause
à effet est un peu trop rapide et juste
dire à mes collègues de bien réfléchir
d'ici la séance puisque les républicains
nous tendent un piège entre ce qu'ils
disent ici les propos qu'ils tiennent à
l'Assemblée nationale et les propos qui
tiennent dans les ambassades à
l'étranger ça porte vraiment atteinte à
l'image de la France au rayonnement de
la France à l'intérêt de la France et au
sentiments aussi antifançais qui monte
dans les pays et notamment au Maghreb et
en Afrique donc là aussi faites vraiment
enfin ayez cette réflexion à
l'esprit monsieur léoman
oui l'heure est grave puisque une
situation met du même côté madame e et
les insoumis qui est assez rare pour
être signalé et ce qui provoque ce qui
provoque ceci ce qui provoque ceci c'est
l'intérêt de la France et quand
l'intérêt de la France est en jeu il n'y
a pas je crois de de de division
possible entre nous là en l'occurrence
ce que signalait madame E est
extrêmement juste c'est-à-dire que ce
que le le sujet qui est en cause ici
c'est l'image qui existe de nous à
l'étranger et mon mon mon camarade et
collègues Carlos Martin bilango l'a très
bien dit c'est aussi une question de de
de rayonnement de la France que c'était
de public développement mais allons plus
loin c'est-à-dire les dans les questions
migratoires il y a la question
économique qui est parfois en jeu et un
certain nombre de personnes quittent
leur pays en raison des situations
économiques de leur pays parfois nous
participons nous-même la France à
affaiblir économiquement ces pays et là
il y a un dispositif qui s'appelle
l'aide publique au développement sur
laquelle il y aurait plein de choses à
redire mais qui participe du fait que ça
améliore un petit peu les choses bon et
bien si à la fois on on essaie de jouer
sur les deux tableaux je voudrais juste
finir sur ça après je vous promets j'en
fais pas
mais si on essaie de jouer sur ça sans
aller bon ben c'est pas possible de
merci
beaucoup madame ki et nous passerons au
vote merci madame la
Présidente je je c'est bon je peux y
aller ou parle c'est vos collègues qui
vous ce st couvre le son je vais parler
adessus des voix alors on va essayer de
faire entendre notre voix les pays
vulnérable vous êtes en train de dire
aux habitants de ces pays on va
conditionner l'aide publique au
développement un chantage infâme au
retour des délinquants sans papier
attention moi je dis un double
problématique le premier problème c'est
que vous êtes en train d'abandonner les
populations les plus vulnérables à leur
sort en en en supprimant les aides
qu'ils peuvent avoir et vous êtes en
train de faire monter une détestation de
la France qui joue à un chantage un
chantage qui est très rude pour ces pays
parce que ces populations sont
vulnérables elles savent qu'elles elles
sont dans l'attente d'une aide et vous
êtes en train de faire un odieux
chantage et je crois que la relation
internationale elle sera
abîmée monsieur gilet ensuite monsieur
le ministre très très rapidement madame
la Présidente il est pas acceptable il
est même pas entendable de de de de dire
que et bien sanctionner des pays qui ne
nous délivrent pas des laisser passer
consulairire ce serait nuire à l'image
de la France non l'image de la France
aujourd'hui dans le monde c'est aussi
l'image d'un pays laxiste et qui se fait
marcher dessus on est un peu le
paillasson du monde et donc il est
important de réaffirmer ici et bien que
nous ne laissons pas faire et que nous
pouvons aussi sortir les gros bras et ne
pas se laisser faire face au pays qui ne
font pas leur travail en acceptant leur
ressortissant c'est se faire respecter
et se faire entendre la voix de la
France encore s'il vous plaît chers
collègues on s'écoute madame meriller
vient de demander la parole et ensuite
monsieur le ministre et nous passerons
au vote s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
oui merci merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais juste réagir à ce qu'on vient
d'entendre parce que leont le
rassemblement national pardon nous donne
des leçons sans cesse mais à plusieurs
reprises quand même depuis depuis lundi
il nous explique quand on leur parle
quand on vous parle de de Madame mélonie
qu'en fait non c'est pas Madame mélonie
que vous soutenez c'est Monsieur Salvini
monsieur Salvini il faut peut-être quand
même dire aux gens qui connaissent pas
ce charmant monsieur quand même qu'il a
qu'il a qu'il est quand même assez
particulier qu'il est un peu nostalgique
de Monsieur Mussolini mais surtout qu'il
a un bilan en tant que ministre de
l'Intérieur qu'il avait promis 100000
expulsions combien il en a réalisé un
petit peu plus de 7000 donc je pense il
faut aussi peut-être que vous soyez
clair sur vos soutiens et puis rappeleer
à tout le monde un peu ce que c'est que
le bilan de vos amis monsieur le
ministre s'il vous plaît bien non pour
rappeler aussi que Monsieur Salvini fait
partie du gouvernement de Madame mélonie
mais ça ça ça vous a manifestement
échapper peut-être peut-être revenir sur
l'article parce qu'on a parlé de plein
de choses et j'ai entendu
monsieur madame la députée je je pardon
de j'ai oublié votre nom jeen suis
désolé quoi excusez-moi madame qu loi en
fait on parle on parle pas du on parle
pas du du même texte non non je crois
pas parce qu'en fait vous dites on va
sanctionner les pays
les populations qui ont besoin de nous
sur le développement mais personne ne
sanctionne les pays qui ont besoin de
nous sur le développement c'est les pays
qui ont signé un accord bilatéral
multilatéral avec nous c'est qu'ils sont
engagés librement pour demander un
certain nombre de choses à la France qui
l'aide bien volontiers c'est le cas de
l'aide au développement c'est le cas de
développement économique c'est cas de la
politique migratoire on peut imaginer
plein de choses on peut imaginer qu'on
est suspendu un certain nombre de
difficultés administrativ qu'on est pas
don pas on n pas donné de visa aux
dirigeants politiques qu'on a peut-être
imaginé des accords pour pouvoir
accueillir un certain nombre d'étudiants
enfin voilà on peut imaginer plein de
choses et parmi comme tout accord bah il
y a des demande de la part de la France
l'accord il est jamais unilatéral c'est
pas un contrat léonin un contrat
international c'est c'est c'est un
accord diplomatique donc chacun s'est
engagé dans l'accord la France y a
peut-être mis et elle le fait désormais
systématiquement des conditions et parmi
ces conditions ce que applique la France
c'est notamment des conditions de retour
au pays de leur nationaux donc quand
l'accord n'est pas respecté et signé
librement par un État souverain il est
normal d'y prévoir un certain nombre
effet de de questionnement voire de de
difficultés et c'est ce que dit cet
article il dit pas qu'on va
unilatéralement dans un pays avec lequel
on a'urait pas d'accord qui vivrait dans
la misère ou dans la grande difficulté
sanctionner ces population donc je pense
qu'il faudrait vraimentevenir à
l'article l'article dit peut et dit si
l'État ne respecte pas les accords
pasilà deuxème sujet deème sujet la
réciprocité des engagements ça existe
dans la diplomatie que font les
États-Unis ou la Chine avec nos
questions économiques bah il demande un
certain nombre de réciprocité notamment
d'actes qui considèrent par exemple à
participer à la vie économique en ayant
par exemple un associé qui est de la
même nationalité pour monter une
entreprise en Algérie c'est ce qui se
passe en Algérie vous ne pouvez pas
créer une entreprise par exemple en
Algérie si vous avez pas un un deal avec
que un associé algérien bah c'est c'est
normal on le respecte bien volontier
c'est c'est la souveraineté d'un État on
a le droit en politique international
d'adopter un certain nombre
d'exigigences quand on signe un accord
multinational ou bilatéral c'est pas
dramatique voilà et tous les
gouvernements l'ont fait y compris les
gouvernements socialistes vous savez
madame donc voilà je pense qu'on peut
revenir au débat qu'on a eu on a besoin
de cet article très important pour
appliquer notre politique migratoire
c'est une arme que vous donnez à la
France vous ne la dévalorisez pas en
faisant ça vous renforce sans pouvoir
diplomatique je vous remercie je mets au
voix le 1588 avec l'avis défavorable du
rapporteur qui est pour qui est contre
il est rejeté nous passons à au 265 de
Monsieur Hadad merci madame la
Présidente c'est un amendement qui a été
adopté par la commission des affaires
étrangères qui vise à préserver les
étudiants des politiques de restriction
de visa dans les cas de non coopération
d'État dans la politique migratoire les
étudiants cont contribu au rayonnement
de nos universités de notre recherche et
donc de notre économie donc il est tout
normal que la la France ne les
sanctionne pas lorsque leur état
n'applique pas ses ses responsabilités
dans le cadre de la politique migratoire
amendement identique monsieur balanan
oui c'est l'amendement également de la
commission des finances mais que l'
portait par Madame Gatel au cas où
Monsieur Adad aurait pu être absent il
est là donc il est défendu je vous
remercie monsieur le le rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente avis
favorable sur le fond sur la forme on
aurait peut-être un peu à retravailler
la la rédaction ce que je vous propose
de faire d'ici la séance mais avis
favorable sur le fond j'ai deux prises
de parole madame jeunevard et puis
monsieur léoman oui merci merci madame
la Présidente alors je prends acte du
fait que on ne soumett pas les visas
étudiants au rapport de force avec les
pays qui sont réticents à délivrer des
laisser passer consulaire pour autant il
me semble qu'il faut sortir d'une vision
un peu lénifiante monsieur le le député
Hadad vous avez dit ça contribue au
rayonnement de la France bien sûr il est
pas question de fermer nos universités
aux étudiants français néanmoins je vous
rappelle les chiffres 100000 visas
étudiants délivrés chaque année par la
France donc on veut pas dire que la
France soit en perte de rayonnement à la
matière on sait aussi on sait aussi que
tous ne sont pas des étudiants euh
comment dirais-je assidus puisqu'on a
voté euh le l'exigence de caractère
sérieux des des études donc moi je
m'interroge monsieur le le rapporteur
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je m'interroge sur
l'opportunité d'écrire dans la loi que
cette restriction des laisser passer
consulaires s'appliquerait aux étudiants
si si vous ne le dites pas je vous
remercie est-ce que ça empêche de
délivrer des visas étudiants je ne crois
pas mais dès lors que vous l'inscrivez
dans la loi vous vous privez du jour
peut-être vous serez obligé de
restreindre les vis pardonnez-moi madame
Martin pour finir merci merci beaucoup
de me donner la
parole simplement je voulais vous faire
remarquer qu' avait un petit caractère
un peu
cont entre ce qui est voté d'un moment à
l'autre de de ce long examen et c'est
normal qu' mérite ce sujet mérite un
long examen donc nous vous nous avons
attiré votre attention sur le fait que
la présence étudiants étrangers sur le
sol français était quelque chose
d'important important pour la France
important pour les pays bien sûr
d'origine je crois même qu'on a évoqué
la question du classement Shanghai pour
autant nous n'avons pas été entendus à
ce moment-là lorsqu'il est question
d'une caution spécifique et de droits
d'inscription qui vont être majorés pour
cela donc faudrait un peu choisir euh je
parle d'une façon générale je parle
d'une façon général hein et et et et je
trouve qu'il est bon de de de d'essayer
en tout cas d'avoir une certaine
cohérence et je redis que je suis
heureuse de voir que l'accueil
d'étudiants étranger est quelque chose
qui nous tient à
cœur je vous remercie je mets au voix
cette ces deux amendements avec un avis
favorable qui est
pour qui est contre ils sont adoptés le
suivant le
euh 535 n'est pas défendu le 390 non
plus amendement identique monsieur Hadad
pour le
269 merci madame la Présidente cette cet
amendement qui a été adopté par la
commission des affaires étrangères vise
à inscrire dans la programmation de
notre politique de développement un
objectif de 10 % de l'aide qui est dédié
au développement des capacités
migratoires de nos partenaires alors je
précise qu'il s'agit pas ici de
conditionnalité mais mais bien d'aider
nos partenaires dans l'aide au
développement à mieux maîtriser leurs
frontières à mieux accueillir leurs
réfugiés avoir une politique de
développement de leur état civil de
l'asile si on prend par exemple un pays
comme la Tunisie qui n'a aujourd'hui pas
de politique d'asile ou de maîtrise de
ses frontières avec ses ses voisins
terrestres ou ou maritimes comme le fait
l'Union européenne la politique au
développement vise en partie à
contribuer au développement de ses
capacités donc il s'agit ici en fait
fondamentalement d'aligner les objectifs
euh et notamment le chiffre de 10 % avec
ce que fait déjà l'Union européenne je
vous remercie monsieur balanan comme
tout à l'heure ou défendu je vous
remercie avis du rapporteur aucun
argument ajouté favorable je alors
monsieur bilango je vous en prie merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur prenez
l'exemple de la Tunisie on on a vu le
résultat cet été avec les gardes de cô
tunisiens vous pensez vraiment que de
financer à hauteur de 10 % avec la
pour les aider à financer les gardes de
côte avec toutes les exactions qui sont
réalisé monsieur Hadad mais c'est mais
non monsieur Hadad vous allez financer
des cartes de côte qui sont violents qui
parfois violent les femmes ça mais oui
on l'a vu les garde de côte bien sûr
bien sûr je vous invite vraiment à à à à
à faire des recherches vous documentz
même vous déplacer en Tunisie pour voir
ce qui se passe c'est très compliqué
pour les personnes je vous yêtes aller
raison une plus et au de développement
doit servir à quoi à à aider sur la
santé à aider sur l'assaignissement dans
ces pays mais pas sur pour garder les
frontières je vous remercie je mets au
voix ces amendements identiques avec un
avis favorable du rapporteur qui est
pour qui est contre ils sont
adoptés série d'amendements identiques à
nouveau monsieur Hadad le
261 défendu je crois c'est l'amendement
de Monsieur fou et du MoDem est-ce que
il est défendu également côté modem
monsieur le rapporteur votre avis avis
favorable parce que ces amendements
proposent de supprimer les alinéats 5 et
6 qui effectivement créent une
contrainte supplémentaire avis favorable
je les mets au
voix avec un avis favorable qui est
pour qui est pour qui est contre bon pas
une grande ferveur il est ils sont
adoptés ils font
tomber suivant le 474 qui le défend
madame
jeunevard merci madame la Présidente
c'est donc un amendement de de Monsieur
Coti alors cela a été dit par mon
collègue Pierre-Henri Dumont il est
clair que
subordonné l'aide au développement à la
bonne volonté des pays pour délivrer des
des laisser passer consulaire est une
demande que nous réitérons de façon
constante depuis des années d'ailleurs
les articles 9 et 10 que nous avons
adopté la levée des protections tout ça
sera V si on ne peut pas expulser si on
ne peut pas éloigné ça ne servira à rien
donc ce n'est faire qu'une partie du
chemin si les pays ne reprennent pas les
ressortissants que nous éloignons que
nous expulsons par conséquent nous
sommes très favorables à cet article
évidemment
nous trouvons intéressant d'élargir au
passeport diplomatique parce que là il
s'agit évidemment des des leaders
d'opinion donc ça peut faire bouger les
lignes j'ai émis des réserves sur le
fait de donner un signal à l'égard des
étudiants et je trouve particulièrement
intéressant l'ajout du Sénat des
centristes du Sénat qui ont inclus dans
cet article l'objectif de lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis ce sera une
demande de retrait puisquen fait
l'amendementel qu'il est rédigé est
satisfait par les dispositions de
l'alinéa 4 qu'il a été rédigé au Sénat
et que nous n'avons pas modifié à
l'occasion des travaux de cette
commission donc c'est une demande de
retrait à des fois avis
défavorable je vais mettre au voix C
pardon monsieur ministre bien sûr non
juste dire Madame jeev que je comprends
très bien l'argument sur
elle a souligné je le remercie
l'importance
elle a souigné l'importance des articles
9 et 10 on pourrait rajouter 13 madame
jeunevard vous avez souigné l'importance
d'articles 9 et 10 et 13 on pourrait
rajouter 13 sur l'expulsion loignement
des étrangers des dit tout ça sera 20 si
alors non enfin si je peux me permettre
parce que aujourd'hui nous expulsons dem
nous éloignons 2500 étrangers
délinquants par an on a 4000 étrangers
délinquants à expulser au éloigner qu'on
ne peut pas
faire qui on ne peut pas demander un
laisser passer r on peut pas le demander
parce qu'il y a des réserves public
qu'on vient de lever bon bon mais avant
même ces articles notamment 14a que je
soutiens fortement évidemment et qui je
crois répondre en très grande partie
aussi à l'amendement de Monsieur Ceti et
de vos collègues on le fait c'est-à-dire
que il y aura forcément une augmentation
d'expulionvumement combien même on
n'aurait pas adopté l'article 14a
l'article 14a permettra d'aller beaucoup
plus loin je je partage bien volontiers
mais je pense que CIT pas raisonnable de
dire que de voter la fin des
restrictions que nous impose que nous
impose la loi française euh ne serait
pas possible parce que d'une part il y a
de juge c'estamendement c'est le
jugement un peu bizarre de Monsieur
marlex ou parce qu' des pays étrangers
évidemment il y a toujours une bataille
évidemment qu'on a besoin du 14a mais on
y arrivera quand même en tout cas on
arrivera à expulser bien plus lorsqu'on
arrive à à lever ses réserves dans
public donc j'entends le lien mais il
n'est pas il n'est pas aussi égal que
vous le dites je vous remercie je
vais oui euh je vous en
prie
je vous en prie alors
ouais je sais pas où il est Monsieur
monsieur Dumont allez-y c'est bon ça
fonctionne merci madame la Présidente
simplement préciser que la question en
réalité c'est aussi la question de
savoir à quoi sert la FD c'estàdire que
si on pouvait peut-être à travailler en
séance mais Imagineer un amendement qui
incite particulièrement à développer les
états civils dans les pays d'origine en
particulier les états civils
biométriques c'est une un des aspects
qui a été mis en place lors de des
discussions sur la grande loi qui a été
votée lors du précédent kquena ce serait
extrêmement positif pu ça permettrait
d'avoir beaucoup plus de retours positif
sur les demandes de laisser passer
consulaire et ce serait une AFD qui
serait utile sans la couper mais au
renvoi à l'exécution des
TF monsieur le ministre je parle en mon
nom il faut évid qu'on en discute avec
le ministère d'affaires étrangères mais
je pense que c'est très c'est très
possible d' c'est ce que nous faisons
déjà vous l'avez voté dans laalopie il y
a une aide budgétaire internationale du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui n'est pas
une aide de développement mais qui
permet notamment grâce à civipol
d'intervenir pour refaire des états
civils et c'est la demande de certains
pays avec lequel on a des relations
diplomatiqu des polices aux frontières
dans le cas des Comores par exemple nous
aidons
budgétairement à l'achat l'équipement
l'essence que l'on met dans les bateaux
pour ceux des gardescôtes Comoriens mais
c'est aussi le cas pour la Tunisie donc
on est tout à fait prêt évidemment à le
faire aujourd'hui c'est les crédits du
ministère d'intérieur qui aide mais
l'aide au développement et c'est une
demande d'ailleurs des pays pas pas tous
mais c'est une demande de ces pays peut
aussi servir à ça en tout cas moi je
suis prêt à travailler avec les
rapporteurs si vous le souhaitez je vous
remercie nous mettons au voie le 474
avec un avis défavorable du rapporteur
qui est
pour qui est contre il est rejeté je
mets au voix le l'article
14a qui est
pour qui est contre il est adopté nous
passons à l'article
14b amendement de suppression le 50 qui
le
défend j'ai qui le défend le
madame madame Rousseau défendu sur les
amendements de suppression le 400 le
842 monsieur
porte merci madame la Présidente ici un
amendement de suppression Paris que le
Sénat a
ajouté une disposition qui permet de
d'informer de supprimer les ation
chômage suite à des décisions de refus
de de tit de séjour euh encore une fois
le droit au chômage il est attaché à la
personne on a quand même on peut avoir
des individus qui ont travaillé pendant
plusieurs années donc qui ont participé
euh au financement de la sécurité
sociale qui ont participé au financement
de la société et qu'on prive de leur
droit au chômage donc encore une fois
c'est une version extrêmement
utilitariste et on considère qu'il faut
pas que ces droits au chômage soi coupé
et vous nous faites depuis ce matin des
leçons de respect des valeurs de la
République mais quand on a quelqu'un qui
a travaillé qui a cotisé il est normal
qu'il continue à toucher ses droits au
chômage je vous remercie le suivant le
931 monsieur Vallot madame caramanli
défendu le suivant monsieur
riman le
115 il est
parti et bien monsieur le rapporteur vos
avis votre avis sur ces amendements de
suppression merci madame la Présidente
je suis défavorable à ces
AMS pardon
pardon j'ai oublié madame excusez-moi
j'ai oublié Madame
Dupont alors mais excusez-moi parce que
je je je ne suivais plus le nos débats
donc j'ai fait une pause intellectuelle
je suis confuse donc je vais dire
défendu je vous
remercie jeis désolé monsieur le
rapporteur pour son
avis attendez monsieur le rapporteur
pour son avis sur ces amendements de
suppression merci madame la Présidente
donc je suis défavorable c'est de
suppression qui parce que la mesure en
fait fait est une mesure de bon sens ça
vise à assurer l'information par un
certain nombre d'organismes d'une d'une
décision confirmant la non régularité
sur de la présence sur le territoire
français par le préfet en revanche il y
a probablement des améliorations de
rédaction qu'on pourra travailler pour
la séance mais en l'état je suis
défavorable aux amendements de
suppression j'ai trois prises de parole
monsieur
coulom merci madame la Présidente oui on
est à nouveau dans une acception à sens
unique de toute cette loi qui finalement
crée toujours plus de devoir pour les
personnes étrangères sur notre sol et
toujours moins de droit et ensuite on a
le rassemblement national qui va
s'émouvoir qu'il y ait des actes on va
dire de délinquence qui puissent se
produire mais imaginez bien qu'arrivver
à un moment euh dans le cas qui nous
intéresse ici avec la privation des
droits au chômage pour motif
d'avoir commis quelque part à un moment
un acte délinquant et bien vous allez
amplifier le phénomène et précariser
encore plus des gens gens qui finalement
vont peut-être parfois être amenés à se
livrer à un larsin ici ou là et vous
favorisez finalement cette précarité qui
ensuite entraîne le fait d'avoir parfois
transgressé certaines de nos lois pour
des raisons tout simplement de survie
sur notre propre territoire parce que
cette loilà elle dépouille finalement
les personnes étrangères de tant de
droits de tant de ressources de tant de
moyens pour vivre dignement et ben
qu'elleell les poussent au point qu'on
les retrouve dans les cras effectivement
où on a beaucoup de gens qui sont là
pour des petits larcins des petits petit
dél madame
Diaz merci madame la Présidente alors là
une fois de plus une partie de la
majorité s'alie avec l'anupès pour
assouplir ce texte et là qu'est-ce que
vous proposez vous voulez que le préfet
après une décision de refus de séjour de
retrait de titre de séjour ou
d'expulsion préviennent les organismes
de sécurité social les casaes à location
familiale et pô emploi pour permettre
une radiation de l'étranger concerné
enfin c'est quand même la moindre des
choses là on parle d'une personne qui a
été reconnue comme en situation de
clandestinité c'est-à-dire qui n'a pas
de raison de se maintenir sur le
territoire vous voulez lui maintenir ses
aides je trouve que c'est pas très
sérieux à un moment où on passe où vous
passez votre temps à augmenter les
impôts des Français là vous avez des
pistes d'économie intéressantes puisque
selon l'OCDE les allocaltion familiales
accordés aux étrangers s'élèvent à plus
de 9 milliards d'euros l'aide au
logement au bénéfice des étrangers à
plus de 5 milliards d'euros et le RSA a
plus de 6 milliards d'euros donc voilà
si on appliquait cet amendement on
pourrait retrouver quelques pistes
d'économie et ça permettrait aux
Français de retrouver leur argent madame
Rousseau en l'occurrence ça n'est pas
l'argent des Français qu'on donnerait
aux étrangers enfin je pense que si on a
du chômage c'est parce que nous avons
cotisé en fait et que ces cotisations
servent d'assurance et que c'est
profondément la philosophie de notre
système social donc ce n'est pas une
charité que nous faisons à quiconque
c'est un droit acquis au titre du TR
travail réalisé en France raison pour
laquelle cela ne peut pas être lié ni à
un
statut de papier d'étranger en France ni
au fait d'être français ou pas français
et en l'occurrence ils ont largement
gagné ce qu'ils ce dont ils peuvent
bénéficier en tant que chômage et nous
n'avons pas à les priver d'un droit qui
est lié à leur
labeur je vous remercie avant vous
monsieur le ministre rapporteur général
voulez dire un
mot mais d'abord répondre à à
Madame répondre à Madame Diaz je vous AZ
mal suivi je pense ma chère
collègue le rapporteur Pradal a donné un
avis défavorable à l'ensemble des
amendements nupes je ne comprends pas de
quelle alliance vous parlez mais je
voudrais répondre à Jean-François coulum
ainsi qu'à madame
Rousseau mais nous considérons qu'à
partir du moment où la personne n'a plus
droit au séjour elle ne peut pas avoir
les mêmes droits que lorsqu'elle était
en régularité enfin ça paraît tout à
fait normal en quoi cela est-il choquant
j'ajoute que nous introduisons un délai
de carence de 3 mois qui fait que la
continuité des soins sera tout à fait
assurée j'ajoute que nous avons supprimé
la suppression de l'aide médicale d'État
qui fait que s'il y a des difficultés
particulières de santé la personne
pourra toujours continuer d'être soignée
donc et d'ailleurs ça ne sa'est pas et
d'ailleurs nous assumons qu'il ne s'agit
pas simplement des prestations chômage
il s'agit de toutes les prestations
organisme de sécurité sociale et il nous
apparaît tout à fait légitime qu'une
personne qui n'a plus le droit de
séjourner en France n'est pas tout à
fait les mêmes les droits les mêmes
droit pardon qu'une personne qui est en
situation régulière je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre et nous passerons
au vote
oui alors qui c'est qui m'a pas rendu
mon
stab je je je pense que la disposition
don que vous évoquez dans dans dans vos
discussions ne correspond pas à
l'article 14b parce que l'article 14b
lui prévoit en cas de police de sjour
ben pardon monsieur le député mais c'est
pas l'article vous évoquez le chômage ça
ne concerne pas le chômage ça concerne
toutes les prestations contributives et
non contributives dans les non
contributives il y a effectivement pour
le coup pour reprendre l'exemple de
Madame Rousseau c'est l'argent des
Français et des étrangers réguliers qui
contribu à la nation mais là il s'agit
pas de cotisation qui donne ouvert à des
droits comme le chôage et toutes les
prestations donc j'entends bien qu'on
axe le chômage parce que c'est ce qui
peut apparaître plus scandaleux mais
c'est l'intégralité des prestations
sociales et il s'agit pas de retirer la
personne qui deviendrait irrégulière par
principe et si le faire en cas de police
du séjour qui correspond à article 13
c'est en cas de désordre public en cas
de retrait au nom de l'article 13 du
titre de séjour ou du refus de séjour
parce que c'est de la police du séjour
de manière expressis verbis organisé
alors oui on retire les prestations
sociales parce que personne ne
comprendrait par exemple l'exemple de
l'assassin de la petite Lola c'est pour
cela c'est pour cela que j'ai pris une
instruction le 17 novembre 2022 à la
demande du Président de la République
pour qu'elle ne puisse pas toucher pour
qu'elle ne puisse pas toucher alors qu'
était irrégulière des prestations
sociales après avoir assassiné une
petite fille personne ne l'aurait
vraiment compris je crois et je rappelle
que cette circulaire d'instruction pour
pouvoir en effet lever les PR sociale a
été validée par le Conseil d'État
totalement et complètement donc je pense
que cette disposition qui consiste à
demander la fin de la des prestations
sociales lorsqu'il y a eu un désordre
public par l'article 13 ou par les
autres articles de police du séjour et
qu'on a retiré un titre de séjour à
quelqu'un qui a vocation à partir du
territoire national parce que notamment
il était dans lesord public se justifie
donc je pense qu'on peut légitimement
voter ces articles 14b pour votre part
juste dire terminer peut-être sur un
sujet qui qui n'a rien à voir mais qui
était précédent puis j'ai entendu ça
m'avait interrogé mais je les avais pas
sous les yeux monsieur Dumont évoqué les
les les la relation que nous avons ave
que notre grand pays ami l'Algérie vous
évoquez les eqtf par rapport au laisser
passer consulaire monsieur Dumont pour
que nul ne soit totalement ignorant sur
sur la question il y a eu par exemple
premier semestre 2023 désolé c'est le
dernier chiffr que j'ai à jour non non
mais dernier chif non les dernier
dernier semestre premier semestre 2023
13260qtf pour des citoyens algériens
6000 6122 6000 qui eux sont des ETF qui
ne sont pas des ETF avec délai
volontaire parce que évidemment vous
prenez laisser passer consulère quand il
y a pas de délis volontaire
ou autres ITF donc ceux qui mériteraient
de laisser passer consulaire c'est 6000
bon et on en a demandé 2808 voilà donc
et on en est à plus de 900 acceptter
puisqueen général on met 3 mois pour les
recevoir donc on est bien d'accord c'est
pas parfait on en est à la moitié voilà
c'est c'est pas extraordinaire il faudra
qu'on se pose la question de savoir si
les délais lesf prix avec délais
volontaire les gens repartent on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler plus tard dans
le texte mais voilà pour montrer la
continuité du travail diplomatique qu'on
a fait avec l'Algérie et moi je merci le
gouvernement algérien et d's on a passé
me dit mon collaborateur l'ensemble des
documents pour Madame Dupont et Monsieur
le F dans le cadre de leur mission
particulière on voit que il y a une
progression très importante qui r que
l'Algérie elle est pas parfaite faut la
continuer mais correspond pas au
chiffres d' a un an et demi je vous
remercie je mets ces amendements de
suppression au voix qui est
pour qui est contre ils sont rejetés
amendement suivant madame yousoufa le
1134 s'il vous plaît merci madame la
Présidente alors cet amendement vise à
faire en sorte que le représentant de
l'État dans le département informe
également le Centre Communal d'Action
Social les différents organismes en
charge de la gestion des logements
sociaux et toutes les mairies du
département euh parce que ce que nous ce
que nous constatons c'est que lorsqu'il
y a une décision de refus de séjour de
retrait de titre de documents de séjour
ou d'expulsion euh certains étrangers
choisissent simplement de changer de
commune en profitant du manque de
communication entre les différentes
strates de de de l'appareil officiel si
je peux m'exprimer ainsi et en fait nous
on voit un nomadisme des des des des
familles qui sont en train de faire le
tour de l'île et donc à forciori à
Mayotte dans un espace insulaire clos on
espère que vous accepterez de de de
rendre automatique la communication par
les autorité préfectorale à l'ensemble
des autorités de la collectivité pour
qu'elle puisse prendre les mesures à
quoi puisque je rappelle queun fois que
la personne est régularisée ça lui ouvre
des droits il nous paraît normal de les
enlever une fois qu'elles ont plus ce
titre je vous remercie monsie
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
chers collègues je je comprends la
logique de cet amendement et j'y suis
assez sensible je parais toutefois poser
des des vrais sujets opérationnels de
capacité des préfectures à diffuser à
l'ensemble des communes CCAS bailleurs
sociaux et puis en plus après les
communes pour pour le traiter donc je je
vous demanderai de de le retirer parce
que je pense que c'est un sujet qui
mérite d'être retravaillé à défaut je
serai contrat d'émettre un avis
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté le
suivant de Monsieur di Philippo n'est
pas défendu monsieur gilet
oui merci monsieur le Président désolé
chers collègues bien pensant de gauche
mais la France n'a pas vocation à être
un guichet social pour clandestin
l'article que l'on discute prévoit que
les différents organismes ne peuvent pas
mettre fin aux droits sociaux de
l'étranger en situation irrégulière
avant la fin du 3e mois qui suit la date
d'expiration de ces autorisations cet
amendement propose donc d'accorder une
période plus raisonnable et donc plus
courte pour procéder à la radiation des
étrangers clandestin il n'y a
effectivement pas lieu d'attendre aussi
longtemps ce délai doit donc être réduit
à l'expiration du mois en cours
l'objectif est de garantir une radiation
rapide et réactive des droits sociaux
d'un étranger en station irrégulière et
d'éviter tout profit de de prestations
sociales sur notre territoire à des gens
je le rappelle qui seraient donc en
situation irrégulière et donc
clandestin rapporteur avis défavorable
le délai d'un mois est
opérationnellement intenable et en plus
les les équilibres de l'article me
paraissent
satisfaisant je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeter
l'amendement l'article 14 B qui vote
pour article qui vot contre adopté
l'article 14 C monsieur Luc le 51 madame
Rousseau cet amendement vise à
supprimer l'article 14 C qui consiste à
faire financer par les personnes
assignées à résidence leur assignation à
résidence je vous propose que on ne
fasse pas payer le stylo du juge ni
l'assignation à résident c'est qu'en
fait je sais même pas comment il est
possible d'avoir pensé à un article de
cette nature et je sais même pas comment
il il a pu arriver dans une loi vraiment
je je je m'interroge beaucoup sur
psychologie de nos sénateurs là depuis
le début de l'étude de ce texte parce
que dans quel état d'esprit peuvent-ils
être pour penser à ce type d'amendement
donc
suppression madame Chatelin n'est pas là
pour défendre son amendement madame
Martin
euh il s'agit là de de supprimer cet
article 14 C dans cette sorte de train
fantôme dans lequel nous sommes voilà
une nouvelle disposition qui vise
toujours pareil à compliquer la vie des
étrangers à la rendre infernale et à
renier sur leur droit y compris sur un
droit absolument fondamental qui est
quand même celui d'aller et venir
puisqu'il s'agit là d'avoir la capacité
de renouveler deux fois donc à 45 jours
l'assignation l'assignation à résidence
ça nous paraît totalement proportionné
ce d'autant plus que ça ne va rien
régler parce que disproportionné que
c'est pas j'ai pas compris j'ai j'ai ma
langue à fourcher ça ça nous paraît
d'autant plus disproportionné que comme
tout le de ce projet de loi ça ne
résoudra rien au bout de ces 135 jours
que va-t-il se passer
rien madame monsieur Vallot non madame
car oui merci monsieur le Président
écoutez au-delà
de voilà de de de ce que vient de dire
nos
collègues le le droit aujourd'hui suffit
amplement pour assurer le respect
justement des des assignations à
résidence et donc c'est cette à travers
ces mesures sont de P pour nous de pur
affichage et l'État aura donc les plus
grandes peines à ensurer l'application
de ces mesures aujourd'hui en France et
donc c'est pour cette raison là on on
propose la suppression de de cet
article le suivant pas défendu le
1356 madame Jacquier Laforge Mame des
Jonker défendu monsieur le
rapporteur merci merci merci monsieur le
Président je avis défavorable à ces
amendements de suppression toutefois en
pensant que sur deux dimensions euh
c'est et ça fait l'objet de deux
amendements que que j'ai déposé et que
j'aurai à défendre plus tard mais les
les deux dimensions sur lesquelles cet
article me paraî pouvoir être corrigé la
première c'est effectivement prendre en
compte la situation de solvabilité ou
plutôt d'insolvabilité de la personne
assignée à résidence pour qu' ne soit
pas mis à sa charge les les frais liés à
son asstion et d'autre part de prévoir
une motivation spéciale pour le dernier
renouvellement de 45 jours eu égard à la
durée de laassignation cumulée donc avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre
oui merci bon évidemment je je soutien
les amendements de monsieur le
rapporteur pour éviter parce que je
crois que en effet sur ce point le Sénat
n'a pas entendu la la remarque du
gouvernement que les personnes qui n'ont
pas de
quoi payer ces assignations résidence
qui sont parfois très chersres parce
qu'il s'agit d'unité d'hôtel par exemple
et pardon mais je ve le dire à Madame
Rousseau comme à madame Martin il ne
s'agit pas que de gens pauvres qui sont
assignés à résidence il y a parfois des
gens très très riche que nous assignons
à résidence avant leur expulsion
notamment dans le cas
de oui ah après vous pouvez laisser des
gens qui sont par expulsés parce que ils
ont ou éloignés parce que ils sont en
intelligence avec l'ennemi ou parce
qu'ils sont fr fiscal si vous voulez que
ce soit nous qui payons leur nuit
d'hôtel je voilà donc je pense qu'il a
une question non mais je réponds à
Madame Rousseau je réponds à Madame
Rousseau dans un premier temps ça
m'avait pas
échappé je et je salue votre solidarité
de group du
P non non je je c'est c'est
pas allez allez allez Contin c'est pas
c'est pas
voilà voilà vous fassiez partie du même
groupe allez vous faites partie je crois
du même groupe de la nupes avec Monsieur
Mélenchon comme premier ministre donc
voilà c'est un point
voilà deuxièmement l'assignation à
l'assignation à résidence l'assignation
à
allez s'il vous plaît la l'assignation à
résidence c'est pas des gens qui c'est
pas des gens qui restent à résidence
l'assignation à résidence c'est des gens
qui doivent y dormir pointer
éventuellement au commissariat mais qui
travaillent pour la plupart d'entre eux
qui ont une activité professionnelle
c'est pas des gens qui sont en rétention
donc c'est des gens qui travaillent donc
on une situation dans laquelle on peut
travailler pe qu'on peut travailler et
pour lequel l'État paye donc leur
assignation à résidence Le nuit d'hôtel
parce que ils doivent être éloignés pour
des raisons d'entre publi c'est le cas
par exemple de personnes terroristes qui
ont été condamné pour des actes
terroristes qui en attendant par exemple
que leur pays redevienne un pays avec
lequel on a des relations diplomatiques
ben oui à la fin de leur période de
prison ils sont assigné résidence par
décision de justice avec un contrôle
judiciaire la question est de savoir
l'état paye déjà en effet la présence
des policiers qui les surveillent et la
question est donc de savoir s'ils ont
des rémunérations s'ils ont du capital
pourquoi il ne payeraient pas leur
assignation résidence je trouve rien de
scandaleux à sur ça notamment modifié
par par les rapporteurs de Monsieur le
Rapp par les rapports de monsieur le
rapporteur alors Monsieur
camardine Merci monsieur le Président
moi je voudrais juste réagir par rapport
à ce que disait madame Rousseau à
l'endroit de nos amis sénateurs pour lui
dire que nos amis sénateurs passent
exactement et s'interrogent exactement
de la même manière que vous sur ce que
vous pensez quand ils sont sénateurs
notamment ce que vous voilà ce que je
voulais dire je crois que on éviteerit
les insultes à l'égard des
parlementaires les uns les autres n tout
le monde se trouverait très
biens madame
ki ah si si
c'est voilà
euh juste juste pour rappeler que cet
article n'aura en réalité que pour
conséquence de que de renforcer
l'exclusion et la précarisation des
personnes visées par ses assignations à
résidence d'ailleurs ces personnes se
trouvent souvent dans une espèce de
Limbe elles ne peuvent ni être
régularisées ni être expulsées et donc
elles sont maintenues sur le territoire
français tout en étant exclus de
l'ensemble de leurs droits donc la
réalité de cette assignation à résidence
c'est que c'est une privation de
liberté demandée par l'état français et
que ce n'est pas la personne assignée à
régler financièrement ce
problème il reste monsieur porte
inscrit merci Monsieur monsieur le
Président je crois qu'il y a quand même
quelque chose de totalement
irresponsable à vouloir faire payer
l'assignation en résidence à ces
personnes mais je reconnais bien la
philosophie de ce texte puisque le
porte-parole du gouvernement Olivier
verran avait dit à l'époque son modèle
c'était le Danemark notamment sur les
questions sur les questions migratoires
oui le Danemark a repris les a d'extrême
droite et d'ailleurs au Danemark il y a
une loi qui a été votée où on peut
saisir une partie des des biens
financiers et et des biens dont
disposent les gens quand ils arrivent
sur le territoire national donc il faut
faire très attention avec cette logique
et je rappelle quand même que dans ce
pays la dernière fois qu'on a saisi des
biens au nom de leur nationalité à des
personnes c'était dans dans des années
plus plutôt sombres de la République
donc là il y a des gens qui viennent
dans notre pays parce que parce qu'il y
a il y a des gens aujourd'hui qui
fuitient leur pays parce que leur pays
ravagé par la guerre parce que il y a le
capitalisme aujourd'hui qui crée des
migrations vous allez détruire ces pays
là et en plus vous demandez aux gens de
payer leur assignation ici mais vous
êtes totalement
irresponsable pour la Russie donc on va
voter qui vote pour les amendements de
suppression qui vote
contre nationalité française les
amendements de suppression sont
rejetés alors on essaie de continuer
monsieur le rapporteur le
1592 merci monsieur le Président 1592
vise comme je l'indiquais un petit peu
plus tôt à prévoir de façon explicite
qu'en cas d'insolvabilité les frais
restent à la charge de l'État et dire
aussi que l'objectif de cette mesure de
l'assignation à résidence c'est de
conduire la personne qui en fait l'objet
à quitter le territoire l'obj n pas de
de créer un statut complémentaire ou
supplémentaire par l'assignation à
résidence mais bien plutôt de créer les
conditions pour que la personne parte
d'elle-même je mets au voix qui vote
pour du rapporteur qui vote contre il
est adopté les deux suivants de monsieur
dippo ne sont pas défendu le 1602
monsieur oui nous avons pas réussi à
faire supprimer cet article
profondément on vous demande donc
d'essayer au moins de limiter la casse
sur le respect du droit vous prévoyez
dans une logique de fausse efficacité de
doubler deux fois l'assignation en
résidence de 45 jours pour la monter
jusqu'à 135 jours bon avec un argument
d'efficacité qui est celui ça nous
permettra d'expulser plus facilement les
gens c'est ce que vous avez fait pour la
rétention administrative dans les
centres de rétention alors le ministre
est déjà parti à chaque fois qu'on parle
d'écas il disparaît c'est toujours bien
pratique mais bon là on est quand même
sur l'arrétation administrative et bien
ça ne marche pas ça ne marche pas parce
que en effet s'est passé consulaires il
y a les réalités les recours car oui les
étrangers ont des droits et même si le
Sénat a voulu a voulu le mettre le
rétablir le séjour le délit de séjour
irrégulier n'est plus dans le texte
d'ailleurs madame jeunevar je vous a
exprimé il y a peu de temps disant que
c'était quand même une ligne rouge qui
avait été franchi je pense sincèrement
que vous êtes en train de
surcriminaliser la vision française de
l'étranger et que vous cassez les
possibilités de recours au droit
l'assignation à résidence casse la
possibilité à la défense des étrangers
monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur avis
défavorable voix qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est rejeté monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez un 1593
oui merci monsieur le Président il
s'agit comme là aussi je l'ai annoncé
plutôt de prévoir que le dernier
renouvellement de la période
d'assignation fasse l'objet d'une
motivation spécifique parce qu'il s'agit
effectivement de durée particulièrement
longue comme je le disais un petit peu
plus tôt en espérant de ne pas pas avoir
à la proncer puisque la personne sera
partie d'ici là je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre re je cro vous
votiz madame je je prie m'excuser
l'article 14 C qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est adopté le 14d Monsieur
Madame Rousseau madame rol qui défend
l'amendement 14d le
52 pardon moi aussi j'ai une absence
comme comme notre collègue et donc je
dirais
défendu madame tourgia le 848 merci nous
souhaitons par cet amendement supprimer
cet
article qui une fois de plus stigmatise
les personnes étrangères en amalgamant
délinquence et immigration puisque on
soupçonnerait quelles utilise de manière
malhonnête et détournée le l'aide au
retour dont elles doivent bénéficier
dans le cadre de une OQTF c'est
alimenter le fantasme c'est ce que nous
disions au tout début de l'examen de ce
texte alimenter le fantasme selon lequel
les les étrangers viennent chez nous
pour profiter de toutes les aides
sociales et y
compris viendrai pour récupérer l'aide
qu'il recevrait pour revenir au pays et
pour pouvoir rester bien sûr et
clandestinement et bien sûr forcément
ils en profiteraient par ailleurs pour
perpétrer des crimes et des délits
euh le suivant pas défendu le 1358
madame Jacquie Laforge madame
desjonkerer défendu
défendu le monsieur
rapporteur donc
euh sur sur ces amendements de
suppression là l'AVI est défavorable de
toute façon ce ce dispositif est déjà
mis en place par décret mais là il est
juste proposé de lui conférer valeur
législative avis
défavorable je mets au voix qui vote
pour contre rejeté sur l'article 14d qui
vote pour contre adopté après le 14d
madame jeevard
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
par cet amendement le groupe des
Républicains prévoit que les transferts
vers l'étranger des sommes touchées par
les demandeurs d'asile au titre de laada
soit interdit et pénalement sanctionné
alors pourquoi est-ce que nous
souhaitons que cette disposition soit
adoptée c'est vrai que par personne les
sommes sont modestes même si ça
représente tout de même un budget de de
plus de 300 millions mais la cible de
cet amendement ce sont les les fraudeurs
parce que et bien bien certaines
filières
d'immigration présumé sont en réalité
des filières de détournement
d'allocation bah oui en l'espèce c'est
une filière clandestine ukrainienne une
autre moldave qui ont détourné plus de
560000 € à la fin de l'année
2022 ce sont des autant de sommes qui
sont prises aux demandeurs d'asile qui
devrai pouvoir bénéficier donc il me
paraît très sain de lutter contre la
fraude chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur merci Monsieur monsieur le
Président je comprends je comprends
l'esprit de la mesure mais c'est vrai
que la mise en œuvre en paraî
particulièrement délicate et d'ailleurs
vous vous l'avez dit vous-même dans la
défense de l'amendement les sommes sont
modestes donc si des sommes sont
transférées il sera très difficile
d'établir quelle est la provenance
réelle de ces sommes et comment les
rattacher à la DA donc à ce titre je
suis amené à émettre un avis
défavorable madame
jeunevard nous ne sommes pas les seuls à
alerter sur ce danger puisquen 2019
l'OFPRA monsieur le le rapporteur a mis
en place une carte de paiement sans
possibilité de retrait d'espèce ni de
paiement en ligne pour la dase qui
permet de limiter les virements
bancaires vers l'étranger donc le danger
avait été identifié nous proposons
simplement de lui donner je dirais un
caractère opérationnel après tout depuis
un moment la France essaie de limiter la
fraude sociale je vous rappelle quand
même que la fraude sociale selon la Cour
des comptes atteint 8 milliards et demi
d'euros donc voilà un exemple de fraude
qui doit être sévèrement sanctionné hein
c'est pour ça que nous demandons une
sanction pénale et puis surtout faut
prendre les mesures pour empêcher
qu'elle ne se reproduise enfin tout cela
relève du bon sens tout de même bah si
monsieur coulum
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
jeevar quand même soyons un peu
raisonnable soyons un peu réaliste vous
vous rendez pas compte de ce que vous
dites la réalité c'est que nous avons
une fraude fiscale qui est évaluée en
France à plus de 100 milliards d'euros
et vous vous en prenez aux gens qui
envoient leur modeste écho dans des pays
lointains où où les gens laissez-moi
finir s'il vous plaît où finalement ils
permettent à des familles de rester dans
les pays d'origine et vous vous voudriez
leur couper parfois cette alimentation
là qu'ils ont depuis notre pays par des
gens qui sont venus travailler seuls sur
le territoire français mais vous allez
créer un aspirateur à immigration si
vous coupez aussi ce genrel de de de de
financement mais non vous le savez très
bien mais on voit vers où vont vos
affect prioritaire c'est pas contre la
lutte fiscale qui représente encore une
fois des dizaines de milliards dans
notre pays mais c'est les quelques
millions d'euros qui transit dans des
petites caisses pour aller alimenter des
villages au fin fond de
l'Afrique me vois votre amendement
madame jeunevard qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté
le 14e un amendement de suppression du
rapporteur 1594
oui monsieur le Président il s'agit de
de supprimer cet article 14e qui vise
spécifiquement la situation des dublinés
AL vous le savez nous sommes
actuellement en négociation très avancé
avec nos partenaires européens dans le
cadre
du pour aboutir à un texte commun
notamment réglementaire et à ce titre la
la position qui serait retenue qui n'est
pas strictement conforme aux position
que défend actuellement la France dans
le cadre de cette négociation pourrait
affaiblir notre position et conduire à
ne pas prendre en compte la défense
légitime de nos intérêts je je donne
donc un avis favorable aux amendements
de suppression monsieur porte le
suivant non mais c'est enfin dans
l'Esprit nous ne sommes pas d'accord
pour que soit étendu aux personnes qu'on
dit dublinisé ce qui est quand même pas
très très joli euh et donc il a cette
extension de la possibilité de les
placer en rétention administrative il
nous semble que le leur parcours leur
situation et cetera sont
suffisamment complexes et et
douloureuses comme cela et qu' n'est pas
utile d'en ajouter bon
voilà Monsieur Lucas
oui ben écoutez euh une fois de plus ma
collègue Martin a dit euh l'essentiel
est bien plus que l'essentiel compte
tenu des des conditions difficiles de
trajet d'arrivver sur le terr
connaissent les Prim arrivant cette
mesure ne constitue qu'une sanction
pénalisante de plus sans intérêt en
terme ni d'accueil d'inclusion nous
sommes donc favorable à sa
suppression Monsieur Madame desjonker le
1361 Madame Dupont le
suivant merci cet article vise à étendre
le placement rétention des personnes
sous procédure
Dublin je je rappelle que le placement
rétention doit pas devenir la norme et
bien constituer un dernier recours en
définitive et je pense que la refonte
globale des textes relatifs aux
migration dans le cadre du Pacte
migratoire européen comme l'a évoqué
monsieur le rapporteur mérite pour nous
de ne pas statuer pour le moment
puisqueon on va avoir des modifications
certainement induites par cette
évolution européenne donc je suis je
pense qu'il faut supprimer cet article
et je pense que le le demandeur d'asile
dubliné ne répond pas aux
caractéristiques n'a donc pas vocation à
être placé en rétention et surtout pas
de façon
systématique je me vois si amement su
pardon monsieurppteur j'ai présumer
votre votre avis favorable que vous avez
donné monsieur Dumont ou merci monsieur
le Président bon évidemment on sera
opposé à la suppression de cet article
qui a été introduit au Sénat mais ça
permet d'attirer l'attention sur la
question des dublinés on sait que c'est
un véritable sujet qu'en réalité
aujourd'hui le système ne fonctionne pas
qu'on est face à un nombre important de
demandeur d'asile euh qui pourrai
potentiellement être dubliné parce
qu'ils ont déjà déposé une demande
d'asile dans un pays autre de l'Union
européenne par exemple les les les
Autrichiens 11000 11000 demandes ont été
faites d'un d'un étranger demande
d'asile ont été faites par un étranger
qui a déjà fait une demande d'asile en
Autriche en 2022 et à peine 3000 ont été
euh ont été renvoyés donc c'est ça pose
un vrai sujet aujourd'hui sur
l'application de cela et sur le fait de
comment est-ce qu'on fait dans une
situation où les frontières sont libres
et tant mieux au sein de l'espace
Schengen pour voir des multiples
demandeurs d'asile et cette proposition
qui a éé introduite au Sénat permet de
pouvoir au moins réduire leses
difficultés sur les quelques cas qu'on
réussi et qu'on a la volonté de Dubliner
alors je mets au voix ces amendements de
suppression qui vottre pour les
amendements de suppression don celui du
rapporteur qui vote contre contre les
amendement
suppression donc ils sont adoptés il
suppriment l'article
14e l'amendement suivant tombe par
conséquent le 14 14 F monsieur Lucas
voulez défendre votre amendement 54
merci monsieur le Président il est
défendu défendu monsieur monsieur
rapporteur oui parce que l'autre tombe
défavorable je mets au voix cet
amendement de suppression de l'article
défvorable du rapporteur qui vote pour
contre il est rejeté le
934 madame
Martin toujours dans dans dans cette
même
logique d'ajouter sans cesse et sans
cesse des sanctions des contraintes des
privations de liberté hein moi j'entends
l'assignation à résidence dans un
certain nombre de situation on peut
aller travailler la journée mais enfin
c'est quand même une restriction d'aller
et venir lorsque l'on n'est pas assigné
à résidence on peut on peut bien
circuler y compris y compris le soir
donc bon voilà les raisons pour
lesquelles on ne veut pas que
l'assignation à
résidence soit un élément supplémentaire
de de tracasserie et cetera à l'égard à
l'égard de ceux qu'on voudrait renvoyer
dans parfois un improbable chez eux
monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable car la sanction
fait partie des mesures parfois
nécessaires pour rendre effective le
respect d'une règle je mets au voix cet
amendement avec défavorable du
rapporteur qui vote pour contre rejeté
l'article 14 F qui vote pour contre
adopté 14g monsieur le rapporteur un
amendement de suppression amendement de
suppression afin de voir les
dispositions de cet article
là où elle doiv être c'estàd dans le
titre s rapporté par notre collègue
servsieur
Lucas défendu monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez un avis favorable à votre propre
amendement qui vaê pour les amendements
de suppression dont celui du
rapporteur qui vote
contre ils sont adoptés suppriment
l'article 14g il font tomber
l'amendement
962 amendement à l'article 14 monsieur
merci Monsieur le le président donc
c'est un amendement de suppression de
l'article 14 évidemment ici tout le
monde s'oppose au réseau de passeur et
dénonce l'utilisation de la misère
humaine et l'exploitation de ces
personnes qui fuient leur pays pour des
causes climatiques pour la guerre pour
des menaces et qui sont utilisés par des
gens qui font de de l'argent sur leur
dos simplement ça a été montré par le
passé sur différents sujets augmenter le
quantum des peines ne permet pas
d'entraver cela et ça ne pose pas aussi
la question encore une fois qui est
évacué dans ce débat la question de
pourquoi les gens partent de chez eux et
on le répètera à chaque fois personne ne
décide de partir de chez soi de manière
spontanée en disant je suis super
heureux je pars je quitte ma maison je
vais dans un autre pays je traverse la
Méditerranée je vais être obligé
d'utiliser des réseaux de passeur
aujourd'hui il faut évoquer la question
de pourquoi ces gens partent et moi
j'aurais aimé qu'il y a des amendements
qui visent des gens qui aujourd'hui font
des profits dans ces pays-là et
notamment ça a été cité par mon collègue
Loman Vincent Boloré et le commerce par
exemple du bois qui a financé des
guerres au liberriens en sierraaléone
qui finance après des réseaux de
passeurs qui oblige les gens à partir
parce qu'on a créé des guerres dans ces
pays et ils sont obligés de fuir parce
que ils sont menacés par des financiers
français qui ont exploité leur
territoire on va laisser s'installer les
rapporteur mais moi je suis quand même
très surpris de votre am de suppression
monsieur porte ce que vous nous proposez
aujourd'hui c'est de de supprimer la
criminalisation des réseaux de faceur
Suppr non de supprimer le fait que l'on
passe d'un délit à un crime pour la
criminalité organisé des passeurs donc
en réalité vous ne souhaitez pas que ces
personnes soient durement condamnées
qu'elles puissent se voir infliger des
peines de prison qui sont extrêmement
importantes que l'on puisse empêcher et
démanteler des filières qui aujourd'hui
organisent le passage et notamment en
Méditerranée ou de la Manche et donc je
suis vraiment très surpris par cet
amendement de suppression qui à mon avis
n'a pas beaucoup de sens monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
alors tout comme vous je suis vraiment
vraiment surpris en fait par par cette
proposition de la France insoumise
portée par Thomas
porte parce que en fait ils veulent
supprimer un article qui aroit les
sanctions contre les réseaux de passeurs
mettant en danger les migrants je
pensais que au contraire que cette mure
serait consensuelle que vous seriez pour
et vous démontrez à nouveau en fait que
votre seul objectif vous pensez vous
démontrez que votre seul objectif
c'est de faire en sorte de d'être contre
tout et vous ne voulez pas protéger les
personnes et donc on est totalement
défavorable monsieur
Dumont moi pardon mais évidemment qu'il
est nécessaire de criminaliser les
réseaux de passeur je vais vous parler
de chez moi dans la Manche la mer du
Nord ceux qui organisent les traversées
ce sont des personnes
qui sont très sincèrement installés soit
en Allemagne soit ailleurs en Europe
soit en France soit au Royaume-Uni qui
ach sur internet des bateaux qui achète
sur internet des moteurs et qui met des
malheureux sous toutes conditions sur S
rafiot parfois sans julet sauvetage et
les font mourir dans la Manche comment
est-ce que vous voulez laisser passer
ces réseaux de passeurs ces criminels
ces meurtriers en les laissant
s'exonérer toute responsabilité
évidemment qu'il faut les sanctionner
évidemment qu'il faut criminaliser
évidemment qu'il faut le faire pour une
raison qui est très simple c'est que
chez moi dans la Manche il faut qu'on
arrête d'avoir des morts et c'est un des
moyens c'est pas le seul mais c'est un
des moyens qui est absolument essentiel
cet amendement de suppression de cet
article qui vise à la criminalisation
des réseaux de passeur est une folie
pure et simple monsieur rigz
oui merci monsieur le Président nous
nous opposons également avec le groupe
Renaissance à à cet amendement qui est
totalement
irresponsable il est incroyable
d'entendre la France insoumise dire
qu'elle ne veut pas sanctionner des
réseaux de passeurs des réseau criminel
je tiens quand même à préciser par
rapport à l'argument qui est donné par
rapport à des citoyens engagés des on
humanitaire elles ne sont absolument pas
visées dans cet amendement absolument
pas par ailleurs par rapport à la à la
disproportion des peines le Conseil
d'État était très clair les peines ne
sont manifestement pas disproportionné à
la gravité des agissements qu'il entend
réprimer nous parlons bien d'agissement
criminel c'est pour ça que nous
rejetterons cet amendement je vous
remercie la suite monsieur Lucas
Monsieur L vous finirez merci monsieur
le Président je voulais quand même venir
en défense de de notre collègue j'ai
entendu monsieur Dumont dire vous êtes
êtes les les amis des passeurs je vais
vous dire qui sont les véritables agents
si ce n'est les banquiers des passeurs
ce sont ceux qui depuis 40 ans
considèrent qu'une législation brutale
et répressive sur l'immigration est
nécessaire pourquoi parce que plus il
est difficile de passer nos frontières
plus les conditions d'accès et d'accueil
au territoires français sont difficiles
plus les passeurs augmentent leurs
tarifs donc en réalité les politiques
les 30 lois immigration en 40 ans n'ont
eu qu'un effet concret palpable c'est
plus d'argent dans la poste dans la
poche des passeurs donc il y a une là
une énorme une énorme hypocrisie à se
faire des peintures de guerre sur le
torse en disant nous combattons les
passeurs nous combattons les passeurs
quand en réalité on construit des
politiques publiques qui favorisent
l'enrichissement des passeurs et nous
aurons l'occasion de revenir sur les
associations qui ne sont absolument pas
protégé par ce dispositif et qui mérite
de l'être Monsieur
léomand Merci monsieur le Président bon
beaucoup de mauvaise fois dans les
réponses qui nous sont apportées sur cet
amendement sur cet amendement de
suppression de l'article puisque déjà
petittin ça existe déjà la la la
possibilité de réprimer ceux qui font ce
ce ce trafic d'être humain et qui font
les passeurs donc petit 1 ça existe déjà
petit 2 toutes les études montrent que
aggraver les peines ne sert à rien pour
lutter contre les comportements et que
ça n'apporte absolument rien donc que
c'est inefficace vous arrêtez pas
d'augmenter les peines surtout et vous
vous plaignez sans arrêt du fait qu'il y
a une augmentation de la criminalité
posez-vous des questions au bout d'un
moment sur ce que vous êtes en train de
faire petit 2 petit tr vous visez avec
ça aussi les associations qui viennent
en aide aux personnes en situation de
migration et qui d'une certaine manière
parfois oui c'est vrai aide certaines
personnes à franchir la frontière juste
pour éviter qu'elles meurent voilà c'est
de ça dont il s'agit et c'est ça que
vous voulez criminaliser donc arrêtez
d'être de mauvaise foi évidemment que
tout le monde veut lutter contre la la
criminalité en bande organisée contre le
trafic d'êttres humains enfin ça fait
partie de nos engagements humanistes
fondamentaux mais on lutte efficacement
contre l'immigration si jamais c'est ça
votre objectif en évitant de faire en
sorte que les gens partent de chez eux
c'est-à-dire en en créant les conditions
pour qu'ils puissent rester chez eux et
notamment en arrêtant de per les pays
qui sont des pays d'émigration voilà
c'est comme ça qu'on fait monsieur le
ministre
oui non je dire deux choses d'abord
c'est évidemment un
article extrêmement
important qui a été d'ailleurs décidé
par le gouvernement avec Monsieur
gardesso que je remercie suite au drame
dans la mer de manche de novembre
2021 évidemment on constate tous que des
délits existent mais que les peines
prononcé par les magistrats sont des
petites peines non pas parce que
magistrat serait laxist mais parce que
ils appliquent aujourd'hui le code pénal
et ce code pénal prévoit qu'être passeur
être marchand demander à des enfants des
femmes des vieillards de l'argent pour
le faire passer dans un autre pays c'est
d'ailleurs d'abord très bien rémunéré et
ensuite ce n'est que condamn que jusqu'à
50 prisons et 30000 € d'amende donc
autant vous dire que ce n'est pas
extrêmement dissuasif et évidemment ce
trafic de passeurs fait naîre beaucoup
d'argent qui par ailleurs et la police
l'a plusieurs fois des GSI des GSE
confondu avec les trafics de stupéfiants
les trafics de terrorisme les trafics de
proxinétisme et c'est une évidence que
ces trafics se nourrissent et ne sont
pas là pour la bien séance c'est donc un
un article très important qui vise de
passer de délit à crime jusqu'à 15 ans
de prison 20 ans si à mort et donc
permettra évidemment d'être à la hauteur
de ce que coûte
je crois les drames que que nous
connaissons toutes et tous euh j'attire
effectivement l'attention aussi que le
supprimer est absurde pour ne pas dire
contre-productif et enfin je veux
vraiment dire à quel point c'est
incompréhensible de la part je crois de
la France insommist que de le faire le
deuxième sujet c'est évidemment le fait
que les les associations ne sont
absolument pas concernées puisque sauf
si elles demandent rémunération pour
faire passer les gens d'une frontière à
l'autre ce qu'elles ne font évidemment
pas euh ici ne sont concernés et définis
comme passeurs que les personnes qui
demandent de l'argent pour pouvoir
passer d'un endroit à un autre donc il
s'agit pas de criminaliser les
associations qui doivent respecter les
règles de droit comme tout le monde bien
évidemment mais il s'agit pas de les
condamner à 20 ans de prison c'est pas
du tout l'objet du texte ne faites pas
croire ce qui ce qui n'a pas écrit dans
ce texte enfin je voudrais juste dire à
Monsieur Lucas que la criminalisation
des passeurs c'est également ce que fait
le gouvernement de Monsieur Scholz avec
les vers allemands je peux d'autant plus
te dire avec les ver allemand avec les v
allement avec les ver allements ils sont
dans le gouvernement ils sont dans le
gouvernement et donc ma collègue ma
collègue SPD ministre de l'Intérieur qui
est une femme d'autorité et de bien qui
souhaite ensemble que nous que nous
portions commun en commun cette
criminalisation des des passeurs et
soutenu évidemment par la coalition
puisque c'est la disposition que nous
avons mis en place ensemble en
tantintérieur donc voilà peut-être que
quand les vers sont en responsabilité
ils veulent criminaliser les passeurs je
le constate
voilà
bien je mets au voix cet amendement de
suppression avec avis défavorable du
rapporteur et du gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté le
suivant madame
déjonkerer merci président cet
amendement l'objectif est de lutter
efficacement contre la traite d'êtres
humains et il convient de s'assurer en
particulier que le crime ne paye pas
voilà monsieur le
rapporteur donc vous proposez que la
peine complémentaire de confiscation
soit ajoutée à l'Arsenal visant les
passeurs
a un risque constitutionnel c'est assez
délicat de pouir le faire globalement
c'est déjà prévu en fait dans le CZ donc
c'est satisfait je propose de le
retirer
ok retirer le 536 538 pas défendu le
1120 Madame
Dupont est pas
le 590 pas défendu non
plus le 933 Monsieur B
ce sera oui merci monsieur le Président
alors cet amendement vise à retirer à
supprimer dans l'article n'a donné lieu
à aucune contrepartie directe ou
indirecte pourquoi
supprimer ce cette expression parce que
on pourrait étendre l'immunité aux actes
consistants à fournir des conseils ou à
de l'accompagnement jurridique
linguistique ou social et toute aide
autre aide apporté dans un but
exclusivement humanitaire autrement dit
si on n d'une façon
indirecte le l'arrivée et je tiens
d'abord à juste à dire
que nous sommes contre les passeurs qui
qui évidemment que c'est un crime et que
ça aujourd'hui c'est un délit mais que
le passage le passage pour contre de
l'argent est bien sûr tout à fait
illégal mais l'aide humanitaire qui
consisterait à donner des conseils
juridiqu à à quelqu'un qui arriverait de
façon illégale doit pouvoir toujours
subsister monsieur le
rapporteur alors le champ de l'exemption
humanitaire est clairement défini et il
est respecté dans ce texte d'ailleurs ça
a été rappelé le Conseil constitionnel
était vigilant là-dessus dans une
question priire de constitionnalité en
2018 en date du 6 juillet donc là-dessus
c'est garanti si on vote votre
amendement une entreprise ou n'importe
qui pourrait proposer avec des
contreparties financières d'accompagner
les migrants ce qui fait qu'on est plus
dans l'aide humanitaire l'exemption
humanitaire justement c'est ce côté on
ne n'a pas de contrepartie financière
donc de fait c'est satisfait et il y a
pas de remise en question dans ce dans
cet article dans cette réécriture
d'article de se sortir le volet
humanitaire donc vous êtes satisfait je
vous propose de le retirer ou alors on
est
défavorable madame kiloi répondre non
oui on on peut le retirer mais il y a
tout de même une incertitude juridique
je tiens à le souligner
retirer le suivant monsieur Lucas madame
regol merci monsieur le Président il y a
beaucoup de raison d'être fier d'être
français pour la beauté de nos paysages
ou toutes nos valeurs mais il y en a
surtout une c'est qu'au fronton de nos
mairies il est noté liberté égalité
fraternité et c'est le sens de cet
amendement qui demande la reconnaissance
du principe de fraternité qui fait
partie intégrante de notre devise
républicaine parce qu'en fait quand on
porte assistant à une personne en danger
parce qu'elle a faim parce qu'elle est
blessée parce qu'elle a besoin d'être
protégée et bien quand cette personne
est une personne migrante c'est pass
possible de an d'emprisonnement et de
30000 € d'amende or tout ça c'est
simplement soulager un peu la détresse
de personnees ça fait partie de ce qui
composent la solidarité et la fraternité
nous nous opposerons toujours les
écologistes enans faille à la
criminalisation de la fraternité et
demandons une reconnaiss ence explicite
du principe de fraternité c'est le gage
de nos valeurs républicaines de l'idéal
d'universalité des droits de l'homme
dont notre Constitution nous porte monur
le
rapporteur en fait madame réol c'est
exactement ce que prévoit le droit
actuel d'ailleurs le Conseil
constitutionnel en effet dit dans sa
décision dont je parlais tout à l'heure
je cite qu'il découle du principe de
fraternité la liberté d'aider autrui
dans un but humanitaire sans
considération de la régularité de son
séjour sur le territoire et c'est
exactement ce que prévoit l'article
l8239 du CZ donc en fait vous êtes
pleinement satisfaite par rapport à ce
que vous venez nous dire dans les dans
les textes c'est confirmé par le Conseil
constitionnel je vous propose soit un
retrait soit défavorable madame
rol alors d'une d'une part je maintiens
et si c'était une réalité nous n'aurions
pas inscrit des amendes et des
condamnations de ce type il n'y aurait
pas eu un procès contre quelqu'un comme
Cédric herou par exemple et des dizaines
voire des centaines de militants qui
cherchent à porter aide à des personnes
en danger ne se retrouveraiit pas dans
des situations difficiles j'entends
votre argument monsieur le rapporteur
mais la réalité des faits
malheureusement contredit tout ce que
vous venez d'avancer monsieur rapporteur
alors justement c'est l'affaire herou
qui a permis cette QPC et c'est là que
le Conseil consal a garanti ces
droits-là ces droits humanitaires donc
c'est
satisfait aue donc vous le maintenez je
le mets au voix qui votre pour qui votre
contre rejeté le 405 qui le défend au
rassemblement national monsieur gilet
oui chers collègues si nous voulons être
efficace en matière de lutte contre
l'immigration il faut évidemment
réprimer davantage les passeurs et leurs
éventuels complices mais pour être
efficace en matière de lutte contre
l'immigration illégale il faut aussi
évidemment avoir une politique globale
et couper notamment les pompes
aspirantes en la matière vous le savez
hein Marine Le Pen est largement
plébiscitée par les Français et a un
programme clair et c'est pas pour rien
et c'est pas pour rien que 80 % des
Français récl des des décisions fermes
pardon en matière d'immigration ils
veulent que l'on agisse avec cet
amendement nous vous proposons de
limiter l'exonération de la
responsabilité pénale de ceux qui
viennent en aide aux migrants il faut la
limiter à évidemment pour que elle soit
limité sans contreparti à des biens
propres à permettre la survie de
l'étranger il faut que ça reste de
l'humanitaire il faut que cette
exonération pénale reste dans un cadre
très précis encadré pour qu'il n'y ait
pas d'abus monsieur le rapporteur cette
restcription me semble totalement en
fait all à l'esprit de à l'encontre de
l'esprit de la mesure que nous sommes en
train de voter ça va à l'encontre de ce
que je viens de dire justement sur le le
volet de fraternité de reconnaissance
humanitaire validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel donc totalement
défavorable je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeter le 995
monsieur
Lucas bien dans la suite de ce qui a été
dit nous voulons garantir en fait que
les associations humanitaires puissent
sauver des vies elles font un travail
que souvent les États devraient assurer
et moi je veux à rebour complet de ce
qu'a dit le représentant de l'extrême
droite qui s'est exprimé il y a un
instant jetant la suspicion sur les
vrais et les fausses humanitaires dire
toute l'admiration qui est la nôtre pour
ces ONG pour ses bénévoles pour ces
humanitaires qui euh en Méditerranée
dans les Alpes dans nos villes dans nos
villages remplissent finalement une
mission d'humanité tout simplement et
font vivre bien mieux que certains ici
les valeurs de la République liberté
égalité fraternité qui donne d'ailleurs
un peu d'optimisme et d'espoir dans ce
moment où nous voyons le débat public
englouti sous les thèmes et les termes
de l'extrême droite poussé par une
droite radicalisée et devant la la
rédition race campagne du gouvernement
et de la majorité présidentielle et bien
nous trouvons chez eux une source
d'espoir et d'optimisme monsieur le
rapporteur les associations fournissant
une aide humanitaire aux étrangers sont
couvertes par l'exemption pénale
humanitaire prévu à l'article 8239 du CZ
je l'ai répété à plusieurs reprises
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce cet amendement là il
est satisfait votre amendement monsieur
Lucas et et le respect de l'État de
droit passe aussi par là on n'est pas
toujours dans l'obligation de de de
rédiger les choses de cette façon là
parce que c'est garanti et le Conseil
constitutionnel a apporté son concours
pour définir comme vous le faites vous
démontrer que c'est bien humanitaire et
que ça n'a aucun risque particulier donc
défavorables auou
retrait je le mets au voix qui vote pour
qui vote contre il est rejeté l'article
14 qui vote pour contre adopté après
l'article 14 monsieur Lucas le
174 merci Monsieur le le président euh
nous voulons euh
euh proposer l'instauration d'un délit
d'entrave au droits d'asile euh qui
serait constitué lorsqu'un individu
perturbe l'accès au territoire français
dans le but de faire obstacle à
l'étranger qui demande à entrer en
France au titre de l'asile qui perturbe
l'accès aux établissements
administration juridiction compétent en
matière d'asile la libre circulation des
personnes à l'intérieur de de ces locaux
les conditions de travail des personnels
qui communique à l'étranger ou diffuse y
compris par voie électronique ou en
ligne des allégations ou incitations de
nature à l'induire intentionnellement en
erreur sur ces droits ou qui exerce des
menaces ou tout acte d' d'intimidation
nous nous avons souvenir de ces milices
faschisantes qui étaient allé jouer à la
police des frontières au col de
l'échelle les amis du rassemblement
national euh à Montgenèvre et il nous
paraît et au col de l'échelle également
avec des moyens d'ailleurs dont il
serait pertinent d'interroger la
provenance hein quand on a les moyens de
se payer un hélicoptère pour aller faire
démonstration de son racisme et de sa
xénophobie ça interroge sur les réseaux
de financement il y aurait la matière à
enquêter
d'ailleurs monsieur euh madame
caramandli monsieur Valot le suivant
caramandz 2 secondes je l'ai perd
excusez-moi ça vous fait une pause alors
oui tout à fait monsieur le Président
effectivement c'est amendement qui qui
propose une nouvelle un peu réécriture
de de cet article parce que on cherche
on vise à créer justement un délit
d'entrave au droit d'asile justement de
sorte à pouvoir sanctionner les
individus qui qui commettent des actes
de nature à entav siment finalement
l'exercice du droit d'asile en France je
pense que comme d'autres délits
effectivement cette incrimination mérite
d'être porter dans ce texte pour
compléter et pour donner un message plus
clair monsieur le
rapporteur al j'entends parfaitement vos
propositions et l'enjeu est important et
je crois qu'on peut partager une partie
de ces en en jeu euh mais il faut
pouvoir garantir qu'il ne soit pas
applicable aux forces de l'ordre dans le
cadre de leur activité légitime seul
aujourd'hui les agents de police peuvent
interdire à quelqu'un de rentrer sur le
territoire national ensuite je dis à
supposer car le droit en vigueur me
paraît déjà à même de sanctionner ce qui
entrave de façon scandaleuse j'en
conviens l'exercice du droit d'asile et
on est d'accord là-dessus je veux dire
que l'idée c'est quand même d'apporter
des réponses mais l'État par l'article
4311 du code pénal répond déjà on l'a
fait avec la par exemple la dissolution
de génération identitaire qui av été
lancé par le ministère de l'Intérieur
Gérald d'Anin on peut contrôler les
frontières édifier des obstacles
reconduire des migrants à la frontière
tombe sous le coup du délit d'imicion
dans une de la dans une fonction
publique donc l' rité c'est que le code
pénal garantit déjà ses réponses on
pourrait apporter des réponses
complémentairire en état l'écriture ne
garantit pas d'apporter ses réponses et
je propose au rapporteur général de vous
apporter des des des des points
complémentaires pour vous expliquer là
où on pourrait aller mais là en l'état
je suis défavorable selon l'écriture
proposée monsieur le rapporteur gén
oui mais quelques mots simplement à
l'attention notamment de Madame car
monsieur
Lucard toutes les situations dans
lesquel
effectivement sont organisés des groupes
venus de l'ultraadroite qui consistent à
interdire l'accès aux établissements aux
administrations aux juridictions dans le
cadre de cette procédure d'asile qui est
un trésor qui est un trésor républicain
conventionnel et républicain mérite à
mon sens en effet de trouver une
sanction
approprié pour la séance je vous propose
qu'on avance très concrètement sur ce
sujet et je souhaite à titre personnel
mais je crois me faire l'éch d'un très
grand nombre de de députés de la
commission des lois et au-delà je
souhaite qu'onon sorte de ce texte si
j'ose dire en ayant créé en effet un
délit d'entrave au au droit d'asile
voilà je pense que c'est très important
si l'on peut sortir du texte avec cet
acquis qui serait une première et qui
serait pas simplement symbolique qui
permettrait d'aboutir à des résultats
concrets au-delà cela a été dit par le
rapporteur d'un certain nombre d'outils
juridiques existants qui sont déjà
puissants mais qui ne condamn pas
spécifiquement l'entrave à ce trésor
juridique que le délit d'entrave que
pourrait être le délit d'entrave donc à
la à la demande d'asile aussi moi je
vous propose de retirer vos amendements
et que nous puissions travailler avec
bien sûr l'accord du ministre pour la
séance sur ce nouvel objet juridique qui
serait extrêmement important à mes
yeux
oui le gouvernement particulièrement
favorable parce que ce délit d'entrave
qui qui existe évidemment j'entends la
question de Monsieur rapporteur général
pour évidemment qu'il y a aucun soupçon
sur les forces de l'ordre d'exclure
directement le sujet qui les
concernerait c'est aussi ce qui nourrit
le le fonctionnement des passeurs
puisque nous constatons à plusieurs
reprises notamment c'est le cas monsieur
le député vous le savez dans dans la
région des des Haut- de-fance des
passeur qui empêche le dépôt des
demandes d'asile pour pouvoir unérer
leur vulnérabilité ne pas avoir accès au
droit et du coup tenter l'aventure vers
l'Angleterre donc je pense que c'est à
la fois un sujet humanitaire personne
n'en disconen mais aussi c'est un sujet
de de de lutte contre ses passeurs et et
le dossier qui peut se constituer contre
eux donc je pense qu'il y a à travailler
collectivement pour trouver une
rédaction pour la
séance alors moi j'entends bien
effectivement c'est cette préoccupation
qui qui est partagée apparemment
d'ailleurs c'est mal puisqueon un
certain nombre de rapports que nous
avons réalisé dans les commissions
affaires européennes ou même ici
précédemment on l'avait déjà soulevé ce
ce problème cependant c'est pas pour
autant que on on accepte de retirer cet
amendement parce que non mais le
rapporteur monie le rapporteur ça permet
d'affirmer et de d'acter quelque chose
sur lequel nous pouvons travailler par
la suite et d'ailleurs mon collègue ici
présent Lucas va prolonger le
l'argumentaire pour travailler ensemble
et essayer de de porter communement euh
une réponse à cette
problématique alors Monsieur Lucas merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général moi je vous propose
qu'on fonctionne un peu autrement c'est
plutôt que de nous suggérer de retirer
pour qu'ensuite vous déposiez qu'on
accepte cet amendement et que vous
l'amendiez au cours au cours de la
séance ce serait une manière de
coconstruire que par ailleurs vous avez
déjà mis en œuvre avec euh un certain
nombre de propositions issues du Sénat
et de LR et donc je trouve qu'il y
aurait une forme de traitement
différencié entre ce qui viendrai de la
gauche et ce qui viendrai de la droite
qui serait assez qui serait assez
dommage vous avez accepté par P entier
desbout du programme de Madame Le Pen
poussé par la droite radicalisée dans ce
texte là nous avons une belle unanimité
sur un sujet sur un sujet humanitaire
sur un sujet républicain qui peut nous
rassembler je vous demande monsieur le
rapporteur une preuve d'amour si je puis
dire plutôt qu'une simple déclaration
d'amour voilz je suis je me suis marié
il n'y a pas si longtemps que ça je
crois que l'amour sur un de chos mérite
des preu et des engagements et par
ailleurs j'ai effectivement vous le
savez assez peu confiance dans cette
majorité donc je demande un engagement
ferme une preuve d'ici avec le vote de
cet amendement et bien toutes mes
félicitations monsieur Lucas monsieur
Dumont merci monsieur le Président c'est
c'est plutôt pour une précision par
rapport aux auteurs de de l'amendement
et au est-ce que cela veut dire chers
collègues auteurs de l'amendement que si
on prend le cas de la jungle de caléis
qui a été créé par la gauche socialiste
au pouvoir 10000 personnes le plus grand
bidon ville d'Europe est-ce que cela
veut dire qu'avec l'adoption de votre
amendement les associations No Border
qui passaient après les agents de Lofi
qui agents de Lofi qui incitaent les les
personnes qui étaient là à déposer
l'asile et des associations No Border
qui leur disaient surtout ne déposez pas
l'asile restez pas en France allez au
Royaume-Uni est- que ces associations là
pourrai rentrer dans le champ de ce que
vous préconisez via cet
amendement alors monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur le ministre qu'est-ce
qu' veut monsieur rapporteur général ah
pardon non mais monsieur Lucas moi des
preuves
sinon d'amour en tout cas d'affection
moi j'en donne j'en donne beaucoup mes
preuves sont
inombrables elles sont presque
quotidiennes je compris dans cette
commission et sur ce texte enfin je ne
vais pas rappeler la belle matinée nous
onons passer ensemble sur l'interdiction
de la rétention des mineurs non ce ce
que je vous propose c'est que je parle
bien d'un amendement qui serait déposé
par vous-même mais qui apporterait pour
je parle pas d'un amendement que
j'adosserai en tant que rapporteur
général mais votre amendement pose une
série difficulté telle qu'il est écrit
aujourd'hui à la fois la réponse à la
question posée par Monsieur Dumont même
si elle était fcétieuse mais euh mais
euh elle elle comportait des éléments de
fond la sécurité aussi cela a été dit
par par Monsieur le Ministre concernant
le rôle des forces de l'ordre il faut
bien sûr sécuriser l'intervention des
forces de l'ordre on parle bien de
celles et ceux qui organisaient ce sont
des groupes puscules vise à empêcher la
demande d'asile on parle pas évidemment
de l'intervention des forces de l'ordre
qui est plus que légitime donc je je
vous propose et je continue à vous
proposer un retrait pour un amendement
que nous pourrions travailler ensemble
pour la séance et que nous pourrons
partager par nos votes mais que vous
assumerez non mais je je pense que il y
a un sujet force de l'ordre je pense que
en effet je crois que Monsieur dubont A
a relevé à mon avis quelque chose que
n'avez pas forcément vu monsieur le
député ducat le fait que les
associations qui en l'occurrence empêche
les agents de l'ofice de faire leur
travail empêche ce dépôt d'asile dans la
jungle dans l'ex j de calé à grande
sainte et qui voulait directement
envoyer les gens en Angleterre je pense
notamment à No Border par exemple B
serait dans le CH de votre amendement
donc effectivement c'est c'est un ça
pour l'instant intéressant
voilà je je me VO am identique maintenu
qui vote pour qui vote contre ils sont
rejetés en attendant la séance on va
faire une pause à la demande express de
Madame jeunevar pour une durée de 15 15
minutes
voilà à tout à
l'heure allez on
reprends alors on reprend mais
malheureusement le 1341 n'est pas
défendu le 7 c'est un amendement modem
monsieur le
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
l'objectif de cet
amendement si je si j'avais mes lunette
ça serait mieux mais c'est pas grave je
le connais par
cœur c'est de c'est de de déétendre aux
étudiants étrangers l'article 15 qui
vient protéger les personnes vulnérables
de la mise à disposition des logements
insalubres pourquoi les étudiants
étrangers parce que les étudiants sont
déjà tous en situation de précarité de
vulnérabilité et encore plus les
étudiants étrangers donc cette cet
article 15 euh l'objectif ça serait de
tendre aussi aux étudiants étrangers euh
de façon à ce qu'il ne soit pas
systématiquement la cible des marchands
de sommeil ce qui est le cas en France
aujourd'hui les étudiants étrangers ne
sont pas protégés et vivent dans des
conditions
indignes alors tu peux la logique de
l'article 15 est d'accroîre la
répression des marchands de sommeil qui
exploite la vulnérabilité des occupants
on parle bien de personnes en situation
irrégulière et pas en situation
régulière or on est d'accord pour dire
que tous les étudiants étrangers ne sont
pas en vulnérabilité non plus il faut
aussi le reconnaître donc là le
dispositif s'applique à toutes les
personnes qu'elles soit étudiante ou non
donc en fait vous êtes satisfaite par
l'écriture actuelle parce qu'on ne fait
pas de distinction entre ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est un étudiant un
travailleur ou quelqu'un qui ne
bénéficie de rien et quoi qu'il arrive
il sera il ou elle seront protégés et
c'est le plus important c'està dire que
vous êtes satisfaite dans la rédaction
actuelle je vous propose de retirer ou
alors ça sera défavorable madame
ki je vais le maintenir s'il vous
plaît je mets au je mets au voix qui
vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté madame jeunev le
808 merci monsieur le Président alors
mon amendement porte sur les alignéas 4
6 8 et 10 dont je souhaite modifier la
formulation vous proposer de modifier le
code de la construction et de
l'habitation c'est donc une disposition
d'ordre général alors si évidemment nous
souscrivons à l'alourdissement des
peines des marchands de sommeil c'est
tout à fait légitime et souhaitable en
revanche nous je propose par cet
amendement d'arrêter euh les alinéas euh
dont j'ai parlé au mots vulnérable parce
que euh vous vous ajoutez pour définir
le mot vulnérable notamment un
ressortissant étranger en situation
irrégulière mais la vulnérabilité c'est
une notion bien connue en droit qui peut
concerner euh la la vulnérabilité en âge
en maladie en infirmité en déficience
physique ou psy cologique la grossesse
bref il y a des tas de formes de
vulnérabilité pourquoi dans cette
disposition générale du code voulez-vous
singulariser au détriment de tous les
autres les étrangers en situation
irrégulière merci monsieur le
rapporteur
pardon défavorable on n'est pas sûr que
supprimer cette mention en fait produise
les effets que vous désirez la Cour de
cassation a déjà jugé qu'un étranger en
situation irrégulière est une personne
vulnérable au sens de l'article du code
pénal qui sanctionne l'exploitation de
la vulnérabilité en soumettant les
personnes à des conditions de vie
indignes donc en fait on dirait à
l'inverse de ce que vous proposez c'est
pour ça que nous sommes
défavorables bien sûr madame
jeevard non mais je je récuse
complètement cette cette explication
monsieur le rapporteur à ce moment-là si
vous commencez une liste il faut la
compléter faut la compléter avec les
handicapés les jeunes en rupture social
les démunis les femmes en situation de
grossesse c'est pas possible de
commencer une une liste euh de de
distinguer la seule vulnérabilité des
étrangers en situation
irrégulière ça n'a pas de sens et votre
explication n'a pas de sens non plus
pardonnez-moi de vous le dire monsieur
Loman écoutez une fois n'est pas coutume
nous serons d'accord avec un amendement
des républicains puisque sur ce sujet
euh on considère que madame jeunevar a
raison euh
venir spécifier un type de personne
vulnérable dans le code de la construc
ça aurait été dans le code sur le droit
d'asile et et l'immigration pourquoi pas
spécifier les les les les étrangers en
situation vulnérable là on est dans le
code de la construction et de
l'habitation donc personnes vulnérabl
normalement ça suffit néanmoins j'ajoute
quand même une chose il est
effectivement très important de lutter
contre le mécanisme qu'on appelle celui
des marchands de sommeil moi c'est un
problème énorme dans ma circonscription
en particulier à greini et en parti ul
très spécifiquement à greini 2 qui est
une immensepropriété et punir ceux qui
s'adonnent à ce type de de comportement
et me semble me semble effectivement
utile mais là pour le coup on est
d'accord avec l'amendement de madame
je monsieur le rapporteur vous
voulezjter quelque chose alors ça
s'appliquera bien à toutes personnes
vulnéral notamment les personnes en
situation
irrégulière on peut on n pas le choix
que de se baser sur ce code là
d'ailleurs sur la note qui vous a été
envoyé à à tous les commissaires aux loi
c'est explicité sur la le la qualité de
vulnérabilité on est le notamment c'est
bien en complément on est sur les
personnes vulnérables notamment quand
ils sont en situation irrégulière donc
on apporte
différ c'est c'est rédigé dedans madame
allez madame jebar nous allons voter
cette amendement de madame jeunevard qui
vote pour ah
pardon monsieur le ministre d'abord
monsieur le ministre
je suis arrivé un petit peu en retard je
suis désolé j'ai loupé le début de votre
conversation cet article 15 il est
d'abord très important lutter contre les
marchands de sommeil c'est évidemment
lutter contre un écosystème mafieux et
lutter contre un écosystème aussi de
trafic de personnes dont les personnes
sont les victimes dans cette histoire il
est évident que les étrangers assation
irrégulières ne sont pas les seules
personnes vulnérables bien évidemment
après madame jeev pour me rappeler de la
discussion qu'on on a eu au Sénat parce
que cette article est à la fois le fruit
de la proposition du gouvernement d'un
amendement du président buffet et d'un
amendement de Yan brossa du groupe
communiste donc c'est c'est désormais
cette transformation la discussion qu'on
a eu ensemble c'était le fait que nous
parlions bien ici des étrangers sitation
régulière parce que Madame jeunevard
nous parlons des étrangers dans ce texte
de loi bon et que non non non mais j'ai
bien compris mais pourquoi on parle que
des pourquoi on dit notamment personnes
étrangères sur irrégulière parce que on
parle ici des étrangers dans ce texte de
loi maintenant si pour la séance moi je
je regarde monsieur le rapporteur si
pour la séance on veut compléter les
personnes vulnérables par un travail
qu'on peut faire avec le ministère du
Logement et avec vousmême faisonsle non
mais bonjour c'est pas très c'est pas
très très compliqué bon bon
donc non mais moi je suis arrivé pour la
je ne me faites pas de procès d'atention
je je voilà voilà désolé voilà comme de
parasard Monsieur soyez pas bon vous
avez raison même les paranoïes ont des
ennemis faut faire
attention donc voilà je pense la
question de la vulnérabilité aujourd'hui
elle n'existe pas pour l'étranger en S
régulière aujourd'hui non non non non
pardon l'étranger en situation
irrégulière il n'a pas la possibilité
par exemple de toucher des AD au
logement et c'est c'estux il n'a pas la
possibilité de toucher les aides de fond
de solidarité pour logement et donc à ce
titre comme il essaie de se loger il va
dans vers un parc informel c'est bien
naturel on peut tout à fait le
comprendre à Mo que vous soutiez qu'on
met les appels pour les personnes
sitation irrégulière on on y met on il y
a une forme de vulnérabilité il est
aussi il est aussi dans un écosystème
comme on l'a dit dans l'article
8 dans l'article 8 de de
mémoire je demande
dans l'article 8 de
mémoire c'est un c'est un c'est un
écosystème aussi où souvent
l'entrepreneur voyou qui emboche des
personnes irrégulière et souvent de
mèche vous le savez bien avec des
marchands de sommeil et il y a un
écosystème de vulnérabilité moi
j'entends votre préoccupation comme
j'entends sans doute la préoccupation de
votre collègue socialiste si ça a été le
cas précédemment donc retravaillons pour
le retravaillons pour la séance soit
pour retirer TER si vous considérez tous
qu'il n'est pas juste mais je pense
qu'il est juste on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler soit soit le compl soit de le
compléter soit de le compléter mais il y
a pas de mauvaise intention il n'y a pas
de mauvaise intention dans cet article
qui a été coconstruit par le
Sénat monsieur le rapporteur général oui
pour pour compléter les les les propos
du ministre pourquoi pourquoi le Sénat à
travers la l'amendement de Yan brossa a
euh souhaité intégrer cette cette
disposition a été voté par le séndat
parce qu'en réalité aujourd'hui dans la
loi il n'y a pas d'assimilation
vulnérabilité situation irrégulière dans
la loi la Cour de cassation le reconnaît
la jurisprudence le reconnait mais euh
le Sénat a souhaité consolider
l'existence d'une disposition
législative qui permet d'assimiler dans
la loi la situation d'irrégularité à
celle de vulnérabilité mais comme le dit
Monsieur le Ministre moi je vous propose
pour la séance qu'on clarifie ce point
parce que soit on le on le supprime dans
ces conditions c'est effectivement
l'interprétation de la cour des
cassation qui s'appliquera soit il faut
avoir une liste plus exhaustive et là on
rencontrera les difficultés habituelles
qui consistent à vouloir être exhaustif
et à rater la cible voilà l'état
d'esprit du Sénat au terme de l'adoption
de son texte il
maintenu de climat tenu je mets au voix
qui vote pour qui vote contre
il est
rejeté article 15 je mets au vo
l'article 15 qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est adopté l'article 15 bis
monsie
camardarticle 15 B l'amendement de
suppression le
133 parce que là il laisse passer le
truc
allez-y il a dit défendu d'accord euh le
426 pas défendu le 495 qui le défend
madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président alors
il est tout à fait légitime de lutter
avec fermeté contre les marchands de
sommeil mais pour autant nous sommes
très surpris de l'apparition de cette
article dans ce projet de loi parce que
cet article prévoit d'accorder un titre
de séjour pour vie privée et vie
familiale d'un an aux étrangers qui
portent plainte contre les marchands de
sommeil bon déjà je ne vois pas pourquoi
il serait pertinent de créer une filière
supplémentaire Visante à accorder des
titres de séjour mais surtout ce
mécanisme peut-être totalement
contre-productif parce qu'il risque de
faire exploser le nombre de
dénonciations et plus particulièrement
des dénonciations calomnieuses donc on
va engorger les les tribunaux et on va
créer une incitation à dénoncer
quelqu'un donc nous voterons c'est pour
ça que nous avons déposé un article de
suppression un amendement de
suppression alors madame jeunevard
oui c'est votre amendement de
suppression éal oui oui merci merci
monsieur le Président alors moi je je
propose en effet tout comme Monsieur
poet qui ne pourra pas défendre son
amendement 133 de supprimer cet article
qui prévoit d'accorder un titre de
séjour aux étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui portent plainte contre
des marchands de sommeil pour moi c'est
ENF pour nous les républicain cette
mesure est absolument inacceptable parce
qu'elle ouvre un droit automatique à la
régularisation pour les étrangers fusil
victime de marchand de sommeil il y a un
principe en drroit c'est que nul ne peut
se prévaloir de sa propre
turpitudeah oui on peut pas se prévaloir
parce que on est en situation
irrégulière droit à obtenir un titre
auquel on n'aurait pas accès de façon
habituelle et normale donc ça c'est
vraiment un encouragement à créer une
nouvelle
filière et vous en verrez je pense assez
rapidement les effets parce que les
passeurs ont une parfaite connaissance
de notre droit et de son évolution et
chaque fois que nous ouvrons une faille
il s'y engouffre par contre il faut
lutter contre les marchands de sommeil
j'ai voté j'ai voté l'article 15 malgré
le fait que mon amendement n' pas été
adopté mais parce que il faut lutter
effectivement contre les marchands de
sommeil alors monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur le ministre oui madame
je suis pas d'accord avec vousessaie de
vous expliquer pourquoi et pourquoi
d'ailleurs le Sénat a voté aussi cet
article si j'ai bien compris qu'on était
à l'Assemblée nationale il l' voté
d'ailleurs à l'unanimité la difficulté
que nous avons je parle de service de
police c'est pour constituer dit d'être
un marchand de sommeil il faut que nous
ayons la preuve que cette personne est
marchand de sommeil c'est exactement le
même parallèle que la loi qui a imaginé
et qui est désormais la loi de la
République et qui je vous rppelle madame
jeunevard pour le coup a été validé par
le Conseil
constitutionnel de la personne qui est
dans un trafic d'êtres humain la
prostitution et qui lorsqu'elle dénonce
ses pro net alors qu'elle est
irrégulière a le droit de de seevir
délivrer un titre de séjour temporaire
en l'occurrence c'est 6 mois le temps le
temps le temps soit de vérifier que les
choses effectivement sont sérieuses mais
aussi de pouvoir accompagner ou
réaccompagner la personne en dehors
d'une filière parce qu'elle est souvent
venue à cause d'une filière et qu'elle
n'a pas de contact parfois pour repartir
et ce titre de séjour temporaire qui a
été imaginé pour les personnes qui sont
dans les traites d'êtres humains
notamment de prostitution marche très
bien d'abord il y a peu de cas qui à la
fin on le titre de séjour je peux vous
le dire mais surtout c'est ça par an
merci 429 exactement pour la
prostitution donc il n'a pas créé depuis
5 ans une augmentation énorme des flux
et surtout on a pu à chaque fois trouver
des témoignages puisque c'est en
échangeune plainte vous l'avez bien
compris trouver un témoignage qui
constitue le délit le crime qui nous
permet de condamner ces personnes et
donc d'arrêter les filières la
difficulté du marchand de sommeil c'est
que et je pense que tous les maires de
votre circonscription dans les
centres-villes notamment qui peuvent
être un peu appauvris avec un urbanisme
un peu vieillissant et des travaux qui
ne permettent pas souvent de mettre des
logements au normees pour plein de
raisons çave touche beaucoup de villes
moyennes la difficulté c'est qu'on a
beaucoup de mal à constituer des lit
marchands de sommeil ça ne repose que
sur l'action des maires qui travaillent
fortement sur l'urbanisme et qui
arrivent extrêmement peu à pouvoir le
constituer donc ce que prévoit euh cet
article encore une fois vootter à
l'unanimité lors du Sénat c'est que en
échange une dénonciation en échange une
dénonciation il y a une carte temporaire
qui est donné qui n'ouvre pas droit
évidemment au regroupement familial et
qui permet à la personne qui sans doute
est arrivée avec une filière parce que
c'est comme ça que les choses
fonctionnent de pouvoir repartir avec
autre chose qu'une filière avec le
soutien de l'État c'est le cas de l'OFI
lorsqu'on a des aides au retour avec le
qtf volontaire et qui permet de de se
retirer des griffes de de ces de ces
difficultés donc moi je veux vraiment
vous dire Madame jeard j'ai pas du tout
la la même le même constat que que vous
d' d'ailleurs plutôt que le supprimer
entre nous soisis vous auriez pu montrer
le fait que vous aviez un doute en
disant non pas doit se voit délivré mais
peut se voir délivré ça aaitentement une
discussion qu'on a pu avoir mais là
franchement à la fois parce qu'il y a eu
une un exemple M eu un deuxième puisque
je vous rappelle que vous avez voté vous
aussi madame jeunevard un amendement qui
avait été proposé par Madame buffet dans
le précédent Modat pour les femmes
victimes de enfin pour les personnes
victimes de violence conjugale qui
irrégulière si elle déposit plainte se
voyz délivrer vousz peut-être pas voté
se voyz délivré un un comment dirais-je
un titre de séjour ça a ça a concerné
moins de 300 cas depuis que la loi a été
promulguée c'est-à-dire objectivement
très peu de personnes mais ça a permis
de mettre 300 personnes en garde à vue
avec des enquêtes et je n'ai pas encore
les réponses pénales mais répondant
évidemment au sujet de soutien public
donc je pense pas du tout je pense même
le contraire de vous ce ce ce cet
article complet y compris avec le le
titre de séjour si dénonciation permet
de mettre fin à des filières mettre fin
à des filières c'est ce que en fait
c'est la philosophie du texte c'est un
écosystème irrégulier il y a une
question de de personnes qui sont déjà
présentes et qui vivent dans ces
conditions mais il faut sincériser les
choses arrêter d'être d' point de vue
derrière hypocrite en revanche mettre
fin à des flux c'est ce qu'on a fait sur
article 5 auto entrepreneur qu'on a fait
article 8 entreprise qui emboche des
irréguliers c'est ce qu'on fait avec
celui-ci pour les marchands de
sommeil attendez parce que j'ai monsieur
porte pour commencer
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement il nous paraît que
supprimer cette article n'est pas de bon
sens parce que ça permet effectivement
de lutter contre des marchands de somil
qui exploitent des gens qui sont dans
des situation extrêmement précaire et
quand j'entends les députés du
rassemblement national par a priori dire
que les gens qui sont dans ces ses
appartements qui subissent la pression
des marchants de sobeil par définition
vont déjà mentir quand quand ils vont
dénoncer la situation c'est déjà avoir
un préj juger sur ces gens-là et puis
finalement on aura vu au travers de ce
texte que un vous défendez là les
marchands de sommeil et vous avez quand
même il y a quelques jours déposé un
amendement pour que les patrons de
petites entreprises ne soient pas
sanctionnés quand ils embauchent des
travailleurs irréguliers donc vous êtes
toujours du côté de celles et ceux qui
exploitent la misère du
monde madame
Rousseau
euh enfin de l'expérience de précédente
à la tête d'une université je peux vous
dire que j'ai vu des étudiants être à 8
par exemple dans des studios de 6 m² et
que nous nous en il dormait à tour de
rôle par par tranche horaire de 3 ou 4
heures et en fait nous nous en sommes
aperçus parce qu'il y avait des
épidémies par exemple de tuberculose
dans ces dans ces lieux parfois
insalubres et en fait il faut se
représenter ce que c'est quand il y a
une pénurie de logement l'exploitation
qu'il peut y avoir de propriétairees peu
scrupuleux qui lou à des prix
exorbitants des logements qui sont non
seulement insalubres mais qui sont sur
en surpopulation
importante et en fait il est très
important de de permettre ce les
conditions de la dénonciation parce
qu'il s'agit de la santé mais aussi de
conditions de dignité et en l'occurrence
je ne crois pas un instant qu'il y aura
de dénonciation massive ou abusive
simplement parce que nous sommes dans
une telle crise du logement qu'il y a de
toute façon des difficultés à accéder à
un toit et que là ce serait des
conditions uniquement qui ne permettent
pas de vivre dignement dans un
logementci qui serait les le déclencheur
d'une d'une plainte de ces personnes
madame chassagol
oui merci monsieur le Président nous
nous serons défavoraable à ces
amendements de suppression pour aller
dans la continuité de ce qu'a dit le
ministre nous considérons que les
personnes qui résident dans ces
logements sont d'abord des victimes et
en plus d'être victime elles ont assez
peu de levierers pour dénoncer
l'indignité dans lesquel dans laquelle
elles vivent si elles le font elles
s'exposent à une dénonciation de leur
situation ou à une précarité qui serait
plus grande encore nous ne pouvons pas
nous résoudre à cela et nous devons donc
d'une part les protéger et d'autre part
mieux définir aussi les conditions dans
lesquelles nous le faisons nous venons
de renforcer les sanctions contre les
marchands de sommeil mais cette nouvelle
disposition serait incomplète si nous ne
pouvons pas actionner des poursuites
mener des enquêtes contre ces personnes
et pour cela le parquet a besoin du
témoignage aussi des victimes qu'elles
soit présente sur le territoire pour
aider à activer l'action publique dans
la pratique une victime en situation
irrégulière n'ira pas porter plainte et
participer à l'enquête contre un
marchand de sommeil de craindre que les
forces de police ne constatent leur
irrégularité le dispositif de délivrance
d'une carte de séjour temporaire permet
donc de contourner cet
obstacle madame
jeuneva merci monsieur le Président
alors s'agissant des des des épous de de
polygame je me rappelle très bien cet
amendement de Madame buffet c'était dans
la
loi séparatisme ou asile immigration
peut-être
séparatisme moi personnellement j'avais
voté contre cet amendement parce que j'y
voyais
effectivement
bon une disposition qui était
susceptible de créer
d'encourager mais s'agissant de cet
amendement regardez les chiffres tout de
même la Fondation abépierre estime à
600000 etiné à 2 millions et demi le
nombre de logements insalubre en France
c'est tout à fait
considérable vous voyez un peu ce à quoi
on peut s'exposer si on est obligé de
délivrer des des titres de séjour fusil
d'un an mais qu'est-ce que vous ferez
après au bout d'un
an que que ferez-vous de ces étrangers
auxquels vous aurez délivré un un titre
de séjour temporaire qui devront donc
quitter leur logement puisqu'il est il
est inapte à être occupé mer et que et
que feront que ferez-vous de ces
étrangers
merci une fois que leur titre de séjour
sera obsol va finir la discussion avec
Monsieur gilet et Madame keloashi après
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre gilet oui monsieur le Président
moi je crois que cette espèce de
marchandisation de la dénonciation
peut-être dangereuse et on peut avoir à
la clé de nombreux abus mais moi je
voudrais surtout qu'on parle du sujet de
fond qui est la lutte contre les
marchands de sommeil et je pense qu'il
faut aller encore davantage plus loin
contre les sanctions pour les marchands
de seeille mais il faut aussi et
Monsieur le le le ministre le sait il
faut aussi aider les collectivités à
pouvoir jouer ce rôle central de lutte
contre les marchands de sommeil monsieur
le ministre quand vous étiez maire à
l'époque le permis de Loué n'existait
pas encore depuis ce dispositif existe
il est facultatif pour les maires euh de
nombreux maires le mettent en place avec
des difficultés financières très
importantes parce qu'il est totalement à
la charge des collectivités
collectivités qui déjà ont de grandes
difficultés à cause de cette agonie
organisée par l'État des collectivités
donc il faut donner plus de moyens aussi
au maire pour qu'il puisse mettre en
place ses permis de louer je pense qu'il
faudrait même les généraliser si l'on
veut vraiment être efficace et pouvoir
lutter contre les marchands de sommeil
il faut aussi d'ailleurs que les
sanctions suivent parce que
malheureusement un grand nombre de mes
se plaignent parce que les sanctions et
bien ne viennent pas alors même que les
maires font le travail d'aller à la
chasse après ces marchant de
sommeil merci alors pourquoi
l'amendement de Madame Genevard me gêne
profondément parce qu'elle met sur le
même plan la personne vulnérable
vulnérable qui est en situation
irrégulière et les filières organisé de
proxénet ou de marchand de sommeil
puisque là on parle de marchand de
sommeil cette personne vulnérable elle
ne peut pas déposer plainte si elle
n'est pas régulière en France donc vous
êtes en train de de proposer à ce que
les filières de marchand de sommeil
continuent à prospérer tranquillement
puisque de toute façon elles trouveront
toujours des sans papiers àber
monsieur le rapporteur général non
simplement rappeler à à Madame jeunevard
que il ne s'agit pas simplement de
conditions d'insalubrité dans les
logements concernés vous évoqueiez cet
argument il y a quelques
instants les dispositions de de
l'article sont beaucoup plus précises et
beaucoup plus exigeantes ce sont les
conditions d'hébergement qui sont
incompatibles avec la dignité humaine
plus le verrou du débot de plainte par
ailleurs et monsur monsieur le ministre
vous a indiqué que la disposition de
introduite par Marie-George Buffet en
2021 n'a absolument entraîner aucune
forme d'encouragement à la
multiplication des situations puisque
300 titres de séjour ont été attribué à
ce titre làà mais je voudrais simplement
euh noter quand même la remarque faite
tout à l'heure par notre collègue du du
Front national du rassemblement national
hier vous étiez euh contre toute forme
de lutte vis-à-vis des employeurs qui
recrutent des personnes en situation
irrégulière hier vous avez
refuser vous étiez euh vous souhaitiez
refuser toute forme de sanction à
l'égard des des employeurs voyou qui
emploie des personnes en situation
irrégulière Vous vouliez même créer une
dérogation spécialement pour ceux qui le
font dans les dans les entreprises de
moins de ha salariés enfin quand même on
s'en souvient je pense qu'on a tous été
témoins et ce soir ce soir vous êtes
contre une disposition qui cette fois-ci
pénaliserait l'hébergeur le propriétaire
le bailleur qui lui profiterit de du
trafic des êtres humains et des
personnes en situation irrégulière voyez
la cohérence de vos propositions d'une
certaine façon au fond au fond vous êtes
vous êtes systématiquement contre tous
les outils qui nous permettraient de
mieux lutter de plus efficacement le
modèle économique des personnes en
situation irrégulière il y a des
contradictions fondamentales dans les
propos qui sont les votres monsieur le
ministre
ouis je veux dire Madame Genevard que
son exemple avec les les nombres de
logements insalubre ne fonctionne pas
parce que c'est c'est pas l'article de
loi qui est écrit madame la la députée
l'article de loi dit quoi l'étranger qui
dépose plainte contre une personne qui
l'accuse d'avoir commis à son encontre
des faits constitutifs de l'infraction
de soumission à des conditions
d'hébergement incompatibles avec la
dignité humaine pas lainsalubrité
mentionn l'article 225 14 du code pénal
se voit délivrer une carte de séjour
temporaire d'accord regarde l'article
225 14 du code pénal l'article 224 225
14 du code pénal c'est pas toute
personne qui est dans un logement ins
salubre c'est le fait de soumettre une
personne dont la vulnérabilité ou l'état
de dépendance sont apparents ou connu de
l'auteur à des conditions de travail ou
d'hébergement incompatible avec la
dignité humaine la salubrité c'est assez
large je suis bien d'accord c'est à
combattre bien évidemment c'est par
exemple lorsqu'un logement connaî pas la
rampe handicapée il a une forme
d'insalubrité c'est comme ça qu'on le
retire les appels au propriétaire par
exemple c'est pas le cas c'est pas
incomatible avec la dignité humaine là
nous parlons de gens qui vivent sans eau
sans électricité avec de la mérule enfin
on connaît tous l'insalubrité profonde
que fait naître parfois des logements
désastreux ignobl voilà c'est pas le
propriétaire qui a pas fait les travaux
depuis 3 ans ça c'est pas bien mais
c'est pas la c'est pas l'atteinte à la
dignité humaine voilà donc euh et puni
et vous avez vu c'est un délit très
important pour le code pénal conf fa la
discussions qu'on a eu autour de
l'article 9 et 10 de 5 ans en
prisonnement et 150000 € d'amende donc
je ne sais pas pour répondre totalement
à votre question qui combien de logement
ça ça occupe il faudrait que cette
personne soit donc irrégulier qui soit
dans dans un logement qui a été euh non
déclaré puisque le principe du marchant
de sommeil c'est qu'il y a pas euh de
quittance de loyer il y a il y a il y a
pas de versement officiel donc on est
bien d'accord que ça limite quand même
beaucoup euh la question de qui se pose
sur le fait que c'est un délogement euh
qui doivent être euh dans les conditions
correspondent à à la noncomailité avec
la dignité humaine et que par ailleurs
la personne qui a loué ce logement de
façon indue connaisse la vulnérabilité
ou l'état de dépendance apparente de
l'auteur avouez que c'est pas les 2
millions et demi de logement qu'on
évoque non non non madame je vous avez
commencé par dire qu' 600000 vous
terminez 1 million en 4 jours faites
attention à l'inflation augmente bon non
mais non non mais non mais il a 4000005
il y a 425000 personnes à la me dont 25
% d'enfants c'est déjà beaucoup on n'est
pas obligé d'en rajouter là bon mais le
sujet n'est pas le sujet n'est pas
encore une fois les personnes le sujet
c'est c'est la filière d'immigration
irrégulière que secrée madame jeard je
veux vraiment attirer votre attention AC
conviction sur le fait que en ne votant
pas ce genre d'amendement vous ne
révélez pas les filière d'immigration
illégale et je veux le dire au
rassemblement national effectivement
parce que je je ne fais pas évidemment
le même prensé à vous qu'à eux eux je
pense que c'est parce qu'ils ont pas
envie de régler le problème ça c'est un
autre sujet on l'a vu on l'a vu hier on
l'a vu aujourd'hui et on verra bien ce
qu'ils feront en effet sur sur ce texte
qui vise à lutter contre le mal à lutter
contre les flux d'immigration
irrégulières organisé par par des
pasteurs et par des gens qui profitent
pécunièrement de de tout cela non mais à
la fin des fins monsieur Lucas parlait
d'amour il y a des preuves d'amour il y
a que ça qui compte on verra bien ce qui
ce qui ce qui fonctionnera à la fin ne
vous ne vous énervez pas c'était juste
pour vous rappeler oui ça c'est c'est
une façon de vous montrer que vous êtes
dans le droit fil comme l'a dit
rapporteur général et comme l'a dit tout
à l'heure monsieur porte dans la
régularisation finalement ou en tout cas
pour écarter ceux qui embauchent des
personnes vulnérables ou qui les lent de
façon vulnérable ça fait beaucoup de
faonindice euh pour pour être du côté
des des des passeurs pour être du côté
des irréguliers c'est même à se demander
si vous n'êtes pas finalement content
qu'il y ait des irréguliers pour pouvoir
les dénoncer c'est c'est c'est peut-être
une possibilité bon donc là c'est
vraiment vraiment très très
incompréhensible madame madame Genevard
elle dit pas ça madame Genevard elle dit
moi j'ai peur que justement ça encourage
c'est c'est très différent très
différent et je constate madame
jeunevard par ailleurs ça devrait vous
rassurer parce que vous dites vous dites
euh j'ai quelqu'un tout à l'heure a dit
ouais mais il pe ils peuvent déposer
plainte pour avoir ce titre de séjour
d'abord déposer plainte c'est pas si
c'est pas si c'est pas si facile que par
ailleurs la personne est irrégulière
donc elle prend une responsabilité assez
forte et je rappelle que la dernière
phrase qui a été rajoutée d'ailleurs par
le ou la rapporteur du Sénat je ne sais
plus elle est renouvelé pendant toute la
durée de la procédure pénale
c'est-à-dire que c'est concomitant avec
la procédure pénale si la personne a
menti si la personne a détourné une
procédure évidemment que c'est d' en
plus un fait aggravant pour ne pas la
régulariser donc je crois vraiment qu'il
y a pas à craindre comme vous n'aviez
pas à craindre de l'amendement de Madame
buffet qui ne traduit pas l'ouverture et
je l'ai pas là mais je vous le donnerai
dans en séance publique le nombre je
crois qu'on était à moins de 400
personnes comm titre de séjour pour
dénonciation de polygamie violence
central familiale et je crois qu'on on a
on a plus on a on a plus on a plus de
500 procédures contre ces personnees et
j'ai déchu y compris la nationalité y
compris de la de la de la carte de
résident qui leur avait été accordé des
personnes pour polygamie qui l'avait
caché parce que c'est pas facile
évidemment à à constater au nom de la
loi séparatisme du fait de la
dénonciation de ces femmes donc
objectivement voilà je peux comprendre
que vous avez une opinion différente je
crois que profondément vous vous vous
trompez c'est quelque chose qui lutte
profondément contre les flux
irrégulier bon allez on vote C
amendement de suppression qui vote pour
qui vote contre ils sont rejetés
l'amendement suivant c'est le mien c'est
une réécriture plus englobante du
dispositif imaginé par Monsieur brossa
puisqu'il s'agit de d'étendre à toutes
les personnes victimes de de
proxénétisme et de traite humaine et de
leur ouvrir l'ouvert enfin le droit à
cette carte de séjour temporaire à
partir du moment où elle dépose la
plainte ou alors elle saisisse
l'inspection du travail on voilà qu'il a
a une logique totalement inverse à ce
qui était proposé par le rassemblement
national qui était de couvrir l'effet de
traite humaine par les employeurs voyou
voilà mon amendement monsieur le
rapporteur le
vôtre al disons monsieur le Président
vous a déjà tout dit je veux juste
rassurer certains de nos collègues c'est
de de rappeler qu'en modifiant
directement l'article
l425-1 existant plutôt qu'en créant un
nouvel article nous rendons applicables
les autres dispositions en vigueur parmi
lesquelles la délivrance d'une carte de
résidence La personne accusé est
définitivement condamné et étant donné
que celui du président est mieux rédigé
que le mien je retirerai le
mien avis favorable au mien un avis
favorable pour le mien et un avis
favorable pour le Président c'est très
gentil monsieur
gilet vous pas monsieur Dumont pardon je
vous avez inscrit merci monsieur le
Président je voudrais revenir sur sur
les propos de Monsieur le Ministre de
l'Intérieur vous avez dit à ma collègue
Annie jeunevard qu'il y avait une
inflation dans ses propos du nombre de
de Cl pardon mais c'est bien vous qui
avez déclaré qu'il y avait en novembre
2021 600 700000 clandestins et en
novembre 2023 qu'il y avait 600 à 900000
clandestins donc l'inflation l'inflation
qui est réalisée beaucoup plus
importante chez vous que chez ma
collègue puisqueen l'espace de 2 ans
vous avez augmenté de 200000 le nombre
de clandestins ceci étant dit monsieur
le ministre de
l'Intérieur la difficulté qu'on a nous
avec la avec la rédaction et avec cela
c'està-dire qu'il suffit simplement de
déposer plainte et que donc il il pourra
évidemment y avoir des dépôts de plainte
abusifs de la part de clandestin et
parce qu'il n'est pas pardon de le dire
nécessaire d'avoir un logement qui est
loué au black en quittance de loyer
n'importe quel clandestin pourra aller
déposer plainte et se voir
automatiquement remettre un titre de
séjour d'un an en vie privée et
familiale même si le logement est
parfaitement salubre même si il y a une
quittance de loyer qui est donné même si
les choses sont parfaitement régulières
au moins du point de vue de la location
du meublé et donc c'est en cela nous som
absolument en opposition et avec
l'amendement initial et avec la
réécriture merci monsieur le
Président peti petit dégabat sur les
chiffres il se trouve que j'avais rédigé
un rapport pour le Premier ministre de
l'époque en 2019 là-dessus euh 600000
c'est ce sont les chiffres de
laabépierre laféération de la Fondation
abépierre l' le le la dial retient
plutôt 400000 et làedans il y a la
moitié des gens qui sont des
propriétaires occupant donc ceux-là ne
sont pas concernés par la mesure dont
nous venons dont nous venons de parler
et puis surtout à votre avis les gens
qui habitent dans ces dans ces logements
ils arrivent comment en réalité les les
filières sont les mêmes ce sont les
mêmes filières qui font arriver de façon
clandestine les gens et qu' vont les
loger dans ces logements à salubre et
que quand on quand on est quand on
arrive à combattre quand on veut
combattre les les logement sal libre on
combat aussi les marchands de sommeil on
combat aussi les des filières qui vont
avec donc je pense que la disposition
qui est proposée est vraiment d'une
grande efficacité en la
matière mais au voit mon amendement avec
avis favorable du rapporteur qui vaêre
pour
qui vote contre il est adopté alors il
fait tomber les
amendements il rédige l'article donc il
fait tomber les amendements l'article il
n a pas de besoin de voter sur l'article
et tombe également le 797 de Madame SAS
et 1392 de Madame CBI on passe donc au
904 de Monsieur
Vallot euh
il fait pas tomber he non non B
allez-y c'est 904 c'est ça oui donc
c'est un amendement qui est suggéré par
France TER d'asile et qui vise à
reconnaître au droit au séjour aux
victimes de conditions de travail
indigne de travail forcé ou de réduction
en servitude ayant déposé plainte c'est
l'esprit que vous avez déjà évoqué pour
d'autres
motifs le 505 qui le défend pour les
écologistes
défendu monsieur le
rapporteur satisfait par la nouvelle
réécriture monsieur vot donc je propose
de le
retirer je les mets au voix alors qui
vote pour qui vote contre rejeter le
1322 qui le défend madame leg grip non
vous ntes
pas allez-y oui donc c'est un amendement
monsieur lefèv qui vise à permettre la
délivrance d'une carte de séjour
temporaire étranger qui dépose plainte
contre un passeur cette fois-ci ou qui
témoine contre un passeur dans une une
procédure pénale alors il s'inspire de
notre législation existante et et il
propose de de compléter le le dispositif
notamment existant du du cza en
prévoyant de délivrer à l'étranger qui
dépose plainte donc une une carte de
séjour temporaire portant la mention vif
privée et familiale d'une durée d'un an
sous réserve que la personne est rompue
lien évidemment avec avec cette personne
l'objectif vous l'avez compris est de
faciliter la dénonciation des réseaux de
passeur monsieur le
rapporteur alors ça paraît cohérent avec
ce que ce qu'on vient de de voter par
contte c'est même bienvenu sur le
principe mais par contre on a un
problème c'est que tel qu'il est rédigé
votre amendement présente deux écueils
le premier ne traite pas des suite de la
procédure pénale comme on vient de
d'échanger c'està dire que logiquement
on a un titre de séjour à la fin s'il y
a condamnation pénale et le champ retenu
me semble très large il y a plus de 2000
victimes d'aide au séjour irrégulier
chaque année moi ce que je vous propose
c'est de le retirer pour une réécriture
potentielle pour la
séance retirz alors merci Madame yadan
le 647 madame
torgia alors nous souhaitons réaffirmer
que l'accès au titre de séjour de
protection pour les personnes victimes
des infractions de traite des êtres
humains ou de proxinetis doit être
automatique et non soumis à la condition
de rupture avec la personne qui commet
ces actes c'est pour cela que nous
proposons de de rajouter cette phrase au
premiè alinéa de l'article L 425-1 du
Code de l'entrée etfin du C sous réserve
qu'il est rompu tout lien avec cette
personne nous souhaitons remplacer cette
phrase par le mot
automatiquement la notion d'emprise doit
être rappelée elle engendre des
mécanismes psychologiques pe rrainer la
personne à couper avec l'environnement
toxique et illégal dans lequel elle
évolue et cette emprise peut s'appliquer
dans le cadre de la sphère privée et
intime mais également dans un cadre
professionnel ou pseudo professionnel
merci monsieur le rapporteur
défavorables VO qui vote
pour V contre
rejet suivants sont tombés par leseffit
mon amendement le 1710 monsieur le
rapporteur alors il est proposé en fait
de de de
d'ajouter une partie sur les étrangers
victimes de trait humaine
majoritairement de proximitif pour les
personnes qui sont entrées dans un
parcours de sortie de la prostitution
qui a été mis en place dans la loi de
2016 l'idée c'est d'aller plus loin je
crois que c'est partagé aussi par
d'autres collègues ici présents d'aller
plus loin de passer de 6 mois à 1 an sur
le titre de séjour et de mieux
accompagner pourquoi je propose cela
premièrement parce que il est compliqué
de sortir de ces réseaux de de
proxétisme parfois il y a des filières
qui sont organisées par les familles on
le voit avec les filières nigériannes
par exemple et il faut du temps pour la
personne victime de cette traite humaine
de pouvoir se reposer se reconstruire
d'avoir confiance pour pouvoir dénoncer
les différentes personnes et permettent
de rentrer dans un parcours adapté
surtout quand elle se retrouve devant le
juge et je dis ça parce que certaines
personnes pour les avoir rencontré
certaines victimes de de de cette traite
et de de ce proximtisme sont liés à des
personnes de leur famille et dénoncé au
tribunal sa propre tante son propre
oncle son cousin ou sa cousine c'est
assez compliqué il leur faut plus de
temps que ce qui était prévu par la loi
de 2016 l'idée c'est de mieux les
protéger et voilà ce que nous proposons
avec cette cette C cet amendement pardon
madame Touria alors précisément
l'amendement que je défendais
précédemment visait à remplacer des mots
par le mot automatiquement et monsieur
le rapporteur vous avez dit défavorable
sans m'expliquer pourquoi vous jugez
cette amendement défavorable j'aimerais
bien en savoir un petit peu plus est-ce
que le mot automatiquement coûte plus
cher pourquoi c'est
défavorable
alors Monsieur V vous avz un amendement
identique que j'ai oublié
allez-yend
madameousse c'est un amendement effet a
augmenté le temps du titre de séjour en
en parcours de sortie de prostitution 6
mois pour des personnes étrangères qui
en plus souvent ont cumulé et les
parcours de migration extrêmement
traumatisants et les les expériences de
prostitution les plus traumatisantes
parce que dépendant de de proxénet et
donc évidemment elles ont besoin d'avoir
un temps et de reconstruction
personnelle mais aussi un temps qui leur
permette le dépôt de plainte
l'instruction et C donc pour cette
raison je pense absolument nécessaire de
passer de 6 mois à un an alors
l'amendement du rapporteur identique
avec Monsieur Vallot qui vote
pour pour qui vote
contre c'est Laam du rapporteur
identique à Monsieur vot vous êtes sûr
de votre qui votre
pour qui vote contre il est
adopt attendez parce
que fait rien tomber alors le 7
le 759 madame obonau
oui merci monsieur le
Président en espérant que nous aurz une
explication en cas d'avis déforable mais
je pense que nous allons vous convaincre
d'accepter cet amendement qui vise à ce
que soit reconnu la qualité de victime
au travailleur la travailleuse dont il
est constaté qu'il ou elle exerce de
façon dissimulée son emploi par la
volonté de l'employeur lequel statut
devrait euh lui ouvrir une
régularisation de plein droit c'est un
amendement qui qui qui qui suit la même
logique prévue aux articles l425-1 et
suivant du du Code de l'entrée du séjour
des des étrangers du droit d'asile qui
reconnaît le statut de victime et
accorde une régularisation aux personnes
victimes de traite des êtres humains et
et de proximitisme on on a évoqué ce
sujet tout à l'heure et donc il nous
semble euh que il est serait tout à fait
cohérent euh pour les travailleurs et
travailleuses qui sont aussi victimes
euh de ce type d'exploitation euh
d'avoir reconnu un droit un titre de
séjour monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable c'est satisfait par
l'article 8 euh proposition d'après
article 8 que nous avons déposé hier que
nous modifierons pour le pour le la
séance publique étant donné qu'on a mis
un caractère automatique et qu'on peut
pas le faire et je rappelle que le
travail dissimulé est un délit euh et si
l'employeur qui se rend coupable est
lui-même étranger il perdra son son
titre de séjour donc on a on a tout ce
qui est on a tout ce qu'il faut dans ce
texte et en dehors de ce texte pour
vraiment apporter les réponses que vous
proposez donc défvorables ou
retrait je le mets au voix qui vote pour
qui vote contre il est rejeté le suivant
le 641 madame auono oui alors il s'agit
là d'une demande qui est aussi portée
par un certain nombre d'associations
d'aide aux femmes euh précaires et et et
au aux femmes immigrées
le fait que l'accès au titre de séjour
de protection
soit réaffirmé pour les personnes
victimes de violence conjugale et que ce
soit donc automatique je le je le redis
c'est notamment en discutant avec ces
associations qui sont rendu compte que
les dispositif
actuel restait très difficilement
accessible à ces personnes et que tant
qu'à
discuter du du sujet autant améliorer
véritablement la d intégration et
protéger automatiquement les femmes
victimes monsieur rapporteur défavorable
par que le caractère automatique de la
délivrance d'un titre est en totale
contradiction avec l'examen de chaque
chaque personne et je rappelle aussi que
pour les personnes qui sont victimes de
violence conjugale le droit n'est pas le
titre n'est pas automatique non plus
donc on est
défavorable je mets au voix qui vre pour
qui vote contre rejeté on passe à
l'article 16 amendement pression le 966
madame
Martin madame auonau
oui alors nous souhaitons supprimer cet
article 16 qui étant l'obligation de
contrôle documentaire des transporteurs
ainsi que les modalités de sanction de
son manquement par amende administrative
il s'agira ici pour les compagnies de
transport d'interroger le nouveau
système informatique mise en place par
la Commission frontiur de de l'Union et
le système européen d'information et
d'autorisation concernant les voyages
tous deux étaient censé entrer en
vigueur d'ici la fin de l'année ce qui
implique qu'en plus du document de
voyagage et du visa sur si la
nationalité l'exige l'entreprise de
transport devra contrôler l'autorisation
de voyage nous souhaitons rappeler que
ce projet eborder a suscité dès sa
conception la la méfiance d'observateurs
internationaux tant il semble avoir
résulté d'une intense campagne de
lobbying des sociétés privées de
contrôle des populations t en tête sans
véritable réelle plusvalue en matière de
de sécurité monsieur rapporteur
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté
l'article 16 qui vote pour qui vote
contre
adopté article 16 B a Monsieur Lucas le
56 merci Monsieur le le président bon
nous proposons de supprimer cette
article qui vise a durcir encore
davantage le le texte afin de rendre
plus difficile les migration en
accroissant le traitement de de donneré
de l'Agence Nationale des données du
voyage à l'en contontre une logique
d'intégration et portant une vision
purement répressive à l'encontre des
primos
arrivants euh madame Martin madame
torign le
967 parce que c'est une discion commune
donc il y a un amendement de Madame
obono 967 qui le
défend vous voulez faire le re et bah si
c'est une défense commune on va demander
pourquoi on on ne justifie pas pourquoi
Monsieur le Rapporteur partiel Vous ne
justifiez pas des positions que vous
prenez ça nous intéresse de connaître
vos arguments de sur crois là où on on
est là pour ça et en plus pour le coup
c'est pas la 50e fois qu'on aborde le
même sujet enfin j'exagère un peu mais
il est vrai que parfois les amendements
couvrent le même spectre de de de
questionnement ou de mesure en fait il
sait pas et et du coup là on aimerait
tout de même avoir des réponses puis que
tu un sujet qui est nouveau voilà
Monsieur si vous savez hein alors
défavorable et je crois que c'est aussi
dans mon bon droit de de ne pas toujours
apporter des arguments parce que il y a
certaines choses qui sont satisfaites et
les débats poussent parfois et on a les
mêmes débats en permanence donc je crois
que les réponses sont apportées
globalement chers collègues après sur ce
ce volet là à nouveau défavorable sur la
suppression en plus c'est un article qui
était existant dès le texte du
gouvernement il a pas été modifié par le
Sénat l'idée c'est que pour nous il
paraît cohérent et adapté on a aussi des
besoins complémentaires pour la lutte
contre le terrorisme et d'autres sujets
et le faire donc à partir de là il est
défavorable alors madame
torinia voulez plus parler bon alors je
mets au voix qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté l'article 16 B a qui vote
pour qui vote contre adopté un
amendement rédactionnel du rapporteur le
1711 qui vote pour contre adopté un
amendement de 936 de suppression de
l'article 16 bis de Monsieur Vallot
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement qui vise à supprimer
l'article 16 bis qui euh lui-même
supprime le jour franc avant d'être
récheminé en cas de refus d'entrée sur
le
territoire monsieur
lucasensite des excellents arguments de
mon collègue VO vous dire
que nous voulons conserver effectivement
ce jour franc pour les étrangers qui est
essentiel leur permet notamment de
contacter des associations qui peuvent
les aider à faire valoir leurs droits et
nous pensons qu'il est juste et
nécessaire que chacune et chacun puisse
connaître connaître ces droits et donc
nous proposons évidemment la suppression
de cet article 16 bis qui constitue
selon nous une véritable négation en
tout cas un entrave au droit d'asile le
1200 pas défendu monsieur le
rapporteur alors ça sera favorable
l'article 7 supprime le jour franc avant
l'expiration duquel un étranger ne peut
ne peut être réacheminé pardon on a pu
le le constater nous-même sur la mission
qui s'est appelé SOS Méditerranée au
chîn Viking mais qui en fait sur les
zones d'attente de la presquille de Gen
suite à l'accueil exceptionnel du bateau
à Toulon et et à Gien laarité c'est que
si on maintient parfois il y a des
solutions tout de suite d'accompagnement
de transport et on risquerait d'aller à
l'encontre même pour les ressortissants
étrangers si on tiit ce ce jour franc
euh le on va le placer automatiquement
en zone d'attente alors qu'on pourrait
avoir d'autres réponses à à apporter et
donc on on met vraiment en difficulté
potentielle le ressortissant supprimer
le jour Fran ne ferait nulement obstacle
à ce que l'étranger exprime sa volonté
de demander l'asile à la frontière ce
qui suspendrait son réacheminement donc
quoi qu'il arrive ses droits seront
conservés rien ne changerait pour le
ressortissant étranger et surtout on
aurait une meilleure possibilité de les
accompagner quand ils arêent sur le
territoire donc
défavorable je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeté l'article 16
bis qui vote pour qui vote contre il est
adopté l'article suivant le 17
amendement de suppression 282 monsieur
Lucas merci monsieur le Président nous
voulons avec cet amendement de
suppression supprimer les dispositions
liberticides de notre point de vue prévu
à l'article 17 de ce projet de loi qui
ajoute une pierre de plus à l'édifice de
la criminalisation des associations
d'aide aux personnes exilés aux
personnes migrantes pour mémoire le
Conseil constitutionnel dans sa décision
du 12 janvier
1977 et du 18 janvier
1995 a rappelé que la possibilité de
procéder à la fouille de véhicules
devait être entouré de garanties
effectives faute de quoi il serait
porter atteinte à la liberté
individuelle par ailleurs de nombreuses
associations témoignent d'un harcèlement
incessant de la part des autorités dans
la perspective de les dissuader de
porter assistance aux étrangers dans le
besoin nous avons pu le constater les un
les autres nous avons évidemment été à
la rencontre de ces associations et donc
nous croyons nécessaire de supprimer cet
article monsieur kabrat le
968 couom merci monsieur le Président
alors là on a à nouveau un exemple du
fait que vous vouliez spécialiser en
quelque sorte particulariser toutes les
les mesures judiciaires et policières au
statut des migrants
euh là il s'agit d'inspecter les
véhicules des particul en frontalière
alors non seulement c'est une pratique
qui à ce jour n'était pas possible elle
était exclue des possibilité
d'inspection prévu à l'article l812-3 du
C non pas les voitures particulières les
Suisses
alors bon en tout cas on a là
l'illustration même que l' on a envie de
faire des lois spécifiques qui s'extrai
des lois communes de tous les
particuliers en France pour des
personnes qui seraient soupçonné
puisquon ne peut pas le savoir avant de
de de leur origine étrangère lorsque le
véhicule est en transit entre deux
frontières donc et bien nous nous sommes
pour supprimer cet article tout
simplement attentatoire à la liberté
monsieur le rapporteur alors juste déjà
au premier permettez-moi de répondre à
Monsieur couum que nous avons modifié le
code douanier cet été et qu'il a été
voté à l'unanimité et qui permet
justement de visiter les véhicules
légers jusqu'à ne9 places pourquoi il y
a cet article parce que les passeurs
aujourd'hui i du moins la police peut
contrôler les camions les véhicules qui
ne sont pas des véhicules légers des
véhicules de tourisme donc que font les
passeurs ils les mettent dans des
véhicules légers jusqu'à 9U places
l'idée c'est de protéger ces
ressortissants mais de garantir que nous
luttons correctement contre les passeurs
donc supprimer cette cet article serait
une mauvaise chose parce que on
enlèverait des moyens à la police de
pouvoir lutter correctement contre les
filières de passeur je pense que la
traite humaine ici nous la lutte contre
la traite humaine ici est censé tous
nous animer mais je crois que vous vous
êtes trompé de combat l'idée c'est pas
de combattre les ressortissants étranger
c'est de combattre les passeurs on donne
la à la possibilité aux agents de police
d'avoir les mêmes disponibilités ou les
mêmes possibilités que les douaniers
rien de plus c'est une visite sommaire
c'est de garantir que à l'intérieur du
véhicule il n'y ait pas une personne en
situation irrégulière qui vient de trans
de de 1 2 3 de transiter via la
frontière grâce à un réseau de passeurs
nous luttons contre les passeurs si vous
retirez ça vous enlevez des moyens
complémentaires à la police donc
défavorable monsieur
RZ
oui merci monsieur le Président j'ai pas
beaucoup de choses à ajouter par rapport
à ce qu'a dit de façon excellente le
rapporteur mendz mais on rejoint un peu
ce qui s'est passé tout à l'heure avec
l'article 14 une vision complètement
déconnectée de la réalité et et du crime
organisé et de ces résseau extrêmement
inquiétant cet article va nous permettre
de mieux lutter contre le crime organisé
c'est pas de s'attaquer à des personnes
qui qui veulent passer de façon
irrégulière et qui sont des fois dans
des situations dramatiques c'est bien
les réseaux de passeur et et étant donné
comme l'a dit le rapporteur que cette
ces réseaux de passeurs se sont adaptés
à notre droit voyant que nous n'avons
pas la possibilité de de contrôler des
véhicules individuels il nous faut être
pragmatique il nous faut faire preuve de
bon sens et donc d'adapter la loi c'est
pour ça que nous voterons contre ces
amendements je vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement est excessive cet article
pardon est excessivement important euh
pour mon territoire euh les migrants qui
sont amenés par les passeurs pour tenter
les traverser chaque nuit de la Manche
et de la Mer du Nord ne sont pas ceux
qui stagnent aujourd'hui dans le calésie
pour la plupart ils sont amenés
maintenant depuis la Belgique voire les
Pays-Bas au moment du passage à quelques
heures de passer parfois une stationne
en France quelques minutes le temps pour
eux de mettre le pied sur la plage
d'embarquer sur un smallbot et d'aller à
la mort et donc avec cet amendement de
suppression vous faites en sorte de
pouvoir continuer le business des
passeurs de ceux qui vont en Belgique
faire stationner les migrants et les
amener sur les côes du Nord de la France
c'est évidemment excessivement important
que les forces de l'ordre puissent
contrôler les véhicule pour sauver des
vies dans la Manche et d'ailleurs je
sais pas si c'est une réponse à avoir de
la part du ministre mais est-ce qu'il
est possible de l'étendre aux zones
litoral une fois qu'on a passé les zones
frontières est-ce qu'on peut s'assurer
que les policiers puissent le faire
également à ce
momentl monsieur
porteou merci bon d'abord il s'agirait
de faire une distinction entre les
missions de la PAF et les missions de la
douane d'autre part les douaniers sont
particulièrement opposé à l'idée de
faire un travail policier lorsqu'ils
sont
mais donc voilà nous les douaniers nous
ont dit clairement qu'ils étaient
opposés à àtre à se voir affecter une
telle mission de
police madame Diaz et après sera
monsieur le ministre oui merci monsieur
le Président nous nous sommes pas du
tout faorable à la suppression de cet
article pourquoi ben parce que nous nous
faisons confiance aux forces de l'ordre
qui font leur travail qui font un
travail remarquable dans des conditions
très difficiles au même titre que les
douaniers et ces deux catégories de
profession ont une vocation c'est
protéger les Français et dans cet
amendement nous nous sommes
particulièrement gênés par les relant
antiflic je vais vous citer la phrase
les associations témoignent d'un
harcèlement incessant de la part des
forces de police et nousent des
relsument désagré en matière de
victimisation des associations
immigrationnistes que qui se victimise
en disant qu'elles sont criminalisées
donc nous vous appelons à la raison
c'est incroyable que ce genre
d'amendement soit déposé et donc bien
évidemment nous votre rencontre Monsieur
le
Ministre bon c'est effectivement un
article extrêmement important pour
lutter contre l'immigration irrégulière
et contre le travail des des passeurs
puisque ce qu'on a constaté
c'est que puisque le contrôle était fait
de manière forte par les services en
général de police de gendarmerie de
police aux frontières même de douanier
pour avoir été 3 ans ministre des
douanes on y reviendra dans quelques
instants pour répondre à la question de
ce que peuv faire les douiniers par
rapport aux policiers on s'aperçoit qu'
ils ont changé leur stratégie avec des
véhicules plus petits des véhicules de
moins de 9 places où ils transportent
des migrants c'est particulièrement vrai
en effet dans la la région Nord monsieur
le député Dumont puisque vous le savez
que l'une difficulté d'aujourd'hui c'est
qu'une partie des personnes migrantes
organisé dans le passage organisé par
les passeurs passe à frontière où il n'y
a ni péréné ni Alpe quelques minutes
parfois avant d'aller dans le dquerco
dans le calisi pour aller se mettre sur
les bateaux faisant ainsi
évidemment un contournement du travail
que faisait auparavant dans les camions
qui malheureusement étit trop connu de
ces passeurs donc ce que fait cet
article c'est qu'il permet de s'adapter
et il s'agit bien de regarder dans une
voiture
particulière les personnes qui sont
transportées afin de commettre une
infraction relative à l'entrée des
séjours en France c'est très important
parce que les douaniers eux font un
travail bien sûr quand ils constatent
l'immigration irrégulière ils font
descendre les personnes puisquil s'agit
d'abord tout de protéger les vies
humaines quand on est dans un camion
dansentre des marchandises par exemple
c'est pas très bon signe mais eux leur
travail les doiniers c'est les
marchandises là travail des policiers
c'est les personnes et donc ils ne font
pas doignier de l'immigration
irrégulière une mission quand il tombe
sur des personnes dans un camion par
exemple il leur demande de descendre
parce qu'évidemment il constat une
infraction comme n'importe quelle
personne mais leur travail n'est pas
lutter contre l'immigration irrégulière
le travail c'est le travail des
policiers et effectivement les policiers
n'ont pas les moyens juridiques
aujourd'hui contrairement à d'autres
pays européens de faire ce contrôle des
personnes non pas des marchandises c'est
pour ça que cet article 17 est très
important pour lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière alors alors la
question de Monsieur Dumont est de
considérer est-ce qu'on peut utiliser
cet article excellent sur d'autres
sujets notamment les bandes frontalières
que représentent les band littoral je
pense qu'on peut
l'étudier parce que ce serait sans doute
abusif dans le droit on y regardera si
l'intégralité des bandes littorales
était concerné on peut imaginer par
exemple que la bande littorale
Atlantique n'est pas tellement concernée
par cette disposition en revanche que la
bande littorale de la Manche de qui va
de dquerque grosso modo jusqu'aux îles
angl-normandes euh que la bande
littorale autour de nos autres m je
pense évidemment à à Mayotte qui connaît
une proximité évidente avec les Comores
ou avec l'Afrique des grands lacs puiss
être concerné par une telle disposition
on peut on peut tout à fait l'imaginer
je pense que ça peut être l'occasion
d'une discussion alors peut-être
faudrait-il faire un avant 17 ou un
après-17 afin de de de constituer
évidemment un article en parce qu'il
n'aura pas été vérifié par le par le
Conseil d'État he c'est un pouvoir assez
important qu'on donne aux policiers en
tout cas moi je suis prêt à y travailler
pour pour la séance bien évidemment bien
je le mets au voix qui vote pour contre
rejeté le suivant monsieur mendz le
1712 merci monsieur le Président le but
c'est de de supprimer les alinéat 3 et 4
euh parce que il nous empêcherait en
fait de de pouvoir faire le travail
correctement exiger des raisons
plusibles risque donc de limiter
considérablement l'effet de la mesure
d'une part il ferait basculer dans le
champ judiciaire et non administratif et
ça aboutirait par un effet miroir avec
les dispositions du code de procédure
pénale donc on n plus dans la même
démarche que ce qui ce qui est proposé
dans cet article et le but c'est de
supprimer donc ces deux
alinéires bien je le mets au voix qui
vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté il
fait tomber le suivant de Monsieur Lucas
madame yousoufa vous avez un amendement
1226 merci monsieur le Président alors
cette amendement vise à autoriser les
inspections des véhicules maritimes au
même titre que les véhicules terrestres
s'appuyant sur le caractère
insulaire de la question migratoire à
maotte et constatant que les opérations
de lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine mobilisent considérablement
la gendarmerie nationale et que nous
observons sur le terrain comme vous
l'avez expliqué monsieur le ministre et
aussi mon collègue Dumont une adaptation
extrêmement rapide des des réseaux de de
traite d'êtres humains avec
à chaque fois de nouvelles méthodes plus
agiles plus fines et donc nous espérons
que que nous pourrons donner les moyens
également en mer d'aller contrôler en
fait on parle des plaisanciers puisque
là c'est c'est de de cela qu'il s'agit
et c'est ce qu'on observe à Mayotte donc
les passeurs peuvent être à peu près
n'importe qui merci beaucoup monsieur
mendz monur rapporteur alle-y alors
chers collègues
on avoue avoir été plutôt séduit par
votre proposition en l'état par contre
il faudrait la retravailler pour la
séance je propose de le retirer non
seulement parce que vous reprenez la
condition d'avoir des raisons plausibles
qu'on vient de supprimer d'une part
deuxièmement parce que vous prévoyez à
l'inverse le cadre procédural minimal
donc il faudrait qu'on puisse leorder
pour la science je propose qu'on qu'on
puisse échanger pour le réécrire en état
je propose donc de le retirer on n'est
pas défavorable mais l'écriture ne nous
correspond pas
Madame monsieurard
merci monsieur le Président je voulais
intervenir pour saluer cette excellente
proposition de ma collègue madame isoufa
parce qu'effectivement parmi les
difficultés que nous rencontrons
monsieur le ministre il y a la question
des voilier en provenance singulièrement
de de Madagascar et particulièrement de
nosbé où là on peut mettre en cause des
Français comme vous et moi qui ont des
voilés là-bas et qui transportent des
filles à à à à Mayotte pour participer à
des activités que nous dénonçons et
d'ailleurs vous avez sans doute vu que
récemment à à mramaadoudou euh la
prostitution chers collègues si vous
voulez que je le dise voilà c'est de
cela dont il s'agit la prostitution des
des jeunes filles qu' on fait venir de
Madagascar et qui par voilier et qui
voilà qui ont posé des gros problèmes
d'ordre public depuis tout le weekend
dernier où on a mobilisé la gendarmerie
pour sauver notamment les gens qui qui
qui organisent tout ça donc c'est c'est
vraiment essentiel pour nous qu'on lutte
contre ça ce sont des Français comme
vous et moi qui ont pignon sur eu qui le
font et qui s'enrichissent sur le dos
des pauvres des pauvres filles voilà
donc c'est très importantou retiz où oui
je je suivrai les indications et on
retravaillera le texte je vous remercie
retirreer monsieur gilet le
suivant oui en en 2021 près de 80
migrants étaient interpellé par la
police nationale dans un train en
provenance de bal et à destination de
mulouse ainsi le train notamment par
l'ouverture totale des frontière est
devenu un moyen de circulation prisé par
les migrants pour se rendre en France
alors que les OPJ de la police nationale
ou de la gendarmerie peuvent procéder à
des vérifications d'identité des
véhicules ferroviaires dans les zones
frontalières rien n'est prévu pour les
agents de la sécurité ferroviaire en
2021 5330 actes de violence verbale ou
physique soit 14 actes par jour ont été
commis contre les agents de la SNCF si
les forces de l'ordre traditionnel ne
sont pas en mesure d'assurer du fait de
leur nombreuses autres missions mais
aussi de leur manque d'effectif la
sécurité dans les transports
ferroviaires la sûreté ferroviaire la
SUGE de la SNF le peu acteur essentiel
de la sécurité ferroviaire dans les
gares les agents de la SUGE doivent
avoir les capacités juridiques de
procéder à ses contrôles c'est ce que
cet amendement propose merci monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable je voit qui vot
pour qui V contre je vous ai oublié
monsieur
excuse-moi l'intention monsieur lu
vraiment l'article 17 qui vote pour qui
vote contre
adopté le 18 ben monsieur Lucas c'est à
vous le
285 tout est pardonné monsieur le
Président non mais tout à l'heure une
collègue du rassemblement national a
dénoncé un prétendu discours antiflic de
ma part et de celui d'un certain nombre
de mes collègues je veux dire ici euh
bon je pourra être blessé si je
n'accordais pas si j'accordais du crédit
à ce que vous dites mais euh que en
réalité quand je dénonce du harcèlement
organisé c'est à des consignes que je
fais référence à des consignes qui font
y compris que nos forces de police sont
utilisées à des choses assez inutiles et
qu'elle feraient mieux d'être utilisé
ailleurs cont tenu d'un certain nombre
de problématiques que nous avons sur nos
sur nos territoire elles sont d'ailleurs
je considère que nos agents de police
sont également victimes de ces consignes
qui consistent à faire du harcèlement
permanent j'en veux pour preuve que
lorsque j'étais à à à briillançon il y a
quelques quelques semaines j'ai
rencontré un escadron de gendarmerie
venu de Toulouse qu'on amené ici faire
la course à des exiler dans des
montagnes gelées et qui arrête des gens
qui de toute façon repasseront parce que
quand on a franchi la moitié quand on a
traversé la moitié du globe pour venir
ici on n'est pas on ne fait pas
demi-tour si facilement donc vous voyez
c'est cette absurdité qui est
aujourd'hui un problème y compris pour
nos forces de l'ordre merci
monsieur monsieur Vallot le 937
oui merci monsieur le Président vous
vous créez un motif de refus de de visa
pour les étrangers qui sont vu délivrer
une TF depuis moins de 5 ans qui ne
peuvent démontrer qu'ils ont respecté
les délais impartis la mesure nous
paraît disproportionnée dans la mesure
où elle être automatique et qu'
concernera des personnes ayant pu
n'avoir qu'un REC regard d'exécution
très faible et pour de de juste motif
c'est les raisons pour laquelle nous
proposons la suppression de cet article
madame
tourg nous nous opposons à l'extension
de la durée maximale pendant laquelle
l'interdiction de retour sur le
territoire produirait soi-disant des des
effets c'est le Sénat qui propose cette
mesure la passant de 3 ans initialement
à 5 et exceptionnellement même 10 et euh
nous voyons ici encore comment le
ministère de de l'Intérieur érige
l'instrumentalisation du critère de la
menace à l'ordre public en doctrine du
gouvernement nous rappelons aussi que
les mesures d'éloignement doivent être
entériné par le l'administ l'autorité
administrative pardon et ça doit tenir
compte de la durée de la présence de
l'étranger sur le territoire de la
nature et de l'ancienneté de ces liens
avec la France donc en fait on en
revient à l'individualisation en quelque
sorte de la peine c'est ce que nous
proposons c'est notre vision de de la
justice qui n'est donc effectivement qui
est donc à l'opposé de celle du ministre
monsieur rapporteur
oui monsieur Lucas vous vous vous avez
dit à plusieurs reprises depuis depuis
lundi parfois nous nous répondions à des
questions que vous ne posiez pas vous
vous souvenez de cette phrase j'ai bien
aimé d'ailleurs mais la il vous arrive
aussi de commenter des article qui qui
n'existe pas de la même façon d'abord
votre amendement s'appuie sur la version
initiale du du du du gouvernement et pas
du tout sur C du Sénat mais ça peu
importe sur le fond sur le
fond vous évoquez les difficultés
juridiques l'avis du Conseil d'État
était très nette sur ce sur ce point il
y a aucune difficulté particulière et
ensuite il n'y a là que l'augmentation
de la durée maximale des interdictions
de retour sans à aucun moment modifier
les conditions qui permettraient de
décider de
l'interdiction de de retour en France
voilà avec une appréciation au cas par
cas par les préfets enfin on est très
très loin de ce que vous avez pu dire
monsieur donc il monsieur Lucas donc il
nous arrive nous de se poser des
questions au regard des arguments qui
n'existe pas dans le texte monsieur
pèin mes chers collègues comme vous le
savez il est difficile de faire
respecter les décisions d'ocf et
l'objectif fixé par ce projet de loi est
de rendre à ces décision leur pleine
effectivité
permettre à un étranger visé par uneqtf
d'obtenir un visa seulement 3 ans après
son son expulsion va à l'encontre de cet
objectif qui est par ailleurs au cœur de
la démarche de simplification prévue à
l'article
21 l'article 18 tel qu'il est porté
aujourd'hui répond à un équilibre d'un
côté il permet de favoriser la lutte
contre l'immigration illégale en
assurant une meilleure effec effectivité
des décisions de qtf de l'autre il
garantit une certaine équité en en
empêchant qu'une qtf interdise
définitivement à un étranger d'obtenir
un visa pour la France porter la durée
maximale d'interdiction de retour à 5
ans s'inscrit parfaitement dans cet
équilibre et c'est pour cette raison que
le groupe Renaissance votera contre cet
amendement de
suppression je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre
rejeté l'amendement de Madame Genevard
le
1521 merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement du groupe les républicains
propose supprimer tout délai maximum
d'une interdiction de retour sur le
territoire français principalement pour
ce qui concerne les personnes qui ont
fait l'objet de cette disposition et qui
représentera une menace grave pour
l'ordre
public rapporteur défavorable supprimer
toute limite maximale à la durée de
l'interdiction de retour est une
contrainte contraire au droit européen
don rien pour ça défavorable madame
Martin al c'est vrai que c'est assez
notable de voir mais ça ça devient une
sorte de litanie de de voir que l'on
puisse s'affranchir au droit de l'Union
européenne alors sur certains aspects
pourquoi pas là où ça se complique c'est
quand il est question de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme par
ailleurs il y a un autre élément qui qui
attire notre attention c'est le fait que
vous visiez plus particulièrement les
Algériens moi j'invite chacun ici en
tant que député représentation nationale
à réfléchir au lien qui nous Liss qui
nous lit à à ce pays et et ce peuple
frère et je crains que ce soit du côté
de la France en tant que tel que les
relations é été beaucoup abîmées
beaucoup abîmées donc je pense que si le
peuple algérien ou des Algériens lit
cela et relie ça avec votre volonté de
de d'être de viser plus particulièrement
ceux qui représentent un danger
particulièrement grave ah je suis pas
sûr que ça arrange nos relations a quand
même alors je pardon madame jeuneva
oui j'entends monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur
l'inconstitutionnalité de la mesure mais
c'est une façon de vous dire que pour
être efficace il faut réformer la
Constitution précisé je mets au voix
votre amendement madame jeunevard qui
vote pour s qui contre rejeter le
suivant monsieur
mendz monsieurci monsieur le Président
cet amendement euh permet en fait de de
réécrire l'article 18 et d'y intégrer
l'article 10 bis qui avait été retiré
par le rapporteur Pradal tout à l'heure
qui permet donc de fixer à 10 ans la
durée maximale de l'interdiction de
retour en cas de menace grave pour
l'ordre public comme le permet la
directive retour au niveau européen de
prévoir un mécanisme de réexamen
périodique de l'interdiction de retour
sur le modèle de ce qui existe en
matière d'expulsion cela permettra de
vérifier l'adéquation de la mesure à
l'évaluation de la menace et de la
situation personnelle de l'étranger je
vous remercie merci Madame Dupon
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
sauf erreur de ma part il me semble que
l'avis du Conseil d'État n'est de est de
ne pas retenir cette disposition parce
qu'il est déjà possible pour l'autorité
consilaire de de s'enquérir des
conditions d'exécution duune noqtf et
d'en tenir compte pour accueillir ou
rejeter une demande et que cette
modification via l'article 18
fragiliserait le pouvoir discrétionnaire
de l'autorité consulaire et entraînerait
de nouveaux contentieux donc j'aimerais
avoir des éléments de d'explication par
rapport à ce point s'il vous
plaît alors monsie madame Martin et
après monsieur rapporteur là aussi
permettez-nous de de vous faire part de
notre étonnement pensez-vous vraiment
que ce que cela soit de cette manière
que l'on puisse avancer et protéger le
pays pensez-vous que de telles mesures
ont une efficacité lorsque une personne
fustelle algérienne d'ailleurs souhaite
quitter son pays s'exiler pour rentrer
dans le nôtre article après article
amendement après amendement ce qui est
révélé c'est le fait que nous sommes pas
dans le sujet et qu'au fond si l'on veut
avancer de bonne manière sur ces sujets
c'est bien la question de l'accueil
qu'il faut traiter et la question de des
phénomènes qui ont lieu dans les pays
dont les personnes s'exilent et entendu
encore une fois que ça n'est pas nous
les pays du Nord qui qui en recevons le
plus je voudrais juste apporter une
réponse à Madame Dupont je crois que
vous vous êtes trompé de texte vous avez
repris l'article 18 initial et donc là
l'article a était totalement réécrit et
en l'état ça répond à vos à vos
attentes vois qui vote pour amendement
du
rapporteur qui vote contre il est adopté
l'amendement suivant monsieur monsieur
porte 73 merci monsieur le Président ici
un amendement pour demander à ce que la
durée d'interdiction de retour sur le
territoire français fixé par la
préfecture soit motivé et tiennent
compte de la situation personnelle de
l'intéressé et permettez-moi d'utiliser
cet amendement pour répondre au députés
du rassembl national qui ont demandé que
les chemo pratiquent un contrôle dans
les trains dès 2017 les chemo c'était
opposé aux directifs de la direction
qu'il considérait qu'il n'avait pas à
faire de délation et de chasses aux
migrants dans les trains fidèles à leur
valeurs de service
public rapporteur répondez alors je
crois pas que c'était l'amendement mais
en tout cas retrait auou défavorable
parce qu'il est
satisfait je me voie qui vaêtre pour
contre
rejeté le l'article 18 qui vote
pour qui vote contre
adoptéprès l'article 18 madame
jeunevar
122 cet amendement concerne le délai
d'exécution du des
TF que nous souhaiterions voir porter à
7 jours monsieur le rapporteur ah pardon
il y a une discussion alors vous
choisissez l'une des
deuxtion
voil monsieur micro monsieur le
Président le nombre d'étrangers
clandestin sur notre sol ne cesse
d'augmenter on compte aujourd'hui plus
de 700000 personnes en situation
irrégulière d'après le ministère de
l'Intérieur et certaines études montrent
même que ce chiffre dépasse sûrement le
million au premier trimestre 2022 et ce
depuis des années les chiffres
d'exécution des qtf sont mauvais cette
année seulement 6,9 % ont été exécutés
ce qui est très mauvais est ce qui fait
de la France l'un des plus mauvais
élèves d'Europe alors que les violence
les crimes les délits commis par des
individus étrangers explosent et que
l'exécution des écf est proche du néant
un message clair et presque in citatif
est ainsi envoyé aux étrangers mettez un
pied en France et vous aurez la quasi
certitude de pouvoir vous y installer
définitivement Didier l'allemand dresse
3 mois après son départ de la préfecture
de police de Paris un constat sans appel
à Paris un délit sur deux est commis par
un étranger souvent en situation
irrégulière face à ces chiffres le lien
entre immigration etécurité ne peut plus
être merci ah bah ou monsieur Nagel n'a
pas là pour défendre son amendement qui
défend
1318 je crois qu'il l' pas
défendu m adan non pas pas défendu 1318
défendu monsieur le
rapporteur alors ça sera défavorable je
rappelle que l'administration peut
refuser d'accorder un tel délai
d'ailleurs sur le qtf étant alors
exécutoire sans délai donc ça c'est ce
que à la possibilité de de de faire
l'administration ce n'est pas en
rédisant de moitié le délai pour
exécuter les qtf que on fera plus
d'exécutions du moins de cesqtf qu'elles
seront mieux exécutées et je rappelle
que le 21 novembre dernier les éléments
qui expliquent euh en apparence que le
faible retour de de de ces
ressortissants ont été expliqués par le
ministre de l'Intérieur Géral d'Anin
devant nous euh et il a été je crois
suffisamment explicite pour démontrer
que c'est pas un problème de délai de
plus on aurait un risque sur les recours
parce que ça pourrait causer par écocher
des perturbations sur les délais de
recours donc totalement défavoraable sur
ces amendements
oui deux choses d'abord sur la
délinquence puisque je vous entends
plusieurs fois citer les les chiffres en
citant le préfet de police
d'allemand je vrais vous rappeler
peut-être ce qui se passe en 2023 c'est
vrai qu'il reste encore un mois donc
mais bon en 2023 le la part des
étrangers mis en cause dans le giron la
préfecture de police c'est 37 %
c'estàdire que nous avons gagné 4 points
si ose dire de délinquances étrangères
en moins à Paris de 23 à 22 et 13 points
par rapport à aux déclarations du préfet
de police qui était celle celui de de de
son année en 2020 c'estd qu' la part de
délinquan des étrangers vous le savez
très bien d'ailleurs c'est pas la peine
de répéter 50 % aujourd'hui c'est 37 %
régulière et irrégulière voilà donc on
pourra regarder pour la séance
d'ailleurs la distinction entre les
irréguliers et les réguliers parce que
effectivement souvent ça ne veut pas
dire grand-chose mais souvent
irréguliers on sait pas très bien ce que
ça veut dire donc aujourd'hui c'est un
gros tiers de la délinquence en
île-de-fance première couronne de Paris
et Paris qui représente elle-même 60 %
de la délinquance générale donc vous
pourriez vous féliciter que la politique
menée par le gouvernement c'est 13
points de recul la dévincance étrangère
dans la CHV vous ne le faites pas alors
que j'ai déjà explicité plusieurs fois
ces chiffres parce que préférez sans
doute lire votre note qui a ét a dû être
rédigée en 2020 ou 21 manifestement
deème sujet monsieur
gilet c'est c'est c'est très important
de comprendre ce que vous le rapporteur
et vous pouvez pé là aussi que les alors
déjà vous dites un million de qtf là on
n pas tout à fait compris d'où vit ce
chiffre là c'était aussi un nouveau un
nouveau chiffre je sais pas quelle est
votre source aujourd'hui il y a 110000
120000 mesures administratives qui ne
sont pas toutes des ETF il y a des ITF
voilà mais entre 110000 et 120000 à peu
près toute chaque année de mesures
administratives voilà non mais vousz pas
desqtf monsieur gilet après P être
imprécis mais préciser dans ces cas-là
euh 110000
120000 qtf vous dites ah bah il y en a
que 7 % appliqué bon d'abord monsieur
gilet je vais vous répéter pour la 8e
fois sans doute la 9e fois comment les
choses
fonctionnent aujourd'hui vous mettez
tout dans le même panier et vous mettez
les eqtf qui sont un départ volontaire
des départs forcés et ce que nous
comptons dans les chiffres que nous
fournissons à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat ce sont les départs forcés si
vous multipliez tous les départs
exceptter ceux qui sont dans la zone
Schengen puisque comme on l'a déjà
démontré ici on ne peut pas compter un
qtf qui part partir de France pour aller
en Belgique ou de France pour aller en
Italie puisque par nature les espaces
sont libres ceux qui sort de l'espace
Schengen c'est autour de 18 à 20 % selon
les années donc déjà on n'est pas à 7 %
d'application on est autour de 20 %
c'est pas beaucoup mais c'est le taux le
plus important de l'Union européenne je
n'ai pas entendu ni la Grande-Bretagne
parce que quand elle est en
responsabilité en Europe c'était 4000
par an la Grande-Bretagne de reconduite
aux frontières quand on en fait plus de
20000 nit madame mélonie faire davantage
puisque c'est beaucoup moins nous sommes
le premier pays malgré tout malgré
toutes les difficultés elles sont
nombreuses c'est pour ça qu'on dans ce
texte à pouvoir conduire les personnes
dans leur pays d'origine troisièmement
vous faites semblant toujours de
constater que ces eqtf monsieur gilet ce
sont tous ces ETF que je pourrais
exécuter mais c'est tout à fait faux
plus de 60 % d'entre eux ont des recours
et donc sont suspensifs c'est l'objet du
texte de loi que nous vous présentons et
donc dans quelques instants monsieur le
rapporteur va vous préciser à quel point
les articles suivants des titres 3 4 et
5 sont très importants pour limiter les
durées des recours et pour limiter les
délais de ces recours c'est pas les
délais des eqtf qu'il faut sur lequel il
faut agir c'est sur les recours et les
recours c'est un an 1 an et demi 2 ans
de procédure pendant que le qtf lui dure
que quelques mois et donc on ne peut pas
expulser ou éloigner des personnes s'ils
font recours contre lequtf donc ce qu'il
faut c'est réduire des recours donc les
chiffres que vous donnez vous le savez
pertinemment parce que j'imagine que
vous êtes un garçon intelligent et puis
vous avez lu votre fich donc j'imagine
que vous l'avez travaillé ou quelqu'un
l'a la travailler avec vous sont
totalement faux voilà donc vous sur une
base qui est déjà assez compliquée sur
lequel on est tous d'accord sur lequel
il faut faire des efforts et je pense
que ce texte c'est la démonstration que
le gouvernement na pris conscience vous
dites des inepsies des contevérités sans
jamais citer vos sources c'est bien
dommage parce que je pensais que le
débat était intéressant alors il y a
quatre intervenants monsieur Lucas
madame 5 monsieur Lucas madame Martin et
madame keloashi monsieur gilet oui
monsieur le Président merci profite pour
livrer une réflexion constructive qui
pourra sans doute éclairer nos débats
puisque
emtion d'accord bon donc je livre cette
cette réflexion à notre sagacité
collective bon c'est pas grave je ferai
une prochaine fois monsieur gilet
oui monsieur le Président je voudrais
répondre à à monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre vous pouvez nier la
réalité la surreprésentation des
étrangers dans les violences dans la
délinquence en général comme la
surreprésentation des étrangers dans nos
prisons est une réalité et vous ne ferez
pas croire le contraire au français s'il
y a une nette amélioration ces derniers
mois je serai le premier à m'en
féliciter on attendra les chiffres
définitifs on vous connait dans la
manipulation des chiffres sur les OQTF
monsieur le ministre vous êtes bien
gentil de dire que que ça a augmenté
mais et que et que finalement c'est la
législation qui vous empêche de les
exécuter et les recours mais je vous
rappelle quand même que vos
prédécesseurs faisaient largement mieux
que vous et que pourtant la législation
n'a pas évolué en la matière donc
monsieur le ministre il ne faut pas
raconter tout n'importe quoi et puis
pour répondre à ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure vous disiez que nous misions
sur les problèmes pour gagner bah si on
mise sur les problèmes pour gagner vu
votre nullité et votre bilan croyez bien
qu'on va gagner en 2027
oui pas du tout non je suis très zine je
suis
trèsine je suis choquée par la le manque
de qualité des des interventions du
remblement national mais
passons je j'aimerais revenir sur
l'amendement de madame jeunev qui coche
toutes les cases d'un message politique
qui ne trompe personne stigmatisation
des Algériens il y a les termisson
auqtf rétention algérien tout y est dans
cette magnifique amendement pour montrer
la fermeté des républicains la fermeté
des républicains qui ne sont pas au
pouvoir délivrer des
tf oui mais j'ai le droit de parole là
maintenant tout de
suite délivrer des milliers d'qtf
réduire les délais passer de 7 jours à 3
jours pourquoi pas à 24 heur passons à
24 he ça ne changera rien absolument
rien au problème de l'exécution de ces
TF premièrement et deuxièmement ça ne
changera encore moins rien du tout à au
fait que l'arrivée de tous ces migrants
de Migs qui F la pauvreté sera massive
alors madame Martin ou madame Tor qui
parle c'est un par groupe depuis mais on
sétait
pase s'il vous plaît juste avant de
faire mon rebond est-ce que je peux
juste vous dire deux mots monsieur le
Président merci en fait vous voyez on
est tous quand même fatigués le sujet
est très
grave pour beaucoup d'entre nous il génè
beaucoup d'émotions parce que nous
sommes sur
euh oui un sujet qui va quand même
impacter beaucoup de gens que peut-être
certains d'entre nous accompagnent dans
leurs circonscription moi c'est mon cas
et donc on est un peu à fleur de peau
donc euh je je ne sais pas comment vous
voulez organiser les débats moi
j'aimerais
bien vous avez fait votre appel j'ai
compris votre appel vous avez une minute
maintenant pour vous exprimer sur
l'amendementci je vous remercie donc euh
voilà moi je veux dire que euh à à ma
aux républicains que cet amendement me
sidère me sidère parce que il se TER
l'exposé des des motifs se termine avec
cette phrase en gras cette disposition
est applicable au ressortissant algérien
donc c'est dans c'est dans l'exposé
sommaire ça ne peut pas donc être dans
la rédaction de la loi parce qu'on
stigmatise
une un un un pays donc là c'est vraiment
le qui est écrit dans ce texte c'est
extrêmement grave et donc moi ce que je
vais faire c'est que cet amendement je
vais le publier je vais le distribuer
dans ma circonscription pour que les
gens comprennent à quel point là on a
passé un cap un cap dans le racisme et
je vous assure que là j'ai une pensée
j'ai une pensée pour tous les gens qui
sont issus de de la communauté
algérienne alors amendement de Madame
jeunevar le 1252 qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté celui de Monsieur gilet le
253 identique qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté le 676 de monsieur nagelen
n'est pas défendu le 57 à l'article
suivant le 18 bis monsieur
Lucas merci monsieur le Président je
voulais simplement livrer à notre
sagacité collective il y a un instant
cette petite réflexion qui m'est venu en
entendant le collègue du rassemblement
national dire disant il y a trop de qtf
non exécuté c'est peut-être parce qu'on
délivre trop de qtf et que ça démontre
l'absurdité l'absurdité de la politique
brutale et répressive qui est celle dans
notre pays il faut être réaliste et
pragmatique et donc moi je crois
qu'effectivement on distribue trop trop
de de qtf évidemment et et et enfin et
enfin d'un mot si je peux terminer ch ch
collègues euh merci président VO euh
pour dire là aussi moi j'ai été ce que
je voulais dire dans mon intervention
précédente mais extrêmement choqué j'ai
une pensée pour les Algériens qui vivent
en France pour les franco-algériens qui
peut-être regardent nos débats en tout
cas en verront l'État dans la presse et
qui se verront stigmatisés de la sorte
je crois que le débat politique madame
jeunevard ne permet pas tout et je crois
que la haine de ceux qui viennent de
l'autre côté de la Méditerranée ne
permet pas tout il y a de la desence je
regrette que les républicains aient
perdu leur boussole et notamment leur
boussole
républicaine amendement identique
monsieur
Valot moi simplement j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que parce que
quelqu'un n'est pas parti de France
alors il ne pourra pas revenir pendant
un certain nombre d'années pour attirer
votre attention sur à la fois je gagne
au grattage au tirage pour reprendre une
qui a été yé hier je ne sais plus par
lequel de ces messieurs derrière
derrière la tribune donc je vais attirer
votre attention sur le caractère un peu
absurde de cette disposition si elle est
adoptée et sur l'engorgement
supplémentaire en terme de de de de
réclamation et de recours que cela va
susciter tout ça et rien n'est réaliste
en fait dans ce que vous proposez tout
n'est que tracasserie avec une
incapacité de surcroix à mettre en œuvre
je crois que nous on est bien plus
réaliste que vous alors le suivant pas
défendu madame desjonkerer celui d'après
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement euh donc effectivement cet
amendement parce que il nous apparaît
qu'il est d'ors et déjà possible à
l'autorité consulaire de s'enquérir des
conditions d'exécution d'une TF et d'en
tenir compte pour acter ou non la
demande monsie le
rapporteur défavorable je mets au voix
qui vote pour pour contre
rejeté le 18 bis qui vot pour contre
rejet adop pardon excusez-moi le suivant
le 975 de madame obono qui le
défend le 975
madame
alors qui le
fait pardon
excusez-moi donc N nous sommes vous
savez d'ailleurs c'est une tradition
française assez vigilant sur les enfin
en tout cas jusqu'à maintenant on peut
dire qu'il y avait en France une
vigilance à la au respect de la vie de
la vie privée et une grande attention et
précaution quant à la manipulation de
fichiers évidemment on sent bien au
travers d'un certain nombre de
dispositions dans cette loi si elle
était votée qui bien sûr seront mis en
place et qui relèv du fichage et de la
surveillance des étrangers c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous demandons à ce
que on arrête ce type de développement
puis par ailleurs on doit vous dire
qu'on n pas complètement dupe hein on
l'a bien mesuré quand le dispositif VSA
a été adopté dans cette fameuse loi Jo
et et autres dispositifs que derrière
tout ça il y a aussi évidemment des
intérêts financiers et industriels
voilà Monsieur rapporteur défavorable
parce que vous parlez des des
départements frontaliers mais quit des
aéroports qui n'y sont pas situés si je
prends par exemple je rappelle qu'on
peut arriver en France directement à
roissie à Lyon saintexupéri à mes Nancy
Loren donc la réalité c'est que ça ne
s'appliquer s'appliquerait aussi de
facto et on n'est pas frontalier donc
défavorable monsieur
kbrat monsie Krat non madame jeunevar
oui merci monsieur le Président alors un
mot d'explication sur la mention de
l'Algérie personne n'ignore ici les
relations particulières et exorbitant du
droit commun qui unissent la France et
l'Algérie en matière d'accueil des
étrangers venant de ce pays il s'agit
pas de stigmatiser il s'agit de
reconnaître un état de fait c'est tout
tout simplement et vous le savez
plusieurs groupes politiques considèrent
qu'il faut revoir ces accords de
68 Édouard Philippe lui-même s'est
exprimé sur le
sujet et ça sera l'objet du premier
texte de la niche des républiqu
laabol la stigmatisation l'opion d'autru
quand elle n'est pas la vre c'est ça qui
est insupportable monsieur Brat et après
on
voter ça c'est je pense que c'est la
[Musique]
nostalpurésidentz paste mais la réalité
elle est iluneé de discriminer votre
propos et le propos des républicains à
part de souligner la mesure
anticonventionnelle euh et de poser une
question de la mention très spécifique
que votre vos amendements ne parlent pas
de réviser d'accord 68 mais précise bien
les ressortissants algériens à chaque
fois ce qui fait une stigmatisation ce
pourquoi ce pourquoi nous réagissons et
je vais vous étonner madame jeunev mais
je crois que oui on pourrait revenir à
une discussion sur accord 68 mais en
revenant et en dénonçant ces accords
vous voulez dire que vous autorisez donc
le cadre qui était avant 68 62 la libre
circulation totale entre les deux pays
pour pouvoir permettre l'installation et
le retour de tout le monde comme c'était
le cas r dans
le bon alors on vote cet amendement et
puis qui votre pour
contre
rejeté le suivant de madameard n'est pas
défendu monsieur monsieur s'il vous
plaît le 944 de Monsieur
Vall 944 l'article
19 on se calme s'il vous plaît laissz la
parole à Monsieur monsieur
Luc
micro
allezê de
parler d'une manière générale c'est
réflex critique sur CR des des pôles des
pôles territoriaux franceasile on n'est
pas évidemment opposé ni à la question
de la simplification ni du
raccourcissement du parcours
administratif des demandeurs d'asile
mais il peut y avoir une discordance
entre le désir
d'accélération pour ensuite reconduire
ce qui ne seraient pas éligible à
l'asile et la nécessité de prendre
connaissance de ce qui s'est
effectivement passé et
d'accompagner les les récits auprès de
populations particulièrement vulnérabl
et euh certaines questions de de de
fonds structurel se pose quant à la
création de de des pôles franceasil dont
le détail est quand même mal assuré dans
l'étude d'impact qui ne dit pas
grand-chose de cette de cette
expérimentation c'est le statut de
sespôules le lien hiérarchique qu'il y
aurait entre leurs agents et ceux de la
préfecture dès lors qu'il serai dans les
mêmes locaux les missions dévoluent aux
agents de même que leur statut mérit pr
d'être d'être
précisé s'il s'agit de l'introduction et
de l'enregistrement du formulaire de
demande d'asile nous fait observer que
ça ne peut pas être fait par des agents
de catégorie B je terminerai cette
phrase un autre jour mon kbrat
972 madame c'est bien on va prolonger on
va prolonger si je puis dire ce qui
vient d'être dit nous ce qui nous paraît
important c'est rappeler que en matière
d'asile qui est quelque chose de très
particulier lié à à la Convention de
Genève de 100 de de 1951 pardon et qui
dit que la France accepte de mettre sous
sous protection d'une façon
inconditionnelle des personnes qui sont
en danger dans leur pays pour diverses
raisons la façon d'évaluer cette mise en
danger c'est le récit et donc ça
signifie queil faut créer les conditions
dans le temps dans l'espace et dans
l'organisation pour que ce récit puisse
être puisse être recueilli si l'on
entend la question du du du
raccourcissement du délai le
raccourcissement du délai ne doit pas
être une entrave comme ça vient d'être
dit à la possibilité de connaître ses
droits de savoir où l'on est de s'être
repéré et d'avoir cet endroit privilégié
où l'on pourra être entendu et déposer
si je puis dire son son récit voilà nous
nous sommes inquiets à la fois par la
confusion qu'induit ses Paul franceasile
et par ce raccourcissement du temps qui
ne paraît pas être au bénéf des
demandeurs d'asile madame genevar le 19
1512 pardon de rien 1205 pas
défendu donc c'est un amendement du
groupe des Républicains qui propose de
supprimer l'article
19 nous considérons que la création de
pôles territoriaux franceasile peut
mettre en difficulté les les préfectures
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
nous proposons la suppression de cet
article monsie le
rapporteur
merci président
euh alors rappelez un peu l'article 19
nous serons je serai défavorable sur sur
les amendements de suppression d'abord
parce que l'article 19 a pour principal
objectif d'améliorer la lisibilité de la
procédure de demande d'asile pour les
demandeurs d'asile eux-mêmes euh
l'article 19 apporte pour les demandeurs
d'asile du moins une aide aux demandeurs
d'asile pour effectuer leurs demandes
sur les territoires il sera mieux armé
que que ne le sont sont les agents de
préfecture notamment pour aider au choix
de la langue dans laquelle se tiendra
l'entretien individuel du demandeur on a
des problématiques d'interprétariat
parfois avec des ressortissants venant
de certaines régions de certains pays on
l'a vu avec l'Afghanistan le Bangladesh
ou d'autres territoires il faut qu'on
puisse avoir les bons interprètes et en
général selon le territoire où vous êtes
vu l'habitude de la procédure ça sera
beaucoup plus simple à mettre en place
je rappelle aussi qu'il est essentiel de
présiser qu'un délai suffisant est
maintenu entre l'introduction de la
demande et l'entretien personnel du
demandeur d'asile avec un agent de
protection de l'OFPRA et et cet
entretien cette instruction se fera
toujours à Montreuil comme c'était le
cas jusqu'à
maintenant sur l'inquiétude concernant
le l'indépendance de l'ofra je préfère
le vous rassurer l'ofra sera toujours
indépendant c'est garanti aussi par
l'article l121 7 du czda et ça ne
changera pas monsieur Valot vous avvez
commencé à parler de des catégories des
agents ce seront des agents de catégorie
B il y aura des recrutements
complémentaires d'environ 150 agents sur
ces territoire là leur objectif c'est de
de de d'organiser l'enregistrement avec
un récit sommaire pour la demande
d'asile donc défavorable à la
suppression de cet
article monsieur
Luca merci Monsieur le le président cet
article poursuit l'objectif de traiter
tout plus vite alors qu'on parle de
personnes dont les demandes doivent être
étudiées avec soin et cela parfois peut
prendre du temps c'est un dispositif qui
nous apparaît à bien des égard dangereux
notamment parce qu'il remet en question
euh nous persistons à le dire
l'indépendance de l'OFPRA monsieur le
rapporteur vis-à-vis de des des
préfectures on a d'ailleurs eu ces
derniers jours des des grèves du
personnel de l'OFPRA qui réclament
notamment l'affirmation de leur
indépendance c'est donc la question est
posée cette indépendance elle est une
condition absolument primordiale pour
avoir une bonne instruction des dossiers
une appréciation individualisée vraiment
individualisée des différents cas donc
de notre point de vue et nous venons en
appui aux amendements qui ont été
évoqués cet article 19 est une des des
pierres de dégradation des garant anti
prococédurale attaché à la demande
d'asile Mad
Diaz merci monsieur le Président alors
la nup refuse la création de pôles
territoriaux France asile parce qu'elle
parce que ces pôles aurent évocation à
accélérer la procédure et donc la nupes
critique le fait que plus on juge vite
plus on expulse vite et donc en fait par
par cet amendement laanupes fait la
démonstration de sont dégoûtants fond de
commerce ils surfent sur la précarité
sur l'incertitude administrative et en
fait ils ont bien compris le système ils
savent que et bien plus les étrangers en
situation irrégulière restent sur notre
territoire plus ils ont de chances de
travailler et donc d'être régularisé et
là ils peuvent vous dire merci pour la
loi que vous êtes en train de faire
passer ils savent que plus les
clandestins restent plus ils ont de
chance de fonder une famille et donc il
sera là aussi plus difficile de les
expulser et là encore ils peuvent vous
dire merci donc en l'absence de volonté
du gouvernement de réduire les filières
d'immigration ils imposent aux Français
leur idéologie aussi funeste que
coûteuse ça sera sans nous madame gevnou
madame
gevnou merci monsieur le Président j'ai
eu peur à un moment que madame Diaz dise
qu'elle était d'accord avec la nupes le
suspense non nous bien sûr onevendra au
groupe Renaissance rejeter ces
amendements de suppression parce qu'on
considère que la création de ces points
franceasile sont vraiment un plus
aujourd'hui un demandeur d'asile il doit
se présenter d'abord dans une structure
d'accueil qui est gérée par des
associations puis ensuite faire sa
demande d'asile auprès d'un guichet
unique à la préfecture puis ensuite se
voir délivrer des conditions matérielles
par l'OFI puis enfin examiner se faire
examiner introduire et faire examiner sa
demande par l'OF pr donc on le voit il y
a une multiplicité d'interlocuteur
multiplicité d' interterlocuteur sur
multiplicité de sites ce qui donne un
délai moyen d'examen de cette demande de
122 jours nous ce qu'on propose ce que
propose le gouvernement et ce que
soutiendra le groupe renaiss dans la
création de ces points territoriaux
françisî c'est bien de simplifier cette
démarche en regroupant les acteurs et en
faisant en sorte que le projet de
l'instruction c'est rapide et de
simplifier les les les délais et les
démarches pour l'instruction de la
demande d'asile sans que celle-ci soit
moins bien instruite qu'auparavant merci
monsieur le rapporteur général oui non
mais simplement quelques mots parce que
j'ai j'ai du mal à comprendre euh les
oppositions qui viennent de de de
s'exprimer on est quun échange c'est
donc normal mais c'est une mesure certes
de simplification sur les 21 jours mais
je je reviendrai sur ce sujet les 21
jours seront possibles plus tard le
Sénat y a veillé c'est une très bonne
chose mais c'est surtout une mesure de
très grande protection contrairement à
ce que vous avez pu dire mes chers
collègues ça veut dire que dès
l'enregistrement dès l'enregistrement il
y aura un agent de l'OFPRA de catégorie
B qui viendra s'assurer d'un certain
nombre d'éléments qui sont fondamentaux
pour la protection de du futur récit
détaillé qui se fera ici en région
parisienne dès le départ nous aurons un
agent de l'OFPRA qui vérifiera la
situation le cas échant de vulnérabilité
ce sera pas un agent de préfecture c'est
lui qui vérifiera la langue parce qu'en
réalité c'est extrêmement important de
de de le savoir dès le départ et c'est
pas simplement un agent de de préfecture
ce sera un agent de l'OF pr c'est lui
qui permettra de recueillir le premier
élément de récit sommaire sommaire
détaillé bien sûr que le récit détaillé
interviendra au moment de l'introduction
de de la demande de l'instruction pardon
de la demande donc vraiment rapprocher
l'OFPRA des demandeurs d'asile c'est
certes de la simplification puisqu'il y
a un gain de temps de 21 jours mais
c'est surtout la possibilité d'avoir un
agent de l'OFPRA tout de suite auprès du
demandeur d'asile et j'ajoute que le
demandeur d'asile pourra compléter bien
sûr son récit sommaire il ne sera pas
fixé dès le départ c'est une évidence
mais je tiens à le redire c'est-à-dire
qu'au moment de l'instruction bien sûr
que le récit sera détaillé bien sûr
qu'il pourra ajouter tout élément
nouveaux qu'il souhaiterait par exemple
parce qu'il aura été entre-temps
accompagné donc j'ai du mal à comprendre
comment vous justifiez votre rejet de
cette disposition il y a des craintes
parmi les agents de l'ofpr j'ai bien
compris enfin ces craintes je vais vous
dire aujourd'hui dans les sites qui
seront les sites pilotes demain c'est
bien parce que ce sont les sites les
préfectures qui permettent aujourd'hui
sur le plan capacitaire d'installer des
locaux indépendants pour l'ofprar et
donc la mise en application dans les
futures préfectures au-delà de ces sites
pilotes qui seront tout de suite
investis par cette réforme si nous la
votons il faudra des aménagements
capacitaires très forts et coûteux mais
très fort pour que
l'OFPRA se voir garanti y compris son
indépendance physique j'allais dire
entire donc c'est une mesure à la fois
de simplification et c'est aussi une
mesure de protection très forte alors je
VO ses amendements de suppression qui
Vêtre pour contre
comment je vous ai pas vu monsieur je
vous a pas inscrit j'ai j'ai répondu à
ta place donc ils sont rejetés le 15507
madame jeunevard alors pas
défendu monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable je mets au voix qui vote
pour contre
rejeté faut voter il que six personnes
qui ont
voté le suivant le 434 madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président alors
si on veut lutter contre l'immigration
il faut peut-être commencer par arrêter
de créer de nouveaux organisme de
recours à un moment donné à force de
créer ce type d'organisme on ne fait
qu'exploser le contentieux des étrangers
je vais vous donner quelques chiffres en
2019 le contentieux des étrangers
représentait 20 % de l'ensemble des
affaires enregistrées au Conseil d'État
contre 13 % en 2014 il représentait plus
de 41 % du contentieux total des
tribunaux administratifs en 2021 et 54 %
pour les cours administratives d'appel
et pour la CNDA c'était 25000 affaires
en 2009 contre 59000 en 2019 donc nous
nous considérons qu'il faut que vous
arrêtiez d'essayer de traiter les
conséquences de votre politique en
multipliant les expérimentations et en
multipliant les recours et nous vous
demandons de traiter le problème à la
cause c'est-à-dire comme le propose le
rassemblement national en faisant
procéder aux demandes d'asile depuis les
autorités consulaires du pays d'origine
du demandeur monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable je mets au voix qui vote
pour contre
rejeté discussion commune monsieur le
rapporteur de
1411 cet amendement vise à à revenir à
la version initiale de l'article 19 pour
ce qui concerne le déploiement sans
expér entation des pôles territoriaux
franceasil étant donné que
l'expérimentation avait été ajoutée au
Sénat comme on le le le monsieur le
rapporteur général l'a dit il y aura
trois sites pilotes qui ont été annoncés
Sergi Toulouse et mes et ça se fera au
fur et à mesure du temps donc le côté
site pilote permettra de démontrer que
ça fonctionne et l'expérimentation
renverrait à un cadre temporaire qui
nous permettrait d'une part de pas
garantir le recrutement des agents de ne
pas garantir le fait qu'ils puissent se
déployer sur les territoires et ne pas
garantir la mise en place des
différentes procédures j'été pour ma
part très convaincu par les
représentants du ministre que nous avons
auditionné qui ont expliqué du ministère
pardon qui ont expliqué clairement
comment était envisagé le déploiement de
ces guichers uniques pareil avec les
échanges avec le directeur général de
l'OFPRA et avec ce délai de 4 ans
d'expérimentation nous ralentissons les
choses alors qu'il s'agit d'une réforme
qui facilite et accélère l'introduction
de la demande d'asile je rappelle que le
fait d'être au plus près sur les
territoires sur les 33 Gudas qui
existent permet de mieux accompagner les
ressortissants permet de mieux les
prendre en charge et d'avoir une
procédure beaucoup plus rapide pour eux
et pas simplement pour nous on parle
d'être humains qui parfois attendre
beaucoup trop longtemps pour se voir vu
à Montreuil par des agents de le frra
donc voici pourquoi on revient à
l'article initial proposé par le
gouvernement monsieur banan vre
amendement
c'est quasi le même amendement il y a
des petits détails des petites
différence mais sur le fond de de de
cette
réorganisation moi je comprends pas les
un certain nombre de de réticence de de
gens qui n'arrêtent pas de nous dire
qu'il sont tout le temps à aller
accompagner les personnes qui demande de
l'asile moi je l'ai fait aussi c'est
c'est extrêmement compliqué aujourd'hui
c'est c'est on a l'impression parfois
d'être dans vous savez cet épisode
d'Astérix et Obélix où ils arrêtent pas
de passer d'une administration à l'autre
enfin c'est quelque chose de
complètement délirant je crois que c'est
dans les grands travaux les 12 travaux
pardon donc là on a une mesure qui s
simplifie qui améliore je je comprends
vraiment pas les oppositions alors entre
les deux versions monsieur le rapporteur
je je vais faire preuve de de je vais
vous faire confiance parce que un
rapporteur il connaît parfois un peu
mieux les sujets que un modeste député
que je suis et je vais retirer mon
retirer mon amendement au au au profit
du vôtre merci Madame
Dupont merci monsieur le Président alors
moi aussi je je suis enfin je trouve
intéressant d'avoir cette proximité et
de de l'organiser néanmoins en tant que
rapporteur spécial j'ai eu moi aussi à
auditionner différents acteurs sur la
mise en place de de France asile et et
je reste interrogative aujourd'hui et je
suis plutôt favorable à ce qu'on
expérimente plutôt qu'à ce qu'on déploie
directement parce que je n'ai pas s'il
vous plaît je j'ai pas on na pas
l'impact du coup de la mesure euh
précisément et c'est vrai que c'est une
révolution administrative qui est
proposée j'y vois un intérêt comme je
vous le dis mais c'est quand même une
révolution administrative d'avoir ainsi
deux agents seuls détachés de l'OFPRA
dans tous les
Gudas quelle sera l'autorité
hiérarchique fonctionnelle de ces deux
agents qui seront un peu perdus quand
même au milieu du des départements
français euh donc je je je suis encore
il sur le coût sur l'efficacité sur les
modalités de gestion et d'organisation
de ce service monsieur
porte j'ai juste une petite question
pour le pour pour monsieur le rapporteur
spécial vous avez été convaincu par les
représentants du ministre ou du
ministère par le ministère monsieur je
me suis rattrapé tout de suite quand ma
langue a fourché et si je peux rassurer
madame Dupon ils seront toujours sous
l'autorité et seulement sous l'autorité
du DG de l'
bon je les mets au voix l'amendement du
rapporteur qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté il
fait tomber le le 781 de madame Martin
le 1028 monsieur Luca merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement est proposé par
le Comité contre l'esclavage moderne et
vise à obliger obliger pardon les agents
de Lofi qui évaluent la vulnérabilité
des demandeur à avoir reçu une formation
obligatoire et actualisée sur le cadre
légal de lutte contre la traite des
êtres humains à des fins d'exploitation
par le travail et sur l'identification
des victimes c'est cet amendement et la
traduction des observations faite par la
CNC DH et par le
GRETA monsieur rapporteur
défavorable me voix qui vote pour qui
vot contre rejeté le 847 madame Martin
très bien donc vous avez compris que
nous discutons le cadre global tel qui
va être mis en place au travers de cette
affaire de
france-asile maintenant nous nous en
quelque sorte dans une logique un peu de
repli nous demandons puisque cela fait
partie de nos inquiétudes l'indépendance
des agents de l'OFPRA l'effet que cela
fera lorsque les personnes rentreront
dans la préfecture alors on nous dit ils
auront des locaux indépendants va
falloir nous indiquer dans le projet de
loi de finance où sont les 10 12
millions d'euros que vont demander
l'installation de cette de ces bureaux
décentralisés de de franceasile hein
vous comprenez on descend un peu dans on
descend un peu dans les étages là nous
en sommes au moment où sans adhérer à la
logique globale de franceasile nous
demandons par l'inscription de cet
amendement des garanties pour la qualité
de l'instruction de la demande et la
qualité du récit parce que c'est ça qui
est central c'est la question du récit
donc on fait une liste de de nécessaires
personnes et compétences qui doivent
accompagner le demandeur d'asile
monsieur le rapporteur bra ils aiment
pas les histoires
non
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour cont j'ai répondu il est rejeté
madame yadan le
1369 oui je vous je vous remercie
monsieur le le président lorsqu'on est
allé visiter un CR
euh il y a quelques semaines de ça nous
avons été interpellés en tout cas en ce
qui me concerne par le fait qu'il y
avait des il y avait un un une liste en
fait qui était qui avait été communiqué
au service du CR service administrative
du CRRA et sur cette liste était
répertorié à peu près une dizaine de
personnes fichs donc des
personnes des personnes qui étaient qui
qui qui faisaient l'objet de de de de
recherche pour prévenir des des menaces
graves pour la sécurité publique ou ou
la ou la sûreté de l'État et ces
personnes-là au bout de 90 jours et bien
audelat de de 90 jours était était libre
donc cet amendement vise en tout cas à
réfléchir sur l'après est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas envisager pour ces
personnes-là sans sans préjuger
évidemment d'une mesure judiciaire mais
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas réfléchir à
aller au-delà de la période de
jour le éloignement demeure une
perspective raisonnable monsieur le
monsieur le rapporteur ah
bon désolé madame yadan mais vous vous
êtes trompé je crois dans l'explication
de votre amendement et sinon
l'amendement dont on discute j'y suis
favorable alors je sais pas oui je me
suis trompée d'amendement parce que je
pas mon fichier alors non alors l'autre
amendement pardon donc le 16 d'accord
donc vous y êtes favor très bien bon je
du coup il y a les autres aussi qui sont
exactement mê je les mets au voix qui
votre pour qui vre contre ilour il est
adopté il fait tomber le 960 et le
978 le
170 monsieur
camardine attendez le 169
pardon les deux si vous les prter en
commune
défendu le temps que je le
retrouve oui merci monsieur le Président
cet
amendement cet amendement a pour but de
lutter contre le maintien illégal des
clandestins dégoutter du droit d'asile
je peux c'est des sujets que je connais
je
pense comme beaucoup d'autres donc
l'idée c'est de dire toutes les
personnes qui une fois leur demande
définitivement rejeté ne puissent plus
se maintenir sur le territoire national
vous voulez défendre le 170 également à
la
suite9 c'est le c'est oui également pour
celui-ci il s'agit de lutter également
contre le maintien illégal des
clandestins débouté du droit d'asile euh
considérant qu'elle sera toujours
préférable d'étudier les demandes
d'asile depuis l'étranger euh plutôt que
depuis le euh son sol national prenons
l'exemple de quelqu'un qui se trouve à
Madagascar ou qui vient des grand lacs
qui atterrit à Moroni comme c'est le cas
souvent ou à
Antananarivo et qui cherche à aller en
Fance c'est singulièrement dans le
département de Mayotte au titre de
l'asile et bien nous lui proposons à ce
qu'il puisse déposer sa sa demande
auprès des services consulaires euh
français soit an Tananarivo s'il est à
Madagascar soit soit
à soit à Moroni ce qui nous permettrait
une fois l'instruction défavorabl rendu
et les décisions définitives
définitivement rendu de ne pas pouvoir
revenir ici avec toutes les difficultés
que cela pose après pour le reconduire
vers son pays d'origine monsieur le
rapporteur vos deux avis s'il vous
plaît euh ça sera défavorable sur les
les deux amendements alors premè parce
que l'expérimentation la demande d'asile
depuis son pays d'origine auprès d'un
Pôle International franceasile donc
c'est ce que vous voulez intégrer euh
vous citez dans votre exposé d'ailleurs
sommaire l'exemple du Royaume-Uni dont
je rappelle que l'ONU a dénoncé la loi
adoptée en 2023 considérant que le
royaumeunievenait au droit international
en matière d'accueil des réfugiés donc
on ne pourra pas r déjà pour cette
première raison accepter ou vous
demander un retrait pour une réécriture
ensuite vous allez beaucoup plus loin
puisque vous prévoyez que l'entretien
personnel puisse avoir lieu directement
dans ce Pôle international sans aucune
garantie notamment de délai de
préparation pour le demandeur et là on
sera en difficulté il faut un certain
temps quand même pour avoir la
possibilité de raconter son récit son
parcours son histoire et pourquoi on
demande l'asile dans l'autre pays donc
en l'état ça ça ça paraît créer des
conditions dégradées d'examen de la
demande d'asile et c'est pour cela qu'on
est totalement défavorable j'aurais aimé
vous dire on peut le retravailler mais
en l'état vu ce qui est proposé c'est
impossible monsieur Dumont merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur déjà le la question de la loi
anglaise c'était plutôt pour la question
du Rwanda et d'envoyer les déboutés du
droit d'asile au Rwanda donc c'est pas
la même chose puceque là on est sur le
dépôt de la demande d'asile la réalité
de ces amendements c'est aussi la
question de l'anticipation de la loi du
règlement asile immigration qui sera
voté au niveau du du Parlement européen
est- qui va être mis en place il est
prévu normalement dans cette décision
européenne et cette négociation au
niveau européen que un maximum de dépôt
de demande d'asile se fasse aux
frontières de l'Europe et donc dans
l'inscription future de ce qui est en
train d'être négocié qui sera très
probablement adopté puisque c'est le
sens des décisions qui ont été prises
par les différents États-membres il est
absolument nécessaire de pouvoir
imaginer cette
internationalisation afin de pouvoir par
exemple comme ça existe déjà dans les
îles grecques
àesbos par exemple dans les camps qui
sont créés pour mettre à l'abri sous le
regard de l'OIM sous le regard des
différents pays membres de l'Union
européenne les demandeurs d'asile
pouvoir déployer dans ces endroits c'est
ce qui va être créé et c'est au
contraire dans un sens qui permettra de
pouvoir mieux gérer au niveau européen
et donc au niveau français et de mieux
renvoyer ceux qui sont dégoutés ce qui
viendront pas mais on est au cœur du
sujet la question c'est de savoir dans
quelles conditions on va pouvoir
permettre à des demandeur d'asile de
voir leur demandes instru dans les
meilleures conditions possibles on a
déjà compris qu'au travers de la
régionalisation on va dire comme ça il y
avait pas de garantie pour que il y ait
des associations qui dès le début avant
même la production sommaire du récit
puisse dire le droit c'est ça qui nous
préoccupe donc là on nous a dit allez
vous rhabiller non pas de garantie dans
la loi et lorsque on vous entend alors
évidemment nous on n'est pas forcément
d'accord avec ça mais vous ce que vous
cherchez aussi à déterminer c'est quelle
va être la procédure qui va permettre la
plus la plus facile la plus aisé pour
selon votre point de vue j'ai pas de
difficulté avec ça qui va permettre
effectivement de faire valoir de la
meilleure manière possible le demandeur
d'asile de sa demande d'asile donc on en
est là donc c'est ça dont il faut qu'on
discute quelles sont les bonnes
conditions à réunir et si c'est France
Terre d'Asile quelles sont les bonnes
conditions à réunir pour France Terre
d'Asile pardon oui France asile oh le
lapsus malheureusement il marche pas là
mais il faudra nous dire où vous trouvez
les 10 12 millions pour payer tout ça
quand même he monsieur le rapporteur
général pour dire où on trouve
l'argent mais d'abord les vous parlez
quels sont les les garanties que
l'instruction l'instruction de la
demande d'asile se fera dans nos bonnes
conditions mais parce que l'instruction
à proprement parler de la demande
d'asile se fera dans les conditions
d'aujourd'hui à l'OFPRA ici en région
parisienne nous parlons de
l'introduction nous parlons de
l'introduction et donc au moment
aujourd'hui il y a les guichets uniques
il y en a 33 de mémoire au niveau
national bien c'est pas à peu près c'est
c'est c'est comme ça il il y a les Gudas
les Gudas permettent de débloquer donc
c'est y compris les conditions
matérielles de séjour les conditions
matérielles au même moment et dans les
mêmes bâtiments mais pas les mêmes
locaux ils seront séparés il y aura la
possibilité de faire la première
introduction pas l'instruction
l'introduction mais il n'y a pas besoin
d'avocat pour demander à la personne
quelle est votre langue mais non la
garantie elle intervient au niveau de
instruction et vous dites ensuite quelle
quelle conditions physique j'allais dire
dans dans la lopmque vous n'avez pas
voté madame Martin dans la lopiteque N
pas vous n'avez pas voté nous avons voté
en revanche la trajectoire budgettaire
mais parce que c'est un beau texte la
lopmie enfin
voyons dans dans la lopmie dans la
lopmie nous avons voté les moyens pour
la déconcentration de l'OFPRA sur
l'année par
exemple sur les espaces franille
franille service pardon pour
2024z jamais AR là j'allais dire quelque
chose mais je vais pas le faire sur 2024
sur 2024 on serait madame Martin sur
2024 on serait madame Martin à 5,3
million d'euros pour les enjeux
capacitaire notamment sur les sites
expérimentaux pour 2025 nous serions à
12 8 million d'euros 2026 18,5 million
d'euros 2027 19,4 million d'euros pour
doter l'ensemble de ces locaux
spécifiques offpra et je je répète sous
l'autorité hiérarchique du directeur
général de l'OFPRA vous dites mais la
distance mais la distance on n'est pas
non plus à l'air des charrettes à bras
pardon mais donc il y aura effectivement
une autorité hiérarchique sur les ETP
qui serait créé nous sommes autour de
100 à 170 ETP créé spécifiquement pour
cette capacité d'accueil de proximité au
moment de l'introduction vous voyez que
c'est quand même à la fois un dispositif
protecteur je l'aià dit dans la dans la
procédure et puis l'État met les moyens
très clairement sur la durée il va
s'engager à la fois sur les emplois et
sur le capacitaire non franchement je
crois que sur ces éléments nous avons
des garanties très forte je dois dire
qu'en tant que rapporteur il me revenait
aussi de les demander d'avoir ses
précisions et je les ai obtenu sans
aucune difficulté bien on a déjà eu la
discussion madame Tor je mets au voix
l'amendement de Monsieur po le 169 qui
vote pour contre rejeté même vot pour le
170 le 1127 n'est pas défendu le 1124
n'est pas défendu le 276 monsieur
gilet
oui monsieur le Président avec près de
131000 demandes d'asile en 2022 la
France et le deuxème principal pays
d'accueil la demande d'asile n'a jamais
été aussi forte qu'aujourd'hui on le
sait aujourd'hui le droit d'asile est
dévoyé c'est une réalité et les
premières victimes d'ailleurs sont ceux
qui peuvent vraiment prétendre à la
demande d'asile Didier leschi directeur
général de l'OFI a confirmé que la
France est l'un des pays les moins
sévère dans l'examen des situations de
demande d'asile souvent débouté dans
d'autres pays européens comme
l'Allemagne la Suède l'Autriche ou le
Danemarc les demandeurs obtiennent en
France plus facilement le statut de
réfugié pour autant nombreux étrangers
tardent à demander l'asile en arrivant
sur notre territoire aussi cet
amendement propose de réduire le délai
dans lequel le demandeur d'asile doit
déposer effectivement sa demande en le
limitant donc à 15
jours alors monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable madame
mer merci monsieur le Président juste un
instant pour rappeler cette phrase euh
de Jordan Bardella qui nous explique que
les femmes afghanes ne sont pas une
plus-value pour la France et qui donc
s'il avait été au pouvoir n'urait pas
accueilli de FEM afghan je voulais juste
rappeler ça à nos collègues du
rassemblement national leur dire qu'il
faut qu'ils arrêtent maintenant
d'essayer de nous laisser croire qu'il
défendre les droits des femmes ne plus
jamais nous dire qu'il défendent les
droits des femmes et surtout ne plus la
ramener un petit peu moins sur le droit
d'asile
madame non non non on on on naapplaudit
pas en commission des lois de façon
générale pour quiconque
on non
[Musique]
j'ai
moi et ben allez allez j'attends un peu
le silence
he moi je voudrais demander au
rassemblement national d'où sort ce
chiffre 15 jours
pourquoi 15
jours pourquoi pas 12 pourquoi pas 7
pourquoi pas
1 sur quoi vous vous basez sur quoi vous
vous basez est-ce que vous connaissez la
situation des gens qui arrivent en
France et quelle est quel est la
situation dans laquelle il se trouvve
avant de demander leur demande d'asile
vous avez aucune connaissance de ça vous
êtes simplement obsédé sur le fait qu'il
faut dès qu'ils ont mis le pied en
France il faut qu'il dégage le plus vite
c'est vrai voilà c'est ça votre
obsession parce que dans les étrangers
attention pas tous les étrangers on l'a
vu précédemment uniquement ceux qui sont
hors de l'Europe bien sûr parce que les
autres les Européens on peut les
accepter les blancs mais ceux qui sont
un peu plus bronzés la seule chose qu'il
faut c'est les faire dégager le plus
vite parce que ce sont tous des
criminels en en germe sont tous des
délinquants voilà votre vision monsieur
gilet après
vote
oui alors je crois qu' quand on entend
pardon de pareiles ananneries il y a de
quoi il y a de quoi alluciner madame
Miller déjà je comprends qu'on puisse
pas partager les mêmes idées je
comprends même que vous puissiez ne pas
croire ce que sont les sondages sur la
vie des Français sur l'immigration mais
c'est une réalité mais vous inquiétez
pas les Français vont les Français vont
vous rappeler la réalité de leur penser
le 9 juin prochain ensuite ensuite
sur sur pourquoi 15 jour pourquoi 15un
jour parce que on n pas été nombreux ici
à participer aux auditions relatif à ce
texte mais nous nous y avons participé
et nous avons en plus de ça rencontré un
certain nombre de professionnels et tous
unanimement estiment que ce délai est
trop long et que 15 jours suffisent oui
madame nous nous écoutons les les
professionnels du secteur qui sont les
premiers à pouvoir dire ce qui serait
bon pour la France qui serait bon pour
notre pays tout en étant acceptable pour
le demandur d'asile l'amendement de
Monsieur gilet qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté le suivant monsieur Lucas
défendu monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable je au voix qui vote pour qui
vote contre rejeté l'amendement 247 qui
le défend alors merci monsieur le
Président alors que les demandeurs
d'asile sont déjà en situation de grande
vulnérabilité lors de leur arrivée en
France les demandeurs d'asile transgenre
et intersexe le sont d'autant plus
souvent originaires de pays où les
personnes lgbtqia plus sont persécutées
et où et où il leur est impossible
d'exprimer leur identité de genre ils
ont besoin d'une procédure adaptée c'est
pourquoi nous demandons de prévoir de
permettre l'enregistrement de la demande
avec la mention de sexe correspondant à
l'identité de genre ainsi que le cas
échéant l'enregistrement de prénom
correspondant à cette identité de plus
cet amendement propose de permettre la
modification de la dite mention relative
au sexe par le biais d'une déclaration
de la personne ayant demandé la
protection internationale dans les 21
jours qui suivent l'enregistrement de la
dite demande alors qu'aujourd'hui la
déclaration de l'identité de genre se
fait sur la base de la perception des
agents de l'OFPRA c'est notre c'est la
responsabilité de la France et nous en
sortirions grandi monsieur le
rapporteur alors chers collègue Rousseau
j'aurais pu être d'accord avec vous
j'aurais pu je comprends d'ailleurs très
bien l'esprit de l'amendement d'ailleurs
si on regarde même sur l'état civil
aujourd'hui en général ça marche pas non
plus comme ça dans l'effet c'est que
l'un des rôles de l'OFPRA lors de
l'introduction de la demande est
d'établir l'état civil du demandeur si
cette première étape crée une distorsion
entre l'état civil de naissance et celui
qui figure dans le dossier on aurait un
gros problème dans l'instruction du
dossier par contre ça créerait une forme
de complexité par contre rien n'empêche
une fois obtenu l'asile de faire changer
son état civil alors je peux comprendre
que ça ne vous convienne pas mais en
l'état ça poserait des véritables
problèmes sur la procédure euh
d'introduction et d'analyse de de
l'asile donc défavorable au
retrait Martin non mais ce qui est ce
qui est soulevé ici c'est l'attention et
le soin qu'il faut porter à la fois au
demandeurs bien sûr d'asile mais à la
procédure qu'ils doivent suivre donc là
Sandrine Rousseau a levé un problème je
m'autorise tant que j'y suis à enlever
évidemment ça n'est pas le premier al à
enlever un autre la présence des
interprètes
le refus de tout ce qui sera de l'ordre
de la de la vidéo de la vidéo à distance
là pour pour faire les entretiens donc
je redis que dans ce projet de loi
particulièrement s'il est adopté les
garanties ne seront pas réunies au-delà
de la territorialisation qu'après tout
on pourrait accepter si toutes les
garanties sont réunies en voilà une
supplémentaire qui
sou oui les personnes qui fuient leur
pays qui en raison de cette
discrimination spécifiquement et
notamment pour les personnes
transgenre sont souvent des personnes
qui ont eu des parcours extrêmement
difficiles donc en fait arriver en
France sous l'identité de genre initiale
peut vraiment être compliqué pour elle
donc en fait ça serait une mesure
d'accueil nous permettant de de
valoriser les valeurs de la France et de
les mettre en avant à l'étranger ça
serait vraiment
important je suis d'accord avec vous sur
ce ce fondement là mais la réalité c'est
qu'on a besoin de l'état civil du pays
de naissance pour créer le dossier donc
en l'état on ne peut pas faire autrement
et on peut y réfléchir peut-être pour
une suite pour pour changer les les les
les documents mais la rérité c'est qu'en
l'état on ne peut pas le faire on a
besoin de ça je comprends ce que vous
dites parce qu'en 2018 nous avons changé
la loi justement pour protéger les
personnes transgenre ou alors homosexuel
qui étaient maltraités ou parfois eux
même chassés ou comment dire mise en
prison et voir même certains perdaient
leur vie pour ces raisonslà et donc donc
c'est nous qui l'avons intégré dans la
loi de 2018 ça prouve bien que on
cherchait à les protéger sauf que en
état l'état civil on a besoin de l'état
civil d'origine du pays d'origine pour
ouvrir la procédure si il arrive avec un
document à marqué monsieur et qu'il
demande l'ouverture au nom de Madame ça
ne fonctionnera pas ça c'est aussi pour
les protéger et rien n'empêche dans la
dans la suite une fois qu'ils sont
reconnus réfugiés et qu'ils ont obtenu
l'asile de pouvoir changer cet état
civil où là ils pouront vivre comme ils
le veulent sans pouvoir être
persécuté donc donc on met on vote le
247 qui vote pour qui vote contre il est
rejeté le 945 monsieur vot madame oui ça
sera moi merci cet amendement vise à
intégrer une obligation de formation
pour les agents de l'OFI et de l'OFP
l'OFPRA je y arrivver une formation sur
la sur la traite des êtres humains
notamment et à des fins d'exploitation
par le travail pourquoi parce que la
Commission nationale consultative des
droit humain a souligné le caractère
insuffisant des mesures prises par la
France en matière d'information de
sensibilisation et de formation des
professionnels à ce sujet le sujet donc
de la traite des êtres humains mais
aussi le sujet des violences spécifiques
faites aux femmes migrantes et aux
infractions qui y sont liées donc nous
demandons la formation de tous ces
personnels monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable monsieur
banan juste je je voulais à ce stade là
avant avant la pause répondre à à Madame
Diaz et au rassemblement national qui
depuis mais non mais mais
sérieusementà qui depuis le début de nos
nos nos débats euh nous nous envoient à
la figure un certain nombre de sondages
mais il y a les sondage oui
effectivement mais il y a surtout les
études et il y a des études très
sérieuses je vais en citer deux il y a
une étude du Centre d'études prospectiv
et d'information internationale qui
démontre que le il n'y a pas plus de
délinquants étrangers que de délinquants
tout court euh première première étude
ensuite on a l'étude d'un d'un chercheur
euh d'un chercheur sur un un indice de
confiance un indice de confiance qui
existe depuis les années 80 sur 48 98
séries de de question et et 106 points
de de données qui qui font un certain
nombre de compilations d'études et ce ce
ce chiffre là montre que l'indice de
confiance des Français vis-à-vis de
l'étranger n'a jamais été aussi fort
qu'aujourd'hui donc moi je veux bien les
sondagesondage la réalité il y a des
donc on vote sur l'amendement de
Monsieur Solignac qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté madame tunal 970 merci
alors nous nous voudrions rajouter à
cette à cet article 19 après l'alinéa
11 la phrase
suivante pr donc notifie au réquérent
l'ordonnance dans sa langue d'origine ou
dans une langue que le réquérent est en
capacité de lire parce que nous
avons rencontré des des des personnes
voilà qui ont vécu ce parcours et qui
nous ont expliquer leurs difficultés à
comprendre ce de ce sur quoi ils étaient
enfin à comprendre leur dossier donc euh
fournir les les les documents en quatre
ou CIN langues je sais plus comment on
l'ppelle appelle ces langues ça porte un
nom les les
langues bon bref euh c'est pas suffisant
donc il faut vraiment faire en sorte que
ça soit ou dans la langue de natale
maternelle ou dans une langue que le
récérang peut comprendre parce que sinon
ça sert à rien et je veux non c'est
terminé c'est terminé le rapporteur et
ben tout à l'heure défavorable Mad
Martin bien voilà à nouveau un problème
qui est soulevé par la
territorialisation mais si attends
attendez laissez-moi juste vous
expliquer euh à partir de à partir de là
ça signifie qu'il faut qu'on ait à
disposition des interprètes en nombre
pour qu'ils puissent dans les fameux
pôles territoriaux accompagner les
demandeurs d'asile donc vous allez me
dire mais non il y a la question des
vidéosurveillance des vidéos audience
excusez-moi moi moi aussi je commence à
être fatigué sauf que nous on n'est pas
d'accord on n'est pas d'accord pourquoi
pas seulement parce que ça fait joli
mais parce que le recueil du récit
encore une fois est quelque chose de
subtil qui qui ne peut pas s'embarrasser
de de ces écran qui vont venir faire
intermédiaire donc parmi les questions
que nous posons dans les conditions de
ces fameux pôles territoriaux c'est
qu'il faut qu'il y ait le nombre
d'interprètes suff dans les langues
suffisantes et c'est là où à mon avis à
notre avis ça devient compliqué je le
mets au voix qui vote pour qui vote
contre
rejeté le suivant un amendement de
Madame Toral
981esend défendu monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable défavorable m VO
qui vot pour contre rejeté 134 et
identique monsieur
camardine non je le prends je le prends
madame jeev tu veux bien
oui merci monsieur le Président bon à ce
stade du débat on va bientôt terminer
les amendements sur sur l'asile j'aurais
rappelé quand même quelques chiffres en
France 131000 demandes d'asile en 2022
dont 43 % seulement si j'ose dire sont
reconnus ça veut dire que par l'ofpras
ça veut dire qu'il y a 57 % de ces
demandes qui ne sont pas légitimes et
c'est une des raisons qui motive la
position des républicains de
l'instruction de l'asile aux frontières
du
pays comme cela a été dit c'est
d'ailleurs l'objet d'un des articles de
la réforme constitutionnelle que nous
voulons faire alors dans cet amendement
de Monsieur
pojet il il demande que la demande
d'asile déposée en France par un
étranger définitivement condamné à une
peine de prison ferme par la justice
française emporte une décision
d'irrecevabilité écrite et motivée par
le fi l'amendement de repli suivant en
plantation de commune madame jeun
défendu monsieur le rapporteur donc
défavorable sur les deux
amendements je le mets au voix le 134
qui vote pour qui vote contre rejeté le
163 pour contre rejeté l'article 19 qui
vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté après
l'article 19 Madame
Dupont oui pardon excusez-moi monsieur
le Président alors cet amendement vise à
assurer une répartition territoriale
géographique équilibrée des directions
territoriales de l'OFI l'Office français
de l'immigration et de l'intégration sur
l'ensemble du territoire puisque
aujourd'hui on constate que l'OFI repose
sur 31 directions territoriales dont la
répartition géographique n'est pas
satisfaisante c'est en tant que
rapporteur spécial que j'ai pu aussi me
pencher sur ce sujet en Île-de-France
par exemple les départements de lesson
et des ivelines sont dépourvu de
direction territoriale pourant
l'activité est forte en Occitanie grande
région deux directions territoriales
interviennent sur 13 départements donc
il me semble qu'on pourrait renforcer la
loi de façon à ce que on renforce ainsi
cette organisation territoriale et ce
mariage territorial en parallèle de
celui de
franceassieur le rapporteur défavorable
je me VO qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejet les ement discussion commune qui
est présente au rassemblement national
monsieur gilet il y en a trois dans la
discussions commune 105 440
441 allez-y
oui monsieur le Président alors le
premier amendement de de mon collègue
thbaau François et bien permet en fait
de de limiter finalement le dévoiement
du droit d'asile mais aussi de protéger
les Français en cela qui prévoit la
suppression du dépôt des demandes
d'asile sur le sol métropolitain ou
ultramarin le traitement des demandes
d'asile uniquement auprès des réseaux
consulaires français ou des sections
consulaires des ambassades françaises à
l'étranger permettrait d'aller en ce
sens sur l'amendement 440 en 2022 ont
été dénombrés pas moins de 330000
franchissements irréguliers des
frontières extérieures soit une hausse
de 64 % par rapport à 2021 devenu de
véritabl passoir nos frontières sont
prises d'assaut par une pression
migratoire inédite qui ne cesse de
s'intensifier cette intensification
massive trouve une de ses conséquences
dans le détournement du droit d' alors
qu'en 2012 les demandes n'étaient que de
61000 elles sont passées à 156000 en
2022 et selon les estimations devrai
atteindre 200000 d'ici 2024 ce que nous
remettons en cause ce n'est pas le droit
d'asile he mais son dévoiement dans cet
objectif de mettre fin au dévoiement de
la politique du droit d'asile le présent
amendement a pour objectif d'inscrire
comme cause de fin de statut de réfugié
le fait que le réfugié soit retourné
dans son pays d'origine effectivement on
le voit et on l'a tous constaté je pense
Sion si on est aller rencontrer les les
professionnels en la
matière régulièrement et je l'ai vu
d'ailleurs en Guyane lors de mon
déplacement dans le cadre de mon rapport
des demandeurs d'asile retournent
ensuite dans leur pays d'origine pour
les fêtes de fin d'année ou pour la fête
nationale pour revenir ensuite sur le
territoire français ce qui montre bien
qu'ils ne sont pas en danger dans leur
pays d'origine et que le droit d'asile
est là et bien dévoyer pardon monsieur
le rapporteur alors parce qu'il y a il y
a deux réponses à faire défavorable sur
les trois bien
entendu deux éléments ce que vous
proposez impliquerait une très for de
modification de l'organisation des
services consulaires et des moyens
supplémentaires très importants donc ça
c'est sur le cl15 ça mettra mal le rôle
de l'OFPRA dont je rappelle l'IND
dépendance vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des
ministères de l'ensemble des ministères
et et cette indépendance répond à nos
engagements internationaux en matière
d'asile et le système que nous proposons
aujourd'hui est le plus équilibré le
plus adéquate qui qui puisse fonctionner
concernant la la les deux derniers
amendements dans les faet lepra indique
clairement que les réfugiés ne sont pas
autorisés à retourner dans leur pays
sauf dans certains cas des cés
impérieuses dans lesqueles un SAU
conduit obtenu auprès de la préfecture
de votre lieu de résidence est
nécessaire ce qui fait que si jamais
le ressortissant étranger à qui on a
donné l'asile ne respecte pas ses
obligations logiquement il peut perdre
son droit donc on n pas besoin de le
rédiger de cette façon dans la loi
est-ce que vous proposez aujourd'hui lui
ne fonctionne pas une partie pourrait vu
comme inconstitutionnel l'autre partie
non réglementaire et en l'état vous
changer tout un système qui est bien
pensé qui qui marche et que nous sommes
en train d'améliorer avec l'article 19
donc
défavorable monsieur le rapporteur
général un complément de d'information
vous avez raté mon cher collègue
l'article 12 bis ah d'ailleurs je ne
sais pas si vous l'avez voté mais nous
répondons précisément à cette situation
du retrait du statut du réfugié lorsque
la personne
a indiqué que ces liens étaient coupés
avec le son pays d'origine parce qu'elle
était persécutée discriminé et puis on
constate qu'elle y part en vacances cela
a été dit par le ministre à plusieurs
reprises et donc nous prévoyons une
disposition qui répond exactement à
cette situation et puis je termine sur
la question du droit d'asile vous dites
nous nous sommes pas contre le droit
d'asile mais si à partir du moment où
vous ne voulez plus qu'il soit demandé
sur le territoire national alors vous
êtes tout à fait contraire à l'esprit
même du droit d'asile d'ailleurs pour le
pacte as l'immigration je je le dis il
il a fallu que les États-membres
s'engagent et s'accordent à créer une
fiction juridique qui fait que aux
frontières de l'Union européenne quand
les ressortissants viennent sur le
territoire de l'Union européenne on
invente une fiction juridique pour dire
en fait non ils ont pas ils sont pas
rentrés en Europe bon mais l'obligation
vous la connaissez c'est que les États
de l'Union européenne se sont tous
engagés à l'obligation d'enregistrement
de chaque personne ce qui n'était pas le
cas aujourd'hui notamment pour l'Italie
et la Grèce qui sont les principaux pays
de Primo arrivant donc en considérant
qu'il faudrait faire systématiquement la
demande d'asile en dehors du territoire
national vous êtes contre le droit
d'asile dem de parole madame torignia
monsieur Dumont monsieur
gilet alors le rassemblement national
est contre le droit d'asile ça dépend
pour qui peut-être pas pour les
Ukrainiens mais pour les Syriens oui
c'est sûr et on a on en a déjà discuté
il y a a quelques jours je sais plus
quand mais quand vous demandez que les
demandes d'asile soit déposé dans les
réseaux consulaires français ou auprès
des des ambassades vous ne comprenez
rien à ce que c'est que la demande
d'asile euh je prends l'exemple de de la
Syrie imaginez les les les les Syriens
qui demandent l'asile en France aller
essayer de déposer leur demandes dans
dans dans un consulat ù euh enfin c'est
c'est excusez-moi mais c'est
complètement absurde ce que vous
proposez ce que je voulais vous dire
tout à l'heure c'est que vous dites que
vous connaissez que vous vous avez
rencontré les personnels de l'ofpr mais
je vous signale qu'ils étaient en grève
justement ces derniers jours et pourquoi
pourquoi ils étaient en grève parce
qu'ils étaient contre le dispositif
franceasile alors si vous les avez
rencontrés on a peut-être pas rencontré
les
mêmes monsieur
dum oui merci monsieur le Président moi
j'ai je peux
parler bon merci monsieur le Président
j'ai j'ai entendu nos collègues du
rassemblement national demander le
l'examen des demandes d'asile à
l'extérieur de la
France bah écoutez moi je trouve ça
intéressant parce que du coup vous
arrivez vous êtes en train de valider ce
qui a été décidé par le Conseil qui est
le pacte asile migration au niveau
européen puisque il est incrit dans la
décision de conseil la proposition de
règlement sur les procédures d'asile
l'introduction de l'examen des
procédures obligatoires d'examin des
demandes d'asile aux frontières de
l'Europe donc on se retrouve dans une
situation où comme vous nous faites à
chaque fois référence à des élections
futures le 9 juin on est heureux
d'entendre aujourd'hui grâce à vous que
vous allez porter ce pacte au niveau
européen c'est encore un revirement
après l'Euro après le frxit mais on
n'est pas un revirement près avec le
rassemblement national sur le niveau
européen merci euh alors c'est vrai que
si j'étais taquin je rappellerai que les
seuls membres du PPE à à s'être pososé
étaient les membres des républicains je
suis pas TAAC monsieur gilet dire
difficile de de supposer dans la mesure
où où le pacte asile immigration n'a pas
encore été voté euh au Parlement
européen voilà donc euh vous pouvez pas
dire que il a été voté puisqu'il ne l'a
pas été sur le fait et bien de déposer
sa demande d'asile dans un autre pays si
je prends l'exemple de la Syrie
puisqu'il a été cité par par une
collègue pour venir en France il faut
d'abord passer par la Turquie et là en
Turquie vous pouvez et bien déposer
votre demande d'asile à l'ambassade
française d'ailleurs plusieurs pays ont
mis en place plusieurs plusieurs pays
ont mis en place le le le ce système là
le fait de déposer sa demande d'asile
dans un pays étranger cela existe
aujourd'hui cela montre bien que c'est
possible c'est pas une idée comme ça
sortie de nulle part c'est tout
simplement aussi une idée pour faire en
sorte de protéger ce droit d'asile parce
que si on veut le protéger et faire en
sorte et bien que puisse en bénéficier
ceux qui ont réellement besoin il faut
évidemment faire en sorte que ceux qui
tentent de le dévoyer et bien ne
puissent plus le faire dans
l'avenir monsieur rapporteur général
avant que nous votions oui je je
j'interviens quand même parce que vous
vous dites des choses qui n'existent pas
mon chers collègues il n'existe aucune
solution pour demander l'asile en France
dans un territoire étranger à la France
ça n'existe pas ce qui non ce qui est
tout à fait possible mais non ça
n'existe pas nulle part même pas en
Turquie même pas ailleurs ça n'existe
pas pourquoi parce que la demande
d'asile ne peut être fa ne peut être
faite que sur le territoire de la
République c'est le principe même bien
sûr aucune autre solution et dans les
organismes consulaires dans les
organismes consulaires il est possible
de délivrer un visa pour que la personne
se rende en France et fasse sa demande
d'asile voilà très précisément comment
les choses se passent aujourd'hui alors
l'amendement 105 qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté 440 même vote 441 même
vote
le le suivant 430 430être pas défendu
mais 1511 madame jeunevar oui merci
merci monsieur le Président donc cet
amendement vise à redonner à la
procédure
accélérée une une procédure qui soit
accélérée pour les demandes d'asile
provenant de pays sûr et nous
préconisons que la procédure soit
complètement distincte de la procédure
normale c'est-à-dire de demandeurs
d'asile qui viennent de pays non sûr et
qui ont un taux de protection probable
très élevé on en a parlé hier pour le
travail des demandeurs d'asile venant de
pays non sûr et auquel vous avez
souhaité pouvoir donner accès au travail
donc il faut impérativement rendre la
demande d'asile moins attractive aux
personnes qui ne sont pas réellement
menacé dans leur pays d'origine et c'est
l'objet de cet amendement je rappelle
les chiffres sur 131000 demandeurs
d'asile moins de la moitié sont bénéfici
de la protection au titre de de
l'asile monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable vous voulez
mettre systém enc les demandeurs d'asile
d'origine de pays dis
sûr non mais le fait que ça soit
systématique déjà ça pose un vrai
problème madame jeev ça parmet ça ça
paraît porter une atteint
disproportionnée à leur droit et
constituer une rupture d'égalité
flagrante avec les autres demandeurs
d'asile et vous parlez d'accélérer la
procédure la procédure est déjà
accélérée pour les ressortissants de
pays reconnu comme tiers sûr donc on
répond à votre attente mais en l'état on
ne peut pas les placer en rétention
administrative juste parce qu'ils
viennent d'un pays reconnu comme sûr et
malgré tout même quand on vient d'un
pays reconnu comme tiers sûr il est
possible c'est infime et ça n'existe
presque pas mais qu'on puisse obtenir
l'asile pour des raisons politiques pour
d'autres raisons pour certains
journalistes qui ont besoin de
protection et ça faut le prendre en
considération vous voyez vous nous voyez
demain placer par exemple un journaliste
ou un opposant politique d'un pays
reconnu comme tiers sû en l'état en
rétention administrative alors qu'il
vient nous demander la protection est-ce
qu'on aurait par exemple la Russie a
toujours été déclaré tir sûr
accepterions nous de placer un
journaliste ou un ou un un un politique
de l'opposition russe en centre de
rétention administrative la réponse je
crois que vous pouvez nous la donner
c'est non donc en l'état ça ça
s'appliquerait ça ferait la réalité
c'est que votre amendement ferait cela
donc défavorable monsieur porte puis
monsieur
Dumont merci monsieur le Président
effectivement le caractère systématique
de du placement est une atteinte
fondamentale au droit mais aller
jusqu'au bout de votre raisonnement
parce que c'est quand même je veux pas
vous faire de procès d'intention mais
c'est le troisème amendement que vous
déposez où écrit en gros en bas
s'applique au ressortissant algérien ce
qui est quand même un sujet moi je sais
pas quel problème vous avez avec les
ressortissants algériens mais cibler une
nationalité et une des concitoyens avec
une nationalité c'est absolument
problématique et je suis désolé de vous
le dire mais quand vous ciblez les
Algériens écrit en gras à la fin de
l'amendement c'est des amendements qui
sont des amendements
racistes monsieur Dumont monsieur Dumont
merci monsieur le Président alors pour
pour pour pour répondre à monsieur le
rapporteur la Russie n'est pas inscrit
dans la liste des pays surûs la Russie
n'est pas membre des pays surûs de
l'OFPRA donc votre exemple est inopérant
sur la question ensuite on a on a une
difficulté on a une difficulté qui est
la difficulté que quand on prend des
pays comme l'Albanie ou la geéorgie on a
une augmentation pour la geéorgie de
plus 104 % des demandeurs d'asile en 3
ans pour l'Albanie plus 21 % ce sont des
PS qui sont dans le top 10 des demandurs
d'asile donc am donné on estime alors
qu'il y a un taux de protection à peine
1 % pour ces pays qu'il faut oui les
garder sous la main parce qu'on sait
qu'il y a des difficultés pour les
retrouver certains ont réussi en
particulier avec Albanie à les renvoyer
pour d'autres c'est un peu plus
compliqué mais il y a pas que la
rétention si on suit ce qui avait été
dit sur les familles on peut aussi très
bien imaginer une résidence surveillée
on peut aussi très bien imaginer une
assignation en résidence ce sont des
dispositifs qui permettent de savoir où
est le demandeur d'asile originaire d'un
pays sûr pour une raison qui est très
simple c'est que nous n'arrivons pas à
juguler les demandes d'asile des
demandeurs issus de pays sûr et on se
retrouve dans une situation parce qu'il
en a de plus en plus on n pas les moyens
en face et donc ça met de plus en plus
longtemps à donner je met merci Monsieur
duumon Je je mets au voix l'amendement
qui vote pour qui vote contre rejeté
amendement 58 monsieur
Lucas défendu monsieur le Président
défendu monsieur Valo
946 défendu madame madame Sebb alors
qu'est-ce qui le défend défendu aussi le
défendu monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour contre rejeter le 770 monsieur
kbrat donc cet amendement propose de
supprimer l'article 19 bis àis sous
couvert de volir éviter les demandes
d'asile abusive cherche à limiter les
pouvoirs d'examen de l'OF pr et comme a
pu le démontrer ma collègueisa Martin
c'est une suite logique qui se produit
avec votre départementalisation
régionalisation de
l'OFPRA la modification apportée par le
droite de sénatorial à l'article L 531
du Code de l'entrée de séjour des
étrangers du droit d'asile oblige l'offa
à clôturer la demande lorsque le
demandeur informe C dernière du retrait
de sa demande en effet avec la procédure
que vous prévoyez de régionalisation et
bien nous prendrons le cap en fait de
détricoter et de casser la possibilité
aux demandeurs d'as de pouvoir demander
l'asile donc nous demandons la
suppression de cet article monsieur le
rapporteur alors défavorable je pense
monsieur car que vous avez pas compris
l'article 19 par que c'est pas du tout à
cela qu'il sert il sert vraiment à
accompagner apporter des
réponses alors il me paraît complètement
légitime que le fra puisse clore en
appréciant chaque situation individuelle
les demandesasil dans les cas très
précis et limitativement énuméré à
l'article l531 38 du C que vous proposez
de supprimer je le mets au voix qui vote
pour contre rejeté le 19 B a qui votre
pour
contre adopté le 19 b b monsieur le
rapporteur
suppression monsieur lucal
59 merci monsieur le Président cet
article prévoit que le rejet définitif
d'une demande d'asile implique une TF et
conduise à l'interruption immédiate de
la prise en charge des soins au titre de
la protection universelle maladie
or or d'après le rapport d'information
du sénateur buffet le taux d'exécution
desqtf en 2021 5,7 % cet article vise
donc à priver de soins des personnes
dont la grande majorité restera sur le
territoire
français les mots me manquent pour dire
là aussi la mesquinerie et l'ignominiie
de cet article adopté au Sénat qui
présente un danger pour la santé la
santé des concerné la santé publique la
dignité des individus et j'allais dire
l'honneur de notre République donc il
nous semble que cet article doiv être
supprimé madame torinia le
768 alors bien sûr on veut la
suppression de de de cet article he
parce qu'on a bien compris l'idée que
comme on est submergé il faut tout de
suite refouler tous les tous les
étrangers qui vont nous env qui vont
nous remplacer et donc là on refuse de
voir s'appliquer une qtf obligatoire et
en plus qui s'accompagnerait de la
suppression automatique de la prise en
charge des soins nous on pense que on en
a toujours pas parlé quand même on
arrive au bout de 5 jours d'examen de ce
texte on na toujours pas vraiment parlé
d'accueil donc on ne parle que de
mesures coercitive
répressive il y a aucun aucun terme
d'accueil et donc donc là encore une
fois il s'agit de prendre soin des gens
qui viennent qui viennent chez nous
monsieur Valo le
suivant oui merci monsieur le Président
très rapidement cet amendement vise à
supprimer cet article pourquoi supprimer
cet article parce que tout le monde est
d'accord c'est pas parce qu'une personne
a un rejet définitif d'une demande
d'asile qu'elle ne doit pas être soignée
et qu'elle ne doit pas être en bonne
santé c'est une mesure de protection
c'est une mesure de protection de
l'humain de l'être humain qui est
derrière cette personne à qui on a
refusé
l'asile le suivant pas défendu monsieur
balanan le
1345fendu défendu voil
madame je crois qu'il
pasfend
1440 défendu et moi j'ai un identique
monsieur rapporteur vous y
étiez allez-y monsieur rapporteur alors
bien entendu je serai favorable mais je
voudrais quand même rappeler parce que
j'ai dit suppression dès le départ et je
crois je pensais avoir plusieurs propos
pour si besoin compléter mais on a en
plus modifié avec l'excellent rapporteur
Philippe Radal tout à l'heure au titre 2
le 14b qui garantit un délai de 3 mois
minimum de maintien des droits de la
Puma donc on aurait été à l'inverse de
ce que nous avions voté déjà ce matin ou
cet après-midi donc on ne pouvait pas
accepter ce volet là et ça pose des
difficultés opérationnelles pour les
services préfectoraux et on ne prend pas
en considération la situation
individuelle et la vulnérabilité des
ressortissants donc pour toutes ces
raisons nous souhaitons le supprimer
donc favorable à l'ensemble des
amendements de suppression alors madame
Martin monsieur Dumont et après non mais
c'était juste une remarque comme ça en
passant mais si j'ai bien compris du
coup si cet article avait été maintenu
ce qui ne va pas être le cas
vraisemblablement il y aura même pas de
recours à la CNDA l'ofre pr dit non
dehors c'est c'est ça l'idée supe ah oui
c'est vrai oui mais on supprime monsieur
Dumont oui merci monsieur le Président
moi je je suis désolé mais c'est cet
article est extrêmement important pour
une raison qui est très simple c'est que
on vit dans une fiction où moins de 50 %
des déboutés de leur demande d'asile par
l'OFPRA et ensuite par la CNDA n'ont pas
deqtf c'est-à-dire que en 2022 il y a eu
74704 demandeurs d'asile qui ont été
déboutés à l'issue de l'appel à la CNDA
et simplement
36980 qui ont reçu une TF c'est-à-dire
qu'on a plus de la moitié des déboutés
on ne sait pas quoi en faire il reste en
France et il se retrouve dans
l'illégalité c'està-dire que votre
projet de loi comme
auparavant ce qui va se passer c'est que
vous n'avez pas le choix entre être
protégé ou être expulsé vous avez le
choix entre être protégé ou devenir
clandestin ça ne peut pas fonctionner il
faut évidemment automatiser automatique
rendre automatique pardon la délivrance
d'une qtf s'il y a décision définitive
de refus de demande c'est
évident je mets au voix les amendements
de suppression qui vote pour qui vote
contre adopter l'article est donc
supprimé on se retrouve à 21h30 pour
peut-être la fin du texte si vous êtes
d'accord